alors on va pouvoir reprendre nos
travaux il est 9h05 tout le monde est
bien installé on retrouve la salle de la
commission des lois et laquelle vous
êtes t attaché madame Toria vous P
commencer par le
821 avec le micro madame
t merci monsieur le Président par cet
amendement nous voulons supprimer les
alinéas 20 à
28 de cet article
9 parce que nous nous sommes contre
l'inflation pénale et donc nous
préférons réduire le quantom de des
peines encouru
euh nous sommes contre l'inflation
pénale nous l'avons toujours toujours
dit notamment parce que ça ne participe
pas non plus à la régulation carcérale
que nous que nous souhaitons
et pour qui va dans le sens de ce que
nous voudrions que soit la d'abord les
conditions les conditions carcérales en
soit puisque la surpopulation carcérale
est un vrai problème et qu'elle est d en
partie à cette inflation pénale voilà
donc monsieur c'est le sens de cet
amendement monsieur valallot le
1076 merci monsieur le président il
s'agit d'un amendement de suppression
des alinéas euh 20 et 29 euh c'est un
amendement qui est suggéré par UNICEF
France et qui vise à réintroduire
l'exigence de motivation particulière
des décisions d'ITF en matière
correctionnelle pour les étrangers
protégés au regard notamment de la
gravité de l'infraction et de la
situation personnelle et familiale de
l'intéressé monsieur le rapporteur vos
avis sur ces
amendement merci Monsieur le président
bonjour à tous donc sur ces deux sur ces
deux amendements 821 et
1076 le Sénat a effectivement supprimé
le régime 10 de protection l'article 131
300-1 cela dit dans son avis du Conseil
des le Conseil d'État dans l'avis qu'il
a rendu a indiqué que les les
dispositions générales du droit
apportaient déjà une une sécurité
suffisante du fait de l'article 132-1 du
code pénal qui prévoit déjà une telle
motivation donc les dispositions du
projet est superfitatoire par rapport à
ces dispositions du code génial c'est
pour cela que j'ai met un avis
défavorable à ces deux amendements qui
euh crée je dirais une enfin qui
n'apporte pas à l'état du droit quelque
chose de de suffisant et nous proposons
de maintenir la déclaration du Sénat
d'où l'avis défavorable que j'ai met
concernant le l'aspect spécifique des
ITF que vous venez d'évoquer ce que je
vous propose puisqueeffectivement là il
y a une difficulté qu'il convient de
régler c'est si vous l'accepter de
retirer votre amendement et de vous
rallier à celui qui a été présenté par
Monsieur le Président Houlier sous le
numéro
1680 pardon l'excellent amendement du
président Houlier comme le dit la
rapporteur
généralsieur V la confiance n'exclut pas
le maintien de mon amendement et
évidment l'intention du législateur si
vous acceptez que le Sénat retiré avec
les intention qui sont celles des
sénateurs qui n'étai pas très
bienveillante moi je préfère une
sécurité supplémentaire la suppression
de ces deux
aliné alors je vais mettre au voie
l'amendement 821 de madame Martin qui
vare pour contre rejeté le 1076 de
Monsieur vot pour contre
rejeté le 1601 est tombé
et c'est donc le 1680 qui est le mien
alors le 1680 il vise à rétablir une
version du gouvernement sur la question
du quantum de peine éligible
pour mettre une enfin pour décider d'une
ITF interdiction du territoire France
français un quantum de peine qui serait
prévu à 10 ans une peine de pass
possible de 10 ans pour les étrangers
qui ser en serait la première infaction
et puis à 5 ans en état de récidive et
c'est aussi pour protéger la mesure
d'une éventuelle censure puisque il
s'agit de là de préserver les
proportionnalités des peines qui serait
celle prononcé et susceptible d'ouvrir
droit de faitte à une ITF dans le cadre
de la double peine que nous
construisons
rapporteur bien sûr avis favorable pour
la raison exposée auss avant
je mets au voix qui vote pour qui vote
contre il est adopté alors ensuite on
avait toute une série d'amendements qui
étaient tombés hier par les fa des
amendements l'adoption des amend
précédents le 825 avait été tombé le 473
aussi le 389 également le 807 aussi 417
alors ils tombent tous jusqu'au
1728 ce qui est aussi le mien que je
vous présente dans une toute petite
minute il est pas il est pas interdit
d'être malin
monsieur là là il s'agit de de tirer les
conséquences de du précédent amendement
que que je vous ai fait adopter
également de modifier les modifications
apportées par le Sénat au régime de
protection contre la prononcée d'une
peine d'ITF qui avait été profondément
modifié par le Sénat et qui sont
susceptibles de recours avant même de
trouver application si nous les
adoptions en l'état le 1728 votre avis
monsieur le rapporteur avis favorable il
est nécessaire pour établir l'équilibre
et privé du risque de contestation
constitutionnel je le mets au voix qui
vote pour qui vote contre il est adopté
et enfin le dernier c'est également une
mesure pour réformer le quantum des
peenes donc le miroir de celui que je
vous ai fait adopter le 1680 c'est le
1681 que je vous présente également
monsieur le rapport votre avis favorable
amendement de cohérence qui vote pour
qui vote contre il est adopté j'en vient
donc au vote de l'article 9 qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est adopté après
l'article 9 monsieur pojet vous avez la
parole pour l'amendement 130
oui merci président l'amendement que je
vous propose précise que la demande de
réexamen d'une interdiction
administrative sur le territoire
français ne peut intervenir avant 10
années alors qu'elle est actuellement de
5 ans lorsqu'elle a été prononcée pour
une infraction à caractère terroriste ou
alors lorsqu'il s'agit d'une atteinte
aux intérêts fondamentaux de la nation
je vous remercie monsieur le
rapporteur avis défavorable puisque la
la lecture euh combinée à la fois de
l'amendement des disposion de l'article
632-6 du czda prévoit effectivement que
le réexamen est fait avec une
périodicité satisfaisante pour permettre
à l'autorité administrative d'apprécier
dans les situations que vous avez
décrites et qui sont des situations
graves monsieur poet la la situation de
l'étranger de l'éventuelle abrogation de
la décision d'expulsion c'est pourquoi
j'ai met un avis
défavorable monsieur
Poget merci j'entends Mons le rapporteur
mais rien aujourd'hui c'est bloqué à 5
ans et si on veut étendre la durée il me
semble que pour les faits de terrorisme
et nous dans les Alpes Maritimes on est
bien placé pour le savoir de rallonger
la période à 10 ans avant de pouvoir
prononcer une nouvelle ITF ça me semble
quelque chose de bon sens
merci bien je mets au voie votre
amendement monsieur Poget qui vote pour
qui vote contre
rejeté le 1129 alors je sais pas s'il
est défendu non il n'est pas défendu le
1560 1524 madame jeevard oui merci
Monsieur le le président
alors le présent amendement du groupe
les républicains vise à redonner son
sens à l'effectivité de la peine
prononcée par le juge du fond et à
lutter contre l'immigration des
individus qui ne respectent pas les lois
de la République à ce titre il apparaît
totalement anormal qu'une décision
judiciaire définitive d'interdiction du
territoire français pour un criminel ou
un délinquant étranger puisse être
annulé par un juge d'application des
peines dans le cadre d'une libération
conditionnelle ou qu'un aménagement de
peine vienne à l'encontre contre des
décisions d'interdiction du territoire
ou d'obligation de quitter le territoire
je vous
remercie monsieur le
rapporteur allez merci Madame madame je
de du dépôt de cet amendement et de et
de l'argumentaire que que vous présentez
effectivement comme on peut le voir pour
d'autres amendements par cet amendement
vous souhaitez empêcher de façon
systématique au au JLD en l'occurrence
mais parfois d'autres magistrats le
prononcer de tout aménagement de peine à
l'exception de libération conditionnelle
euh cette disposition n'est pas conforme
à l'état de notre droit puisque la
décision 2019 799 et 800 rendu sous
forme de de QPC le 6 décembre 2019 par
le Conseil constitutionnel a prévu
expressément ce cas alors pour pour dire
les choses rapidement et ne pas avoir
àer aller redire peut-être lorsque
d'autres sujets je crois que lorsqu'on
parle des décisions du Conseil
constitutionnel une modif ication de la
Constitution ne réglerait pas forcément
intégralement les décisions et ne
n'abolirait pas l'ensemble des décisions
du Conseil constitutionnel puisque cette
décision est notamment fondée sur des
principes généraux du droit qui vont
bien au-delà du texte de la Constitution
de 1958 et notamment la question de la
proportionnalité et rattacher notamment
la Déclaration des droits de l'homme et
du citoyen comme a pu l'indiquer le le
président à plusieurs reprises et c'est
pour cela que en l'état de sa
nonconformité donc du risque
d'inconstitutionnalité fort que
présenterait l'adoption de cet
amendement je mets un avis
défavorable monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le Président
saluant la commission des lois madameard
on s'est posé la la double même question
que que vous et on a eu le même la même
réponse que monsieur le rapporteur pour
un dispositif qui pourrait ressembler à
votre amendement mais du coup on a fait
les choses différemment de deux manières
la première vous évoquez finalement la
question de la libération conditionnelle
ou d'aménagement de peine qui n'est
possible que pour les étrangers que pour
les Français qui évidemment sortant de
prison veulent
ou doivent se réintégrer à la société
française ce qui n'est pas la vocation
de l'étranger qui lui doit quitter le
territoire national si on part du
principe qu'il a commis un crime ou un
délit qui relève de l'article 9 ou de
l'article 10 tel qu'on l'a imaginé et
donc nous avons créé avec le Sénat un
sur proposition du gouvernement un
article 9 bis que vous avez dû voir qui
est la libération sous contrainte qui
correspond exactement au principe de la
liberté conditionnelle pour s'insérer
autant l'étranger autant le français
délinquant doit s'insérer dans la
société après sa peine de prison autant
l'étranger délinquence il a commis
quelque chose de grave qu' l' amené à
une peine de prison sans doute que il a
donc commis quelque chose de grave s'il
en est un de la prison ferme et bien
d'aller vers la la conditionnalité de
son départ c'est le départ c'est c'est
c'est pas le départ de la prison c'est
directement le CRRA puis ensuite donc ça
cet article 9 B répond à une grande
partie de votre amendement deuxième
parti autrement c'est finalement ce que
disait monsieur Pradal sur le régime du
juge des libertés et de la détention
alors là pour le coup vous l'urez
constaté la Constitution prévoit
explicitement le travail du juge de
liberté de la détention et comme a très
bien dit Monsieur le le rapporteur par
ailleurs comme on modifierit la
constition sur ce point
incontestablement dans la Déclaration
des droits de l'hommes du citoyens dans
le préembule de 46 il y a les moyens
pour pouvoir donner au juges liberté de
la détention même réformé par la
constitution des moyens de de de de
constater la la la grande
inconstitutionnalité votre proposition
cependant nous on a fait des
propositions de modification du régime
du JLD et notamment le fait sil y a des
article sur ce point qui vont nous
interpeller à mon avis pendant un bon
moment avec la partie gauche de
l'hémicycle pour notamment mettre que le
JLD n'est plus simplement un juge qui va
regarder la procédure mais qui va
regarder la dangerosité des personnes et
nous avons inséré dans l'idée de la
décision du JLD le fait qu'il devait
prendre en considération la dangerosité
des personnes donc là on parle bien des
étrangers c'est bien ce que vous
souhaitez et que com bien même il y aura
une nudité de procédure constaté la PAF
qui est oublié un cacher la difficulté
d'éloigner une personne à un KPI qui ne
veut qu' a des pas des pont t de retour
et bien nous introduisons quelque chose
de nouveau qui est le fait que Ben le
juge de libertétion ne peut libérer
cette personne du fait de des décisions
d'aujourd'hui puisque aujourd'hui c'est
notre problème principal on va dire
puisque en moyenne si les gens doivent
pouvoir rester jusqu 3 mois dans un cras
il y reste 34 jours parce que libéré par
le JD notamment au tout début de la
procédure et ça c'est une difficulté
évidemment très important on l' évoqué
hier avec les interventions on introduit
donc l'idée de dangerosité dans la
décision du juge de liberté de détention
qui répond me semble à une autre partie
de votre amendement alors c'est vrai
qu'il rond totalement à l'amendement
pour des raisons constitutionnelles
qu'on a évoqué mais je pense que le 9
bis répond totalement à la question de
l'étranger qui a une aménagement de
peine et entre nous trouv tout à fait ça
scandaleux comme vous et c'est pour ça
qu'on change la loi de la République et
il nous paraît tout à fait
constitutionnel en re compromis avec le
Sénat et en revanche sur la question du
JLD on va jusqu'au plus qu'on peut faire
aujourd'hui et quand je vous dis ça je
ne suis pas tout à fait certain que nous
ayons tous les armes aujourd'hui dans la
Constitution pour permettre de le faire
on aura l'occasion de parler dans not
PPL constitutionnel de savoir comment on
peut euh mettre tout en gardant
évidemment la possibilité d'un juge
indépendant et la séparation des
pouvoirs le caractère de dangerosité
dans les décisions prises en la liberté
des détorion sachant que le CR n'est pas
un lieu de punissement en attendant une
décision c'est un lieu de de de
rétention en attendant une expulsion
voilà ce qui évidemment euh et et n'est
pas n'est pas si facile que ça à définir
donc un avis défavorable mais sur le
fond je pense qu'il est très largement
satisfait par les deux dispositifs qu'on
verra plus tard madame fossillon merci
monsieur le Président bon dans les faits
aujourd'hui très concrètement 90 %
quasiment des étrangers pour lesquels on
demande une un aménagement de peine ne
l'obtiennent pas ceux qui l'obtiennent
la plupart du temps ce sont ceux qui
sont qu' ont le plus fort potentiel en
fait de régularisation euh donc ça ça
existe moi la question que que je me
pose qui mort peut-être un peu sur sur
l'article suivant c'est que en réalité
on le voit aujourd'hui quasiment 30 %
des personnes qui sont en cras sont déjà
des sortants de
prison et et en réalité la demande de
laisser passer consulaire elle
n'intervient qu'une fois qu'ils sont en
cras pas quand ils sont en prison donc
la LSC en réalité on leur refuse en
disant ça permet quelque part de de
mettre tout de suite en route leur leur
expulsion ce qui n'est pas la réalité
donc on les prive d'une LSC tout en en
les laissant finalement plus longtemps
encra et vous venez de le dire ce n'est
pas censé être un lieu de punissement
même si aujourd'hui dans les faits çaen
est souvent un et tout en sachant qu'en
réalité le parcours du laisser passer
consulaire ne débute pas avant l'arrivée
encra monsieur ministre ouis très
rapidement parce qu'on aura se débat
plus tard mais je dire madame la députée
que ce qu'elle dit était vrai me semble-
jusqu'en 2021 j'ai pris en 2021 une
instruction pour que lorsque les
étrangers sont en prison notamment après
le drame que de ce photographe qui a été
molesté à reins je sais pas si vous vous
en rappelez qui
était un sortant de de prison dont on ne
connaissait pas l'identité puisque cette
personne était irrégulière et dont
l'identité était pas connu il y a des
gens en prison dont on ne connaît pas
totalement l'identité y compris la
nationalité c'est ainsi j'ai donc
demandé une instruction commune avec le
garde des sauts pour que 6 mois avant la
libération alors tout ça n'est pas
parfait puisquil y a toujours un un juge
évidemment qui peut permettre une
libération anticip mais 6 mois avant
libération on face sa demande de laisser
passer consulaire donc aujourd'hui c'est
moins le cas est-ce que vous évoqué
madame la députée est beaucoup est
beaucoup moins vrai la deuxième des
choses c'est que la libération sous
contrainte c'est exactement répond à
cette question après est-ce qu'on est
d'accord ou pas pour que les étrangers
qui ont fait des peines de prison
doivent être expulsés c'est un autre
débat politique mais en tout cas la
libération sous contrainte qui est le 9
bis c'est on ne libère pas la personne
de manière anticipée si on n pas laissé
passer consulaire donc ça c'est vraiment
un article très important pour notre
fonctionnement général et puis
troisièmement les centre de rétention
administratif vous le savez bien en tout
cas c'est vraiment la marque de
l'arrivée au ministère de l'Intérieur de
de de de équip du du président de la
République c'est le fait qu'on y mette
désormais à 97 % hormi maotte 97 % des
personnes qui sont soit radicalisées
soit condamné par la justice qui était
pas le cas auparavant il n'y a que 3
person de gens qui TR personnes 3 % de
personnes encas au moment où je vous
parle qui n'ont qui n'ont pas de casier
judiciaire donc aujourd'hui il y a par
exemple quasiment plus d'enfants dans
les cras on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler pour que ce soit la loi de la
République donc je pense qu'on a changé
le modèle d'cra et si ce n'est pas des
lieux de de détention supplément ent
c'est des lieux de rétention de
personnes dangereuses malgré tout et on
aura l'occasion de voir qu'on change le
régime de sec dans les moments qui
viennent je me VO l'amendement de Madame
jeunevard avec un avis défavorable du
rapporteur qui vote pour qui vote contre
rejeté le 774 madame
tia
merci par cette par cet amendement nous
souhaitons donc supprimer cet article
qui a été rajouté
par le Sénat qui durcit encore plus
évidemment le le le texte initial et qui
donne une vision raciste comme tout tout
le texte de toute façon mais encore plus
de manière
prignante puisque il envisage de
euh
accorder ne pas accorder précisément les
mêmes droits au euh au détenus français
et aux justiciables étrangers la
sanction pénale a précisément pour but
de réhabiliter l'auteur d'une infraction
et lui permettre son insertion dans la
société qu'il s'agisse d'un citoyen
français ou bien d'un étranger et nous
nous opposons donc à cette vision
raciste de l'exécutif qui part du
principe qu'un étranger condamné qui a
purgé sa peine constitue par nature une
menace pour l'ordre public et un danger
pour
mon
oui merci Monsieur le le Président c'est
un amendement en effet qui était du
gouvernement qui était rajouté au Sénat
qui est qui n'a pas été soumis à la vie
du Conseil d'État ni présent dans
l'étude d'impact et qui au fond ignore
l'objet de la de la libération sous
contrainte qui est un instrument de
lutte contre la récidive hier nous avons
évoqué les cas de récidives multiples
auquel se heurtait dans l'exécution
ensuite de mesures d'éloignement ou
d'expulsion pour pour être plus précis
euh le ministère de de l'intérieur et
donc il nous paraît que c'est un un un
détournement de de de d'un d'un objet
euh de politique pénale euh à mauvaise
ession madame fossillon
oui merci monsieur le Président je je
partage l'argument qui consiste à dire
que c'est un un un détournement d'un
d'un dispositif pénal à des fins de de
contrôle migratoire il me semble aussi
que en réalité euh se
priver d'un élément d'un dispositif
pénal qui permet
aujourd'hui de tenter de réinsérer mieux
quelqu'un dans la société mais surtout
de lutter par ce faitl contre la
récidive en a'ayant jamais l'assurance
que la personne va être expulsée puisque
là vous condamnez toute personne qui
sort étrangère qui sort de prison à
bénéficier de cette libération sous
contrainte qui est quand même le moment
où on va dire les spipes interviennent
le plus auprès d'eux euh et oui mais en
situation irrégulière vous ne savez pas
s'il sera s'il sera expulsé vous ne le
savez pas donc en fait ce que vous vous
prenez le risque d'avoir quelqu'un sur
le territoire qui en réalité n'a pas
bénéficié euh de la période la plus
intense euh de euh la lutte contre la
récidive franchement je au-delà de
idéologiquement est-ce qu'on est
d'accord ou pas en terme de sécurité
intérieure je vois pas le je vois pas le
bénéfice monsieur le rappteur au
contraire dans ces trois amendements
vous a supprimer les dispositions
introduites sous l'article 9 B par
amendement gouvernemental au Sénat alors
de qui parle-t-on rapidement on parle de
gens qui sont en situation irrégulière
qui n'ont pas vocation à rester sur le
territoire et qui pourrai bénéficier en
application de la loi du 22 décembre
2021 du régime de la libération sous
contrainte cet article 9 bis il vise à
établir le fait que la libération sous
contrainte ne peut être mise en œuvre
que pour permettre l'expulsion c'est
pourquoi j'ai met un avis défavorable à
ces trois amendements de suppression par
rapport à cette mesure utile mon
rapporteur général oui pardon juste un
mot parce que j'entends madame torignha
parfois même monsieur Lucas mais euh
parler de de racisme je voulais vous
réveiller mon cher Lucas je sentais que
on y était pas non mais j'entends
j'entends l'argument de principe là
Infiné toujours le dernier ultime le
racisme mais madame torignha je pense
que vous n'avez pas compris les
dispositions de comprend très bien mais
je vais vous l'expliquer quand même
parce que je suis pas
sûr il y a aujourd'hui un alors me
traitez pas de raciste madame d'accord
si si vous vous considérez si si Madame
voilà donc moi je veux bien qu'on se
respecte vous traitez la majorité le
ministre la majorité présidentielle de
raciste et quand je vous dis vous n'avez
pas compris vous trouvez ça IR
respectueux plaisantez ou quoi alors moi
je vous explique l'article 9 B l'article
9 B madame c'est pas méprisant le
racisme c'est pas une insulte c'est
leexte laissez-moi parler madame
l'article 9 bis l'article 9 bis madame
torignia il prévoit la libération sous
contrainte en tout cas le droit commun
aujourd'hui c'est la libération sous
contrainte est prévue pour les nationaux
comme vous l'avez dit en en effet il est
prévu aussi pour les personnes
étrangères en situation régulière rien
n'est prévu pour la situation des
étrangers en en irrégularité et donc
nous alignons qu'il y'y a pas de raciste
de distinction entre les nationaux et
les non nationaux c'est le contraire on
fait le droit commun pour tout le monde
de façon monsieur rapporteur Pradal l'a
dit à ce que nous puissions ensuite
permettre l'exécution de l'éloignement
en s'appuyant sur un certain nombre de
d'éléments qui sont les interdictions de
territoire les interdictions de séjours
qui correspondent à des faits qui ont
été commis pas n'importe lesquels je
vous renvoie notamment aux dispositions
du Code pénal qui s'y
réfèrre par ailleurs sauf erreur de ma
part c'est la une législation qui porte
sur jusqu'à là une instruction qui avait
une instruction commune du ministre de
la Justice et ministre de l'Intérieur
pour que on limite les libérations sous
contraines au fait que les expulions
soient mis en uvre monsieur le ministre
tout à fait monsieur le Président de la
Commission des des lois moi je veux dire
l'importance de cet article pourquoi
parce que la loi pour la confiance dans
l'institution judiciaire que vous avez
avait voté qui du 29 décembre 2021
permet au détenus de bénéficier d'une
libération anticipée sous contrainte de
plat droit lorsqu'il peuvent purger un
relicat de prison de 3 mois dans le
cadre de l'exécution d'une d'une peine
de prison euh ça c'est vrai pour les
Français c'est vrai pour les étrangers
en sitation régulière qui ne
rentreraient pas s coup de l'article 9
ou l'article 10 imaginons des gens qui
ont été condamnés à des peines de moins
de 2 ans de prison bon mais c'est pas
vrai des irréguliers et la libération
sous conditionnel sous contraint
pour
réinsertion c'est vrai pour ceux qui ont
intérêt à se réinsérer dans la société
mais les irréguliers n'ont pas intérêt à
se réinsérer dans la société qui plusé
lorsqu'ils ont été condamnés de façon
définitive à des peines de prison donc
on peut quand même SAF sauf si on part
du principe qu'il faut insérer des
personnes irrégulière qui par ailleurs
ont été condés de façon définitive et
qui ont exercé des peines de prison donc
il y a là pour le coup je dis à Monsieur
Valot le Conseil constitutionnel Conseil
d'État reconnaît largement que d'abord
le droit au séjour n'est pas un droit
général et absolu fort heureusement et
qu' a une différence de traitement
évidemment proportionné possible entre
deux personnes dans des situations
différentes et dans un but d'intérêt
général là il y a deux personnes qui ont
des situation différent un qui est
irrégulier l'autre qui est régulier ou
qui est français et il y a un but
d'intérêt général c'est un criminel ou
un un auteur de délit et donc il faut
pouvoir s'en éloigner la difficulté
c'est que la loi que vous avez adopté et
c'est pour ça qu'on vous propose cet
article la loi que vous avez adopté
depuis le 1er janvier connaît des
difficultés pour les services
pénitentiaires et pour les services de
la police au frontière pour éloigner des
personnes puisqu'il y a des Y a donc des
libérations anticipées qui sont pas
forcément prévues pour lequel
effectivement elle vient contraré
l'instruction qu'on a pu prendre avec
monsieur le garde des saau et c'est très
important la préfecture de la Dordogne
par exemple dans un petit département
comme la Dordogne cette année son 88
étrangers éloignable 27 font partie du
public des de l'administration
pénitentiaire qui ont commis des crimes
ou des délits et qui sont éligibles de
plein droit à une d'expulsion dans des
pays qui acceptent madame fossillon leur
ressortissant 27/ 88 à expulsé c'est
quand même important et c'est notamment
le cas du préfet de Saint maritime
préfet sa qui m'a encore écrit très
récemment donc pour éviter les sorties
sèches de détenus irréguliers qu'on ne
pourrait pas reconduire dans leur pays
les mettre dans les centres de rétention
administratif dans leur pays cet article
est très important puisqu'il permet de
faire un lien direct entre étrangers
irrégulier condamnés en prison centre de
rétention administratif retour dans leur
pays d'origine parce qu'ils n'ont pas
vocation à s'intégrer dans la société
française ils ont eux-mêmes parce qu'ils
sont irréguliers d'E part et parce
qu'ils ont été condamnés à des peines de
prison autre part montrer qu'il ne
voullait pas s'intégrer à la société
française alors j'ai monsieur Lucas
merci monsieur le Président oui
rapidement parce que le rapporteur
général m'a mis en cause de façon assez
gratuite simplement lui dire que moi
j'ai toujours su prendre mes
responsabilités d'ailleurs monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur était présent
sur une liste à des élections régionales
pour laquelle j'ai appelé à voter pour
faire barrage à l'extrême droite raciste
justement choix que je non mais à
l'époque j'étais dans l'au de France
Monsieur le Ministre et j'ai appelé à
voter pour la liste de Monsieur
Bertrand face à Madame Le Pen pour
empêcher que l'extrêmeite raciste ne
prenne une région et je prends toujours
mes responsabilités pour le barrage
républicain je je dénonce en revanche un
racisme d'atmosphère don j'estime que
vous l'entretenez à travers ce texte qui
amène à ce que le débat public soit
englouti sous les thèmes et les termes
de l'extrême droite et je crois que
c'est extrêmement mortifère pour notre
démocratie donc je n'ai jamais dit que
le rapporteur le ministre le
gouvernement était raciste je je
j'assume en revanche de dire que le
débat public tel qu'il est organisé il
suffit d'ouvrir les réseaux sociaux
d'allumer sa télévision pour voir qu'il
contribue à un racisme d'atmosphère
extrêmement dommageable je crois pour
notre démocratie et les principes
républicains donct j'espère qu'il
devrait qu' qu'il pourrait nous
rassembler alors je mets au voix les
amendements de suppression qui votent
pour qui votent contre ils sont rejetés
je me vois l'article 9 bis qui vote pour
qui vote contre il est adopté l'article
10 l'amendement 776 madame torign merci
monsieur le Président alors moi je veux
je veux redire que on ne peut ne pas
avoir les mêmes avis sans pour autant
expliquer à celui qui n'est pas du même
avis que vous que il ne comprends pas je
comprends très bien je comprends très
bien et c'est bien pour ça parce que je
comprends très bien que je m'oppose
fermement à ce texte et que je demande
la suppression par cet amendement je
demande la suppression de cet article 10
qui réduit en fait
les les la la protection
e des des étrangers contre les décisions
d'obligation de quitter le territoire
français plus
fondamentalement c'est l'esprit de tout
ce texte qui amalgame l'immigration à la
délinquence c'est ça qui est dans le
cœur de ce texte et c'est pour ça que je
dis que ce texte est raciste et je ne
suis pas la seule à le dire toutes les
associations qui viennent en soutien à
ces personnes qui ont eu des parcours
tragiques pour quitter leur pays parce
que ils se soucient de leur survie
toutes ces associations disent avec moi
que ce texte est raciste et elle le
monsieur Vallot vous enfermez
madame hier on a une discussion qu'on
poursuivra dans l'hémicycle je pense de
façon plus plus construite et plus
approfondi mais je disis qu'il y avait à
mon sens un problème
d'équilibre pardon ah pardon non
voilà vous m'avez perdre le fil je vous
remercie d'équilibre d'équilibre général
en entre dans dans les
dispositifs proposés par par le par le
gouvernement et parmi les les
déséquilibres il y a à mon sens cette
confusion entre les les mesures
d'expulsion et les mesures d'éloignement
et ce cette cette confusion me paraît
dangereuse est introduit la notion grave
de sécurité publique la nécessité
impérieuse pour la sûreté d'étable
sécurité publique qui sont évidemment
des notions au contour difficile à
appréhander et elle présente le risque
ou l'avantage selon de contourner les
garanties procédurales qui sont liées à
l'expulsion puisque ce ne sont pas ce ne
sont pas les mêmes pu par ailleurs rien
n'indique que le nombre de laissés
passer consulair l'effectivité ou
l'augmentation du taux de de reconduite
d'expulsion serait augmenté
euh madame
fossillon je suis désolé merci un
amendement de de suppression parce que
nous ne souhaitons pas voir évoluer un
système de de de protection générale et
objective vers un système partial qui
est soumis à à une appréciation
subjective au cas par cas de de
l'administration on pense qu'il y a un
risque fort d'arbitraire et d'atteinte
au droit au respect de la à la vie
privée et familiale à l'intérêt
supérieur de l'enfant on pense également
que c'est un risque d'accroître le
contentieux administratif puisque les
personnes étrangères soumises qui vont
faire l'objet de d'une d'une qtf
pourrait quand même s'opposer à à à ces
mesures sur le fondement du respect des
engagements internationaux de de la
France je parlais intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant qu'est-ce qui se passe quand on
éloigne des parents qui ont des enfants
par exemple ici prise en charge par
laaz monsieur le
rapporteur mer merci monsieur le
Président donc sur ces amendements de de
suppression avis défavorable cet article
10 qui a été modifié par le Sénat
demeure quand même équilibré même poste
rédaction du Sénat parce qu'en fait par
son alinée à 5 est maintenu un certain
équilibre je rappelle que l'équilibre
général de de cet article 10 vise à
atténuer les protections dont bénéficie
l'étranger en matière d'qtf et
l'équilibre est maintenu puisque
l'alinéa 5 précise que l'autorité admin
adistrative doit toujours veiller à
conserver l'équilibre entre l'impératif
d'une mesure d'éloignement visée
notamment par cet article et celui de
tenir compte de la situation personnelle
de l'étranger concerné tout ceci bien
sûr sous le contrôle du juge c'est
pourquoi je pense que dans sa rédaction
initiale bien sûr mais également dans sa
rédaction sortie du Sénat C article 10
est nécessaire dans le cadre de
l'équilibre général de la loi et j'ai
met un avis défavorable à l'égard de ces
amendements de suppression madame
Rousseau
i en fait la question c'est euh
l'appréciation euh qui est faite de la
situation de chaque de chaque mineur et
en fait là il il y a une part
d'arbitraire c'est ce qu'on dénonce
depuis le début de ce texte c'està-dire
que c'est un texte qui donne plus de
place à l'arbitraire et qui donne moins
de place à euh des lignes de droit qui
nous permettraient d'avoir des recours
très simples et une application très
simple de la loi donc en fait pour cette
raison-là nous soutiendrons les les
amendements de suppression parce que
précisément quand il s'agit de mineur
nous devons plus encore que pour les
adultes être extrêmement euh strict
monsieur le ministre oui madame rousseo
pardon mais il s'agit pas de mineur non
non il y a pas de mineur concerné là
dans l'article non non non non il y a
pas de mineur concerné là on parle des
majeurs voilà donc non non c'est c'est
non mais faut faut qu'on explicite le
texte l'article 9 et l'article 10
concerne les majeurs la seule réserve d'
publique que nous gardons justement
c'est les mineurs qui commettraient des
délits ou des crimes pendant qu'ils sont
mineurs voilà donc après les majeurs
dans leur vie une fois qu'ils sont
arrivés mineurs sur le territoire
national et une fois qu'ils sont majeurs
sur le territoire national quand ils
commettent des CRIM et des délits ils
sont sous régime de la majorité pas sous
régime de la minorité donc on t on parle
pas des mineurs dans dans ce texte bien
évidemment je rappelle que d'ailleurs
les mineurs c'est le juge qui décide de
leur expulsion du territoire national
c'est pas le pouvoir administratif alors
que cette article 10 il est très
important c'est sans doute un des plus
importants avec l'article 9 de ce projet
de loi qui vise vous l'avez compris donc
à pouvoir éloigner appliquer davantage
et beaucoup mieux les les les arrêtés de
reconduite à la frontière du fait des
protections que la loi et pas la
constitution ou la convention nous
applique l'article 9 c'était les
étrangers qui pouvaient régulier être
expulsés du territoire national pour une
menace à l'ordre public l'article 10 ce
sont des
irréguliers qui malgré la menace qu'il
représent pour le territoire national ne
peuvent pas être éloignés de l'ordre de
du territoire national pardon parce
qu'il y a des réserves d'ordre public ce
qu'on appelait Jadice les réserves de la
fin de la fin de la double peine donc
les dispositions qui aujourd'hui sont
dans la loi et qui nous nous empêche de
de de de d'éloigner ces personnes
d'appliquer les eqtf c'est tous les
étrangers qui résident en France depuis
l'âge de ces 13 ans l'étranger résident
en France régulièrement depuis 10 ans
l'étranger en France régulièrement
depuis 20 ans l'étranger parent d'un
enfant français s'il peut prouver qu'il
contribue à l'entretien et l'éducation
de ses enfants l'étranger conjoint de
français l'étranger résidant
régulièrement en France depuis 10 ans
l'étranger titulaire d'une rente
d'accident de travail une maladie
professionnelle et l'étranger résidant
habituellement en France et dans dans
l'état de santé nécessité prend une
charge médicale à défaut qui peut
entraîner des des conséquences donc nous
proposons que nous puissions appliquer
les eqtf pour toutes ces personnes si et
seulement si il s'agit pas de
l'appliquer pour les personnes qui n'ont
commis aucun acte illégal sur le
territoire national quelqu'un qui est
arrivé avant l'âge de 13 ans qui est
irrégulier à 19 ans le texte ne prévoit
pas de l'éloigner ce que prévoit le
texte c'est si quelqu'un est arrivé
avant l'âge de 13 ans et qu'à 19 ans il
a été auteur de crime permettre de
l'éloigner voilà c'est le comportement
de la personne c'est pour ça ce texte
est fondamentalement pas raciste il
s'intéresse au comportements il
s'intéresse pas aux personnes il
s'intéresse à ce qu'ils font pas à ce
qu'ils sont c'est ça le racisme le
racisme madame la députée c'est de
s'intéresser aux gens pour ce qu'ils
sont pas par leur comportement voilà
heureusement il y a des personnes qui
sont jugées pour ceux qu'ils font c'est
le principe de la démocratie et pas pour
ceux qu'ils sont ceux qu'ils sont c'est
l'essentialisme là on n'est pas
essentialiste donc le fait est vous vous
l'êtes quand vous dites par nature nous
sommes racistes alors que moi je vous
dis c'est le comportement qui fait
quelqu'un est raciste mais c'est
peut-être une différence d'près
assciation de ce qu'elom finalement donc
le le le ce texte est très important
parce que il vise à pouvoir appliquer
ces eqtf moi je veux dire dans ce débat
sur les eqtf c'est un débat un peu un
peu fou puisquon demande au mis
inérieurs d'appliquer les eqtf très bien
d'une part plus de la moitié d'entre eux
sont soumis à des recours donc on peut
pas les appliquer ce sera ce qu'on verra
dans le titre 3 4 et 5 tout à l'heure
avec Monsieur mendz mais deuxièmement la
moitié de cestf par ailleurs l'autre
moitié la loi m'empêche de les appliquer
notamment la loi qui a été à voter au
début des années des années 2000 j'ai
plusieurs exemples évidemment de
possibilités je prends l'exemple d'une
lettre que m'aenvoyé le préfet de la cô
d'or le 15 novembre 2023 donc c'était
voilà quelques jours prenant l'exemple
d'un d'un ressortissant qui est
aujourd'ui sous le coup d'une qtf qui a
plus de 100 condamnations judiciaaires
il a 29 ans il est arrivé avant l'âge de
13 ans sur le territoire national il a
cumulé des peines prononcées pour un
total de 31 ans et aujourd'hui il ne
peut pas être éloigné du territoire
national alors qu'il est irrégulier
parce qu'il est arrivé à 12 ans sur le
territoire national alors que sa famille
habite dans son pays d'origine bon je
vais évidemment pas faire la la liste
très nombreuse qui existent dans l'tude
d'impact des besoins de cette mesure là
encore nul besoin de réformer la
Constitution nul besoin de réformer la
CEDH ou les engagements internationaux
de la France seule la France a ces
dispositifs qui nous empêche d'éloigner
des étrangers qui sont déjà irréguliers
vous l'avez compris et qui relèvent donc
bien sûr de mon souhait de voir ces
amendements de suppression
rejetés
Martin merci sur l'affaire en tant que
tel des des
OQTF qui doivent évidemment se faire
c'est comme ça nous on doit on doit
trouver les équilibres et vérifier que
l'État de droit surtout dans notre pays
est effectivement une réalité depuis je
pense à peu près
1995 et ces fameuses lois immigr en
moyenne prise tous les 18 mois on met
tour de vis sur tour de vis et et et
l'équilibre et l'équilibre se brise
d'autant plus à chacune à chacune des
étapes nous ça nous ça nous donne à
penser que il faut absolument changer de
stratégie et à la fois bon ça je pense
que chacun l'a compris travailler sur
les questions d'organisation de
l'accueil à l'échelle de l'Europe à
l'échelle du du pays évidemment mais
aussi avoir une réflexion sur ce qui se
passe autour des otf qui sont à la fois
inopérante puisque une une extrême
minorité réalisée si on va dans votre
logique et et ensuite qui qui qui ne
permettent pas par la même de rétablir
l'ordre si ces personnes sont
effectivement à l'origine du désordre
donc on a un double un double problème
si je
alors madame jeunevard
pardon oui merci monsieur le Président
en effet c'est ces deux articles le 9 et
le 10 sont extrêmement importants ils
permettent l'éloignement des personnes
en situation régulière ou irrégulière
ayant commis des des délits ou des
crimes graves j'attire votre attention
monsieur le ministre sur le fait qu'à
l'article que l'article 4 B permet de
régulariser dans les métiers en tenstion
des personnes situation irrégulière même
si elles ont commis des infractions
pénales donc si je résume au cas de BIS
on régularise au 10 on éloigne ce n'est
pas
cohérent monsieur le
ministre oui oui après vous pas alors je
ferai remarquer madame jeunevard que
d'une part cet article 10 modifié par le
Sénat sur proposition du gouvernement
n'a pas été remodifiée par l'Assemblée
nationale c'est donc la rédaction du
Sénat que nous vous reproposons comme
vous l'a dit monsieur le rapporteur
deuxièmement je regrette du coup que
vous n'z pas déposé d'amendement pour
participer à la construction du CAD bis
comme l'a fait le Sénat parce qu'on
aurait très bien pu prendre cet
amendement et nous avons constaté que
s'il y avait une question de
compatibilité avec l'ordre publique
prévu déjà dans le CAD bis expressis
verbis il n'est pas écrit ceux qui avent
un casier judiciaire ne peuvent pas être
régularisés c'est chose quelque chose
qu'on peut faire en en séance selon le
degré évidemment du casier judiciaire s
s'agit d'un dél routier encore une fois
je pense qu'on peut constater que
l'excès de vitesse n'empêche pas la
régularisation s'il s'agit d'un refus
d'obtempéré on peut considérer que ça ça
empêche la régularisation donc on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler mais je
regrette Mame jeunev que du coup vous
n'avez pas proposé cet amendement à
l'article 4 b donc on a la séance pour
ça on pourra l'occasion d'en d'en
reparler bien évidemment madame
fustillon non simplement pour dire de
dans le débat on a vous laissez
l'impression monsieur le ministre que
toutes les protections sont sont
uniquement des obstacles et que la fin
justifierait tous les moyens
heureusement il existe encore quelques
protections et on va tenter de les de
les défendre euh j'ai vu par exemple
récemment euh lors de de visite en
centre de rétention qu'il y avait des
personnes d'origine afghane qui
n'avaient pas obtenu l'asile puisque
toutes les personnes afghanes
n'obtiennent pas l'asile et qu'elle elle
elle se retrouvait en CRRA bon d'abord à
mes yeux il y a aucun sens à ce qu'elle
s'y retrouve mais heureusement qu'il
existe des protections qui font que il y
a des pays dans lesquels nous ne
renvoyons pas les gens d'ailleurs même
s'ils ont même s'ils ont commis un un
trouble à l'ordre public et que dans ces
cas-là nous avons quand même pour
mission de lutter contre leur et leur
insertion dans la
société alors je mets au voix pardon
j'ai madame yadan qui sétait
inscrite comment madame MERER ou madame
yad madame yad allez-y oui je voulais je
voulais juste rassurer rassurer nos
collègue en fait sur sur cet article par
rapport par rapport à la protection de
de de notre État de droit et du fait qu'
il s'agit simplement de de de tenir
compte du comportement récent d'une
personne en fonction au regard en fait
de l'ordre de l'ordre public et en cas
de menace grave de menace grave à
l'ordre
public dans ce cas-là et la menace grave
à l'ordre publique c'est une notion
juridique bien bien établie et et très
ferme et dans ce cas-là les protections
contre l'édiction de de la décision
portant portant au qtf dont bénéficient
certains certaines catégories
d'étrangers que vous avez mentionné
monsieur le minusre à l'exception des
mineurs de de 18 ans pourront
effectivement faire l'objet d'une mesure
de d'éloignement mais ce que ce qu'il
faut vraiment retenir à mon sens c'est
qu'en fait la réforme que nous
envisageons ne conduit pas forcément
automatiquement toute personne
représentant une menace grave à l'ordre
public euh à l'ordre public d'être
d'être éloigné parce que pourquoi pour
quoi parce que cet impératif de
sauvegarde de l'ordre publique est
toujours mis en balance avec la
situation personnelle de l'étranger et
les décisions
d'éloignement alors je vais mettre au
voix les amendements de suppression qui
vote pour vot contre rejeté le suivant
le 1078 monsieur Vallot madamearam
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre monsieur le rapporteur cet
amendement qui est finalement un
amendement proposé par par l'UNICEF
France vise finalement à préciser dans
le texte de loi que ces décisions de qtf
prennent en compte de manière
proportionnelle justement les au regard
de la menace représentée par l'étranger
des circonstances relatives à sa vie
privée et familial et l'intérêt
supérieur de ces enfants mineurs
pourquoi parce qu'en fait le le Sénat il
a il a il a rendu encore plus sévère le
texte mais il a accepté
de à l'exception des mineurs
donc finalement cette cet aspect là sera
confié à l'administration et
l'administration la seule responsable
d'apprécier justement chaque fois la au
cas par cas les éventuelles atteintes à
la vie privée et et on a quelques doutes
on a quelques voilà on attire
l'attention justement a qu'il soit
nécessaire de repréciser les éléments
dans le texte pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
dérive
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
avis défavorable pour deux raisons
d'abord sur le fond je j'estime que la
disposition est déjà satisfaite parce
que la notion de proportionnalité qui
est proposé pour être rappelé par cet
amendement elle est déjà continué j'ai
l'occasion de le dire et de de donner
des avis défavorables sur des
amendements qui visaient justement à
réduire l'obligation d'examen en
application du principe de
proportionnalité notamment sur les
sanctions automatiques d'autre part et
je pense que là c'est une petite erreur
légistique l'article 2512 du czda vise
spécifiquement les ressortissants de
l'Union Européenne qui eux bénéficient
d'une protection absolue que je rappelle
les dispositions ne peut faire l'objet
d'une disposition portant au qutf les
citoyens de l'Union européenne ainsi que
les membres de leur famille qui
bénéficient du droit au séjour permanent
prévu à l'article l234-1 l'adoption de
cet amendement aurait donc pour
conséquence d'amoindrir la protection
dont bénéficie les ressortissant de
l'Union européenne avis défavorable pour
ces deux
raisons monsieur le ministre non je veux
redire ici une chose assez simple ce que
nous faisons nous c'est que nous
libérons la contrainte qui pèse sur le
service du ministère d'intérieur
ministère l'intérieur la loi aujourd'hui
empêche le ministre de l'Intérieur de
procéder à leur éloignement mais
évidemment je dis à Madame caraboli
comme la très comme on l'a dit hier il y
aura toujours un juge c'est le juge qui
va regarder évidemment par rapport au
préambule de 46 par rapport à la
déclaration des droits de l'homme par
rapport à la cdH si il y a une balance
avec la vie privée familiale comme dans
le cas du terrorisme il s'agit pas ici
de dire que on va éloigner expulser à
100 % là l'idée c'est que je ne peux
même pas appliquer les eqtf que nous
devons prendre voilà donc soyez rassuré
sur ce point deuxièmement sur l'intérêt
des enfants bon d'abord si on avait
comme idée l'intérêt absolu des enfants
on mettrait plus personne en prison sous
prétexte qu'ils sont parents donc ça me
paraît pas un très bon argument deuxièm
personne n'empêche la famille de suivre
la personne qu'on éloigne ça me paraît
pas deième argument diriment euh il est
vrai que il peut y avoir dans certains
cas euh extrêmement précis que peut
juger le juge des moments où on peut
considérer que l'intérêt de l'enfant ce
soit que la personne soit là mais enfin
l'intérêt de la chant ce que dit déjà la
loi c'est qu'il doit pouvoir contribuer
euh à euh l'éducation et euh au euh et
au moyens matériels de de sa famille
c'est quand la personne parce que on
parle de gens qui ont été condamné à de
la prison qu'on fait des crimes et des
délits graves bon voilà c'est quand même
plutôt euh quelque chose qui contribue
pas à l'éducation des enfants et qui
pourvoit pas totalement l'intérêt
matériel de la famille donc je pense que
ce que nous souhaitons c'est faire lever
ces protections qui n'existent qu'en
France laisser le ministre d'intérieur
faire son travail et laisser le juge de
pouvoir juger s'il y a proportionnalité
voilà il y a rien de rien de contraire à
l'état droit dans ce que nous faisons
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
poet dans un amendement qu'il ne peut
défendre ayant dû partir suggérait que
pour quelqu'un qui se dérobe à une
première au qtf on ne lui laisse pas le
bénéfice de délais supplémentaires
euh en cas de en cas de récidive c'est
l'amendement
132 dès lors qu'il s'est dérobé une
première fois qu' ne puisse pas lui être
octroyé un délai
supplémentaire une seconde
fois B Jes je mets au voix l'amendement
de monsieur Brun qui vote pour qui vote
contre rejeté le 827 celui de Monsieur
gilet
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre collègues expulser ce qui
représente une menace grave pour l'ordre
public c'est du bon sens et c'est une
fermeté qu'attendent plus de 80 % des
Français parce qu'à l'heure où les 13 17
ans concentrent 20 % de l'ensemble des
mises en cause pour trafic où les
mineurs représentent jusqu'à 46 % des
mises en cause pour violence sexuelle
sur mineurs 40 % des vols violents ou 30
% des coûts et blessures volontaires sur
moins de 15 ans et bien il y a une
nécessité d'agir ne pas agir ou ignorer
cette réalité sur ê irresponsable les
émeutes de juin dernier nous ont
d'ailleurs montré au concret ce que
l'inaction de l'État fait encourir à nos
villes et aux Français
nous ont aussi montré que la France est
bien trop laxiste en la matière pendant
les émeutes près de 30 % des interpellés
étaient des mineurs parmi eux beaucoup
étaient issus de l'immigration parce que
la problématique des sanctions contre
les jeunes est un vaste sujet il
convient au moins d'aborder ce cas dans
le projet de loi cet amendement propose
donc et j'en conclu et bien que les
Parents étrangers d'un mineur étranger
condamné pour des faits graves puissent
être expulsé à l'issue de l'exécution
par le mineur de sa peine d'enfermement
merci Monsieur Pradal mon rapporteur
avis défavorable par que la situation
visée serait de de procéder à à
l'expulsion soustf des parents
d'un d'une personne ayant réalisé des
actes répréhensibles ce qui pose deux
problèmes d'abord ça viendrait frapper
des personnes en situation régulière qui
n'ont pas commis de fait répréhensible
autre qu'un lien de parenté d'autre part
ça ne réglerait pas la situation VO ça
une difficulté importante pour les
autres enfants la les composantes de la
fratterie et donc pour cette raison avis
défavorable monsieur le ministre non
mais je pense que cet amendement il est
il est intéressant pour montrer la
différence que nous avons importante
avec le rassemblement national là vous
proposer de pouvoir alors si je peux me
permettre monsieur le député pas
expulser mais éloigner puisque c'est
unqtf d'éloigner un étranger sous
prétexte qu'un de ses enfants aurait
commis un crime ou un délit donc c'est
une sorte de responsabilité à l'envers
bon dans le droit français le mineur est
protégé de ses parents là vous
l'occurrence le parents serait déprotégé
par par le mineur comme l'a très bien
dit monsieur le rapporteur d'abord il
n'y a pas qu'un enfant il y a une
solidarité qu'est-ce que vous faites
avec deux enfants qui se comportent bien
et un qui se comporte mal vous expulsez
un parent sur deux c'est effectivement
pareil une situation qui j'imagine que
c'est un amendement qui qui n'est pas
sérieux il était fait comme vous l'avez
dit vous-même pour pour en discuter et
deuxièmement il peut pas y avoir de
solidarité entre parents et enfant sur
l'éloignement l'expulsion la peine de
prison on peut imaginer du coup dans un
monde non étranger dans un monde
français au partir du principe queon
condamne à la peine de prison les
parents si l'enfant a commis un crime
bon ça me paraît bizarre donc il une
solidarité financière qui se pose dans
le débat public parce que les aides
sociales sont données aux parents pour
éduquer les enfants la question se pose
parce qu'il y a un lien entre on donne
de l'argent à quelqu'un pour pouvoir
éduquer son enfant ou pour pouvoir
contribuer à son éducation et on sait
tous que c'est quelque chose qui est
déjà très discuté mais il peut pas avoir
de solidarité dans le régime des
expulsions des éloignements ou de la
peine de justice entre enfants et et
parents voilà donc je pense que
évidemment votre amendement vous le
savez très bien n'est ni proportionnel
ni constitutionnel ni conventionnel ne
respecte en aucun cas l'État de droit et
et et j'imagine qu'il étaé fait par
provocation madame Martin puis Monsieur
didet
Merci en France la la la la tradition si
je puis dire qui s'inscrit dans le droit
et quand même de distinguer ce que font
les enfants de la des parents et bien
évidemment des frères et
s'ils en avaient parce que à minima
c'est contradictoire avec
l'individualisation de la peine par
ailleurs vous avez dit que les jeunes
gens qui
avaient commis des délits lors des des
révoltes urbaines étit à tel pourcentage
issu de l'immigration bon moi je sais
pas d'où vous d'où vous sortez ce
chiffre là puisque en France ce sont des
statistiques qu'on ne peut pas posséder
et tant mieux
mais je me permets quand même de vous
rappeler que ces jeunes gens sont
français et que parmi nous un tiers des
Français donc parmi nous aussi et même
parmi vous figurez-vous c'est incroyable
nous avons parmi nous un tiers des
Français ont un grands-parents qui est
qui n'est pas né en
France Monsieur
gilet oui très rapidement monsieur le
ministre merci de cet aveu vous vous
l'avez dit il y a une différence très
claire qui ressort à travers cet
amendement entre votre vision la vision
du gouvernement et et la vision du
gouvernement entre de des Français et du
rassemblement national notre vision qui
est celle d'une fermeté et qui est voulu
par les Français et votre vision qui est
celle du laxisme et du laisser faire
puisqu'on le sait la situation enire la
situation s'rave d'année en année et
donc là très clairement sur cet
amendement on voit très clairement une
différence totale de point de vue
monsieur le ministre non enfin le
laxisme pardon c'est vous qui l'incarnez
quand vous voulez régulariser et mettre
les patrons en dehors du coup lorsqu'ils
embuchent des irréguliers dans les
circonscriptions viicol que vous avez
défendu hier cet amendement non mais
rappelons rappelons rappelons cet
amendement rappelons cet amendement donc
voyez restons restons restons détendu le
laxisme c'est vous qui l'incarnez
lorsque vous voulez pas que les patrons
donnent aux étrangers les moyens
d'apprendre le français puisque vous ne
voulez pas de différence entre les
étrangers irréguliers ou les étrangers
réguliers dans les contrats d'entreprise
puisque sans doute vous avez vous-même
un intérêt particulier avec l'amendement
qui avait été donc déposé hier sur le
fait que vous embauchiez vous l'avez dit
dans les entreprises de votre
circonscription vous l'avez constaté des
étrangers irrégulier donc alors les
leçons de l'axisme vous les gardez pour
vous déposer plutôt des amendements plus
réfléchis si vous me permettez la la
prochaine fois euh là c'est pas une
différence entre nous et vous sur
l'xisme ou ou la fermeté c'est une
différence fondamentale fondamentale
entre les gens sérieux les gens qui ne
le sont pas votre amendement consiste en
quoi il consiste à éloigner les parents
quand un enfant aurait commis un crime
ou un délit donc on va donc imaginons
une famille de de de de trois personnes
quatre personnes un papa une maman et
deux enfants voilà ou deux papas et deux
mamans et deux enfants l'un d'entre eux
l'un d'entre eux l'un d'entre eux est
français l'autre est étranger ils ont
deux enfants il y en a un qui a commis
il y a 17 ans un fait grave l'autre qui
n'a pas commis donc votre amendement
comment il s'applique votre amendement
monsieur le député B il s'applique pas
parce que ce que vous faites c'est
n'importe quoi vous allez pas éloigner
une personne en gardant l'autre avec un
enfant qui resterait là pendant que
l'autre serait parti avec lui d'ailleurs
il y a pas de solidarité entre l'enfant
et le parent dans votre amendement vous
écrivez n'importe quoi donc ne faites
pas des leçons de politique et de droit
de ce point de vue ce qui montre que
vous n'êtes pas prêt pour le pouvoir
vous êtes éventuellement prêt pour faire
un tracte bon ça c'est possible mais
mais pas pour le pouvoir vous pouvez pas
rédiger des choses pareilles sans en
plus en rajouter derrière pour expliquer
qu'il y a une différence entre nous la
différence entre nous c'est l'article 9
et l'article 10 on verra bien ce que
vous ferez à la fin sur ce texte de loi
sur cet article monsieur le député
est-ce que oui ou non vous êtes d'accord
pour que la loi française indépendamment
de la réforme de la Constitution la
Convention européenne des droits de
l'homme puisse permettre d'éloigner des
étrangers délinquants de toute façon il
y a une politique du pire chez
rassemblement national de même que vous
n'avez jamais voté les textes européens
qui nous permettaient de pouvoir pouvoir
travailler contre les étrangers
terroristes ou contre les terroristes
même de même que vous n'avez pas voté le
texte séparatisme dans l'ancien mandat
de même que vous n'avez pas voté tous
les des textes de fermeté que propose
gouvernement la République parce qu'en
fait ce qui vous intéresse c'est la
politique du pire vous ne souhaitez pas
qu'on apporte des solutions pour
empêcher le carburant qui monte pour
rassemblement national c'est ce que nous
voulons empêcher donc vous faites la
politique du pire vous ne votez aucun
des textes qui consistent à améliorer
concrètement la sécurité de nos
concitoyens donc c'est ça la différence
entre nous c'est ça la différence entre
nous monsieur le monsieur le député
voilà c'est que vous vous êtes dans
l'incantation dans le n'importe quoi
vous n'êtes manifestement pas prêt pour
le pouvoir et c'est tant mieux pour la
République Vous vous opposez par
principe à tout ce qu'on propose et vous
vousosez par principe par tout ce qu'on
propose voilà bon voilà donc on verra
bien à la fin la belle affaire ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'il y a des choses
concrètes qui sont bien sûr ferme et
difficile que l'article 9 et l'article
10 qui est finalement ce projet de loi
et puis il y a des choses qui relèvent
du cyberespace juridique c'est ce que
vous présenter avec des choses qui sont
impossibles à mettre en place fait
faites attention parce que vous avez vu
ce qui s'est passé pour les
conservateurs britanniques qui on promis
le brexit ce qui se passe quand madame
mélonie dit qu'elle n'a pas besoin de
l'Europe et qu'elle fera un blocus naval
quand vous arrivez en responsabilité
malheureusement vous faites n'importe
quoi quand la polne veut sortir quand la
Pologne veut sortir de de de ces traité
comme vous l'avez vous-même porté en
soutenant le gouvernement polonais non
seulement ils se font il font recul en
marche arrière sur les questions
européennes mais en plus après ils
perdent les élections vous l'aurez
constaté monsieur Pradal mon
rapporteur je mets au voix cet
amendement de Monsieur gilet qui vote
pour qui vote contre
rejeté le l'amendement de Mons poet qui
a été énoncé par Madame jeev n'est pas
défendu le l'endement de Madame Dupont
le 432 1432 merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre bonjour chers
collègues alors on on cherche à sortir
de l'hypocrisie avec ce texte et adopter
des mesures efficaces la simplification
dans la simplification des procédures
dans la fermeté en matière d'expulsion
ou dans la régularisation des S des sans
papiers dans les métiers en tension les
qtf aujourd'hui sont délivrés de façon
large dans notre pays et cet amendement
propose de mieux cibler justement cette
délivrance d'obligation de quitter le
territoire de façon à ce qu'elle soit
aussi davantage suivi des faits et donc
je propose de concentrer la délivrance
des
OQTF sur et d'éviter que des étrangers
ne présentant aucune perspective réelle
d'éloignement du fait de leur situation
personnelle et familiale ou du fait d'un
contexte diplomatique et géopolitique
particulier ne se voit délivrer ses qtf
et donc d'être placé quelque part dans
une
situation très instable et très précaire
où on est ni régularisable ni expulsable
dans les faits donc avoir une politique
beaucoup plus ciblée de délivrance de
ces OQTF de façon à les exécuter à se
concentrer sur une meilleure exécution
et de façon à éviter de placer des gens
dans une dans un nomansland
administratif tout simplement
monsieur le
rapporteur chers chers collègues je
comprends l'intention portée par par cet
amendement qui vise en fait à créer deux
motifs de protection supplémentaire le
premier pour l'étranger ne présentant
aucune perspective réelle d'éloignement
du fait de sa situation personnel et
familial et le second pour l'étranger
qui ne présente aucune perspective
réelle d'éloignement du fait du contexte
diplomatique et géopolitique la première
catégorie parécouverte par les rédaction
la rédaction actuelle de l'alinéa 5 qui
prévoit justement cet équilibre c'est
pour ça que je m'étais permis d'insister
notamment au moment des amendements de
suppression veut dire que l'équilibre né
par la présence de cette alinéa 5 permet
à mon sens de régler cette situation ce
qui pourrait me conduire à vous demander
de de le retirer sur ce point concernant
la deuxième catégorie je je pense que là
pour le coup la situation est différente
puisque je n'adhère pas à l'idée que
nous devrions subordonner la position
sur
l'étranger notamment en matière
d'qtf par exemple à la situation d'un
État qui refuserait de délivrer les
laisser passer consulaire cela a créé
une inégalité à mon sens d'appréciation
liée à au comportement diplomatique d'un
pays autre que la France par rapport à
la situation une concretto que nous
devons apprécier sur chacune des
personnes concernées l'exécution étant
un autre sujet je sais le travail en
profondeur que réaliseant le ministère
de l'Intérieur que le qu d'oré pour
obtenir dans les bonnes relations que
nous avons avec l'ensemble des pays de
laisser passer consulaair suffisant mais
subordonner et mettre sous le contrôle
du juge par l'inscription dans la loi le
fait qu'on ne devrait pas délivrer une
octf et créer une protection par exemple
parce qu'un pays refuse d'être
coopératif créer à mon sens une
inégalité de traitement selon la la
nationalité des ressortissants qui
pourraient être concernés par cette
mesure c'est pour cela que je suis
contraint d'émettre un avis défavorable
à cet
amendement madame Dupont merci monsieur
le Président j'entends vos arguments euh
mais si on reste sur l'exemple afghan où
un demandeur d'asile c'est se trouve
débouté le contexte de ce pays le
contexte particulier de ce pays euh rend
de fait extrêmement difficile voire
impossible une expulsion c'est ces
cas-là que je visais bien entendu je je
ne enfin je n'ai pas aucun enfin je
pense qu'on a aucun intérêt à favoriser
les détournements et le refus de laisser
passer consulaire et un détournement en
définitive la politique de dééloyement
qu'on entend conduire non non c'est
vraiment des cas particuliers que je
souhaite qu'on cible beaucoup mieux et
les n les fameux Nini ni expulsables ni
régularisable c'est une réalité il faut
je pense qu'il faut sortir de ce
nomansland administratif et c'est une
manière de d'avancer sur ce sujet me
semble-t-il mon le ministre alors ce qui
est sûr Madame Dupont c'est qu'il n'y a
pas de tolérance comme il y en a dans
d'autres pays ou quelqu'un qui serait
dans la situation du Nini ni plus
irrégularisable euh pourrait avoir le
Dung allemand qui permet de travailler
malgré le fait qu'il soit irrégulier
afin de vérifier son identité c'est sûr
que c'est peut-être ce qui manque dans
le droit français aujourd'hui le qtf
joue ce rôle-là aussi nous savons tous
si on n'est pas hypocrite qu'on met
parfois des eqtf à à des personnes pour
lui donner pour lu vérifier son identité
sans pour autant savoir qu'on va pouvoir
appliquer cette qtf dans la mesure où
cette personne par exemple est dans un
pays avec lequel on a plus de relation
diplomatiques la Syrie l'Afghanistan
donc ce qui manque dans le droit
français c'est la tolérance que ont
beaucoup d'autres pays autour de nous
qui permet de rentrer dans cette
catégorie qui consiste à dire on vous
éloignera ou on vous expulsera le jour
où on aura des relations diplomatiques
avec ce pays ce que nous on appelle
laassignation report
ce qui sera d par unqtf en disant on
reportera plus tard l'application deqtf
quand on aura des relations
diplomatiques avec ce pays est-ce que
d'autres pays appellent la tolérance
pourquoi on vous l'a pas proposé d'abord
parce que les Allemands eux-mêmes
reviennent sur cette dispositif qui pose
d'autres questions plus compliquées et
deuxièmement parce que là vous auriez
dit peut-être pas vous Madame Dupont
mais vous auriez dit bah voilà en fait
vous essayez de cacher la vérité en
créant un nouvel document qui va casser
le thmomètre là où je suis moins
d'accord avec vous Madame Dupon c'est
que d'une part c'est pas parce que pour
répondre aussi à Madame fossillot qui
l'a évoqué tout à l'heure l'afgan qui
est dans dans une prison dans un cras il
peut pouvoir retourner dans son pays euh
si c'est quelqu'un par exemple qui est
de qui qui est partisan des talibans qui
non mais c'est un Afghan il y en a eu
j'en ai encore eu un quelques semaines
un Afghan partisan des talibans
courordanné pour terrorisme qui est
reparti de lui-même par un avion via
l'Inde ou Pakistan je ne sais plus en
Afghanistan donc il y a des Afghans qui
retournent en Afghanistan et ils le font
de manière volontaire encadré mais ils
retourneent en Afghanistan donc la
nationalité ne ne fait pas toujours le
retour ou non retour même dans un même
dans un pays même dans un pays mais B il
vaut mieux qu'il reparte chez lui s'il
veut repartir chez lui et que la conpp
de prison je préfère qu' paraghanistan
c'est établimement terroriste qui reste
en France c'est sûr si j'ai plus de moè
de l'enfermer ça c'est évident que je je
prends cette position il y a pas de
sujet deuxièmement Madame D pont encore
une fois je peux comprendre aussi comme
l'a dit le rapporteur votre position
mais laisseer le juge juger là ça veut
dire que là on anticipe le fait on juge
à la place du juge nous-même on on juge
par par avant ce fait qu'on ne peut pas
aller voir le juge voilà d'abord il y a
l'appréciation d'administration qui
n'est pas bête et méchante et qui
n'applique pas systématiquement tout
sans sans sans libre appréciation et de
le juge le cas que vous évoquez ben il y
aura un recours et ce recours sera
devant le juge et il va regarder entre
la vie privée et familiale les
possibilités d'éloignement diplomatique
et évidemment la dangerosité de la
personne et il jugera là aujourd'hui ce
que ce que je ne peux pas faire c'est
même pas aller devant le juge pour le
proposer voilà si j'avais été dans cet
état d'esprit pr là encore une fois je
n'aurais pas pu expulser monsieurissen
parce que tout le monde me disait euh on
ne peut pas l'expulser voilà bon et à la
fin on a réussi à le faire parce qu'on a
réussi à prouver en faisant des enquêtes
qu'il avaient un lien avec ce pays par
exemple donc je comprends votre
préoccupation je crois qu'elle ne peut
pas être retenue pour les raisons que
j'ai évoqué parce que la nationalité ne
fait pas toujours le comportement et
troisièmement ce qui m'a paraît
intéressant c'est laisser le juge juger
et le ministère de l'Intérieur faire son
travail de ministère de
l'Intérieur je mets au voix l'amendement
de Madame Dupont qui vote pour qui vote
contre rejeté madame Diaz le
826 merci monsieur le Président donc par
notre amendement nous souhaitons
contester le fait que dans cet article
il y ait une possibilité de limitation
d'expulsion d'étrangers ayant fait
l'objet d'une qtf bon
écoutez on ne peut pas se permettre dans
l'état actuel des choses de limiter
l'exécution des ocutf voyez je fais
référence à un petit livret qui
s'appelle immigration comment font les
États européens un petit livret de fond
d'AOL qui date de 2023 et page 32 de cet
ouvrage il y a écrit les obligations de
quitter le territoire un échec français
moi je rétablirai en disant un échec des
différents ministre de l'Intérieur les
chiffres sont ééloquants ils indiquent
qu'entre 2015 et 2021 la France a
exécuté seulement 12 % de ces OQTF
faisant de nous les cancres du
classement européen alors vous voyez
monsieur Darmanin vous vous passez votre
temps à nous donner des leçons nous nous
souhaitons humblement vous rappeler à
votre bilan monsieur rapporteur avis
défavorable c'est l'inéa 5 qui fait
l'équilibre de
l'article je mets au voix alors madame
mer
oui merci monsieur le Président je
voulais juste rappeler un petit peu à la
fois que notre
groupe je me suis trompé de
microction oui je voulais simplement
rappeler l'importance de ces articles 9
et 10 et et et voilà le fait qu'on soit
extrêmement attaché le groupe
Renaissance à ces articles 9 et 10 qui
sont fond fondamentaux encore une fois
il faut il faut bien se dire une chose
c'est que depuis quelques décennies on a
nous-même enfin nous pas nous en
l'occurrence mais les gouvernements ont
finalement organisé une forme
d'impuissance et et que finalement on n
arrivrivait même plus à se poser la
question de l'expulsion ou de
l'éloignement puisque en réalité on
avait introduit un nombre de protections
tellement important qu'on ne pouvait
plus rien faire donc l'objectif de ces
articles 9 et 10 c'est de lever ces
protections mais non pas de
déséquilibrer complètement évidemment
l'ordre des choses puisque j'entends
bien la gauche qui nous parle de l'État
de droit voilà c'est ils se sont
transformés en Conseil constitutionnel
mais en l'occurrence l'État de droit est
parfaitement respecté puisque voilà il y
a encore une fois un équilibre qui va se
faire entre la vie privée et familiale
et la nécessité de sauvegarder l'ordre
public donc c'est des articles qui sont
fondamentaux et c'est pas un débat sur
les eqtf mais un débat vraiment sur
l'éloignement des délinquants étrangers
monsieur le ministre
oui madame Diaz on a très bien compris
qu était le sens de cet
article 10 et pourquoi vousouz supprimer
lgé à 5 vous êtes en fait gêné qu'on
obtienne l'expulsion l'éloignement des
étrangers délincant vous voulez
déséquilibrer totalement notre régime
pour qu'il soit censuré par le Conseil
constitutionnel pour que vous puissiez
dire ah vous l'avez vu ilarrive pas à
éloigner les étrangers on a tout à fait
compris quel était votre sens bien voilà
donc comme vous pouvez pas mais ben oui
ou alors je vous prête peut-être des des
des signes d'intelligigen que vous
n'avez peut-être pas forcément bon mais
dans ces cas-là alors non btis le compl
c'est ça c'est-à-dire que c'est assez
simple c'est que exactement ce que je vi
répondre c'est exactement ce que je vi
répondre avec même duup pont c'està que
l'administration n'est pas bête et
méchante faites confiance au préfet au
fonctionnaires de la République au
policiers au gendarmes je sais qu'
priori c'est pas évident pour vous mais
mais qu'est-ce qu'ils font ils regardent
les fonctionnaires ils ont liberté
d'appréciation si quelqu'un
manifestement à coup sûr à coup sûr le
juge dira que ce n'est pas possible de
l'éloigner parce que il na en effet est
arrivé imaginons à 6 mois sur le
territoire national que il a 75 ans
parce qu'il y a des gens de 75 ans qui
commettent des crimes et des délits que
par ailleurs c'est tous ces enfants sont
est en France qu'il est marié en France
qu'il a une situation en France bah
évidemment que le juge ne va pas
procéder à son éloignement ce qu'on fera
là dans ces cas c'est qu'on on va
embouiller les les tribunaux c'est ça
qu'on va faire si la personne a 9 ans il
il arrive il arrive que des crimes et et
des délits soient commis dans des
violences intrafamiliales par exemple
par des personnes de 80 ans si ça fait
69 ans qu'elle est sur le territoire
national qui vient d'un pays en guerre
et et qu' a sa vie ici bien sûr que la
jour de préfecture le préfet va pas
prendre un eqtf c'est exactement ce que
veut dire cette alinéa donc arrêtez de
caricaturer la question en fait
fondamentale c'est est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord ou pas pour qu'on essaie de
résoudre une partie de la difficulté que
nous connaissons du fait de la loi
française soit vous voulez faire la
politique du pire pu vous votez contre
le texte soit vous voulez considérer que
ce que nous faisons est un pas très
important pour la sécurité de nos
concitoyens dans le respect des
étrangers qui respectent la République
et dans ces cas-là vous considérez que
ce que nous faisons est conforme non
seulement État de droit mais à une
politique de fermeté après vous pouvez
tout à fait considérer en effet qu'il
faut déstabiliser le texte pour qu'il
soit censuré par le Conseil
constitutionnel c'est une possibilité je
constate d'ailleurs s que vous n'avez
pas de proposition alternative je
constate que le rassemblement national à
part les amendement de suppression n'a
pas de proposition alternative sur
l'article 9 l'article 10 l'article 13
vous n'en avait pas si on a retenu la
volonté de pouvoir empêcher les patrons
qui embauche des personnes irrégulières
sur votre territoire de pouvoir pas être
embêté par le texte de loi ça c'est vrai
qu'on l'a entendu cette proposition
alors je mets au voix l'amendement 826
qui votre
pour qui vot contre il est rejeté le 526
n'est pas défendu il y a deux personnes
qui sont exprimé madame gaz c'est comme
d'habitude je mets au voix l'article 10
qui vote pour qui vote contre il est
adopté le suivant le 1141 tombe parce
que c'est une rédaction concurrente le
10 bis le monsieur le rapporteur le 1714
oui sans se méprendre amendement de
suppression de de cet article au motif
que il nous paraît pour des raisons de
rédaction mal positionné dans le texte
et cet amendement de suppression n'est
fait que parce que il sera repris par
l'excellent rapporteur Mendes sous
l'article
18 al monsieur valallot
ou on est sur
le ok oui oui tout à fait excusez-moi le
10 10 B he excusez-moi et effectivement
c'est c'est c'est on on l'a dit
d'ailleurs les collègues portent le la
même la même proposition que avec notre
groupe aussi pour dire que finalement ce
ce texte cet article qui a été issu d'un
d'un amendement du Gouvernement euh au
Sénat euh pose vraiment beaucoup de
problèmes à la fois sur la question ù
cherche à réduire le délai de départ
volontaire d'une obligation de de qtf en
tout cas et augmenter donc la durée de
l'interdiction de retour sur le
territoire français et il met aussi à
l'égard à cet égard sur le le même plan
l'étranger qui présente une menace pour
l'ordre public comme c lui aussi qui
représente un risque de soustraction
d'exécution de la mesure et donc c'est
vraiment la crainte que nous avons c'est
une généralisation de cette mesure c'est
pour cette raison là qu'on nous
proposant la de supprimer cet article 10
bis fon
défendu alors comme ils sont identiques
je donne un avis favorable à mon
amendement qui a les mêmes conséquences
que les autres amendements défendus en
vue de la suppression de cet article 10
bis merci bon je souscris au propos de
ma collègue caramandli simplement euh
une collègue de la de la majorité nous
disait tout à l'heure que nous aimions
avec mes collègues de laanupes rappeler
l'État de droit et que nous étions
passionnés par l'État de droit j'avoue
être un peu un peu circonspet par ce
propos parce que nous devrions ici
toutes et tous être préoccupés de l'État
de droit et du respect de la
Constitution et oui nous nous
considérons nous nous considérons qu'un
texte de loi ne doit pas être un texte
inutilement bavard un tracte mis à
disposition de la droite radicalisée de
l'extrême droite pour un certain nombre
de ses présupposés mais au contraire
s'attacher s'attacher à
être soucieux du respect des principes
qui fondent notre République et qui sont
précieux donc s'il faut que nous
continuion à les défendre En vert et
contre vous nous le
continuerons alors madame Martin puis
madame je su pas français
on y reviendra quand on quand on sera à
l'article 18 mais je je repose un peu
toujours les mêmes les mêmes questions
c'est-à-dire que depuis 95 on a des lois
qui serrent la vis entre
guillemets relativement aux exilés qui
sont dans le dans le pays et qui font
reculer leurs droits augmente les les
les situations dans lesquelles on
pourrait les mettre de
sauf que ça ne change rien finalement
puisque on voit bien que la la la la
réalisation en particulier des otf sous
toutes les formes ne fonctionne pas donc
on a une loi c'est un peu comme
l'assurant chè pénale finalement on a
des lois qui augmentent les sanctions
qui élargissent l'abaissement des droits
mais qui qui ne fonctionne pas donc on
est encore une fois dans une logique qui
est une logique tout à fait pagogique
madame Miller oui merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président de me donner la
parole non mais je voulais effectivement
rappeler à Monsieur Lucas qui ne
m'écoute pas mais tant pis lui dire
qu'effectivement on est très attaché à
l'état de droit évidemment qu'on a
l'occasion de le rappeler très
régulièrement et notamment le ministre
et et notamment à l'égard du
rassemblement national qui pour le coup
s'en fait clairement un paillasson très
régulièrement mais qu'en revanche
respecter l'État de droit c'est pas non
plus se prendre pour le Conseil d'État
le Conseil constitutionnel en
l'occurrence sur ces articles 9 et 10 le
Conseil d'État a a bien préciser que ils
étaient parfaitement conformes au bloc
de constitutionnalité je mets donc au
voix ces amendements de suppression qui
votre pour qui votent pour les
amendements de
suppression qui vote contre ils sont
attends qui vote pour les amendements de
suppression du
rapporteur qui vot contre sont
adoptés
alors à l'article 11 madame Martin
amendement
778 donc
on
qu' par est
tombé je su dérouleurs madame si la
réponse c'est qu'est-ce que je fous
voilà simplement mais rien n'a été dit
qu' n'aille pas dans ce sens là donc je
ne comprends pas le sens le sens de
cette de cette remarque alors là on
arrive dans un des un des cœurs du sujet
qui est l'affaire de la coerition pour
relever des des des des empreintes bon
en l'occurrence digital et et des et des
photos on sent bien qu'on est dans une
logique d'abaissement des droits ça
n'est pas ça peut paraître anodin pour
un certain nombre de personnes mais ça
ne l'est pas du tout le fait que du
utiliser la coerition pour relever des
éléments biométriques quels qu'il
soit de surcroix ça donne on est
toujours dans dans cette logique là hein
de dire bon on augmente la la
criminalisation d'une manière générale à
l'égard des réfugiés des exilés et on
abaisse leur droit c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous continuons à dire et nous
continuerons à dire et à le démontrer
que cette loi caractère de xénophobie
nette puisque serait assumé y compris
par la minorité présidentielle l'idée
selon laquelle on peut encore une fois
abaisser les droits des personnes
euh sans sans coup faer rire et sans que
cela pose de problèmees c'est la
première fois qu'on fait
ça monsieur madame
car alors oui cet amendement de notre
groupe groupe
euh finalement rappelle que on revient
sur les empreintes qui sont qui sont
proposées dans cette dans cet article et
plus
particulièrement qui permet aujourd'hui
le de de faire se relever sans le
consentement de l'intéressé alors je
pense que nous pensons qu'effectivement
là un certain nombre de personnes qui
peuvent se trouver dans cette situation
souvent vulnérabl ne connaissent pas
forcément l'État de droit dans lequel se
trouve la qui en vigueur dans l'état
comme comme le nôtre et ces dispositions
qui risquent aussi de de conduire à des
abus massifs parce que à cet égard euh
il n'y aura pas de présence d'une
association d'un avocat de quelqu'un qui
peut accompagner ces personnes et donc
il faudrait aussi encore le prévoir il
n'est pas prévu dans le texte donc
contester la mesure de contrainte n'est
pas prévu et je pense que pour nos
droits c'est essentiel aussi de le
préciseron là nous proposons la su
cet article monsieur lucas3 écoutez mes
collègues Martin caramanli ont
parfaitement dit les choses comme à leur
habitude et donc
défendu m Fillon le suivant mes
collègues l'ont très bien dit mais je
continue quand
même non effectivement c'est là il y a
un vrai recours à à à la coarciss pour
la prise d'empreinte et je trouve qu'au
fur à mesure voilà on passe des Caps
devant lesquels il faut poser des des
obstacles on est clairement là dans dans
une volonté de de criminaliser les les
étrangers moi je m'interroge aussi
beaucoup sur la partie qui dit dans le
texte manifestement âgé de 18 ans euh où
très clairement il y a un problème là
sur la liberté individuelle l'atteinte
aux liberté des enfants pardon euh et
qui à mes yeux risque quand même de
renforcer euh le le le pouvoir là des
policiers pour avoir à juger de la
minorité ou pas on voit déjà ça de
manière assez importante mais vraiment
le manifestement
18 ans à mon sens est extrêmement
problématique puisque là on va avoir à
sans sans qu'il ait l'autorité il a de
contrôle préalable de juridiction on va
avoir potentiellement des enfants qui
vont être contraints d'être
photographiés auxquels on prend des
empreintes et qui potentiellement sont
enregistrés comme tel alors même qu'il
n'y a pas eu la phase d'évaluation donc
pour moi grosse alerte
rouge alors l'avis du rapporteur s'il
vous plaît monsieur Pradal
merci merci monsieur le Président don
quelques mots sur cet article 11 qui
effectivement apporte des éléments
utiles et nécessairire je crois qu'il ne
faut pas lui attribuer des intentions
une porté des mots qui ne sont pas réels
à titre liminire puis qu'il en a été
beaucoup questions je rappelle que
l'avis du Conseil d'État sur cette
disposition a considéré qu'il n'y avait
aucune difficulté ni juridique ni
d'opportunité à l'adoption de la mesure
qu'elle est présenté et que recourir à
la contrainte pour relever des des
empreunes en cas de refus et donc N pour
s'assurer de l'identité de la personne
la nationalité sans cela nous privons
les agents et donc les agents il portent
la voix de la République dans cette
affaire là d'un certain nombre
d'éléments permettant d'établir la
vérité ou la justesse des affirmations
qui peuvent être présentées par
l'étranger je rappelle ensuite que ce
dispositif est encadré que nous aurons
l'occasion de présenter différents
amendements avec le rapporteur général
pour modifier l'encadrement et puis pour
apporter des garanties procédurales pour
que cet article 11 fonctionne
correctement et je rappelle enfin que
c'est le droit européen puisquon fait
porter beaucoup de mots sur le droit
européen c'est le droit européen qui met
en place cette mesure et je suis un
petit peu gêné d'avoir un discours qui
pourrait laisser entendre que la
clandestinité est plus protectrice de
droit que l'officialisation d'une
situation monsieur le rapporteur
peut-être dans le prolongement de ce que
vous nous dites c'est que d'abord c'est
une transposition avant son adoption du
pacte asile migration qui a reçu
d'ailleurs un accord au Parlement
européen par le fait d'une grande
majorité Renaissance certes le PPE
également mais les socialistes ont voté
pour ce pacte asile migration qui
prévoit la prise des empreintes de toute
entrée de toute entrant sur le
territoire communautaire dès sa première
entrée et donc ça n'est là que la
transposition en droit national de ces
obligations monsieur le
ministre merci euh de quoi s'agit-il là
aussi c'est un article important c'est
effectivement la coerition pour pouvoir
prendre les empreintes pour reconnaître
l'identité des personnes c'est quand
même important lorsqu'on veut lutter
contre l'immigration irrégulière alors
aujourd'hui je vous rappelle que le
droit c'est que les personnes doivent
pouvoir le faire et si elles ne le font
pas elles sont c'est un délit donc on on
poursuit pénalement les personnes qui
refusent de comprenre leurs empreintes
il y a eu 1872 condamnations en 2021
pour des faits de maintien irrégulier et
de soustraction à à cette mesure euh
pour prendre les empreintes je suis pas
tout à fait certain que ce soit mieux
pour les étrangers de pouvoir les
poursuivre pénalement parce qu'ils
refusent qu' prennent le empreintte
c'est c'est assez particulier sachant
que pour la plupart des étrangers en
situation irrégulière qui sont ainsi
contrôlés ils souhaitent par ailleurs
demander l'asile on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler et qu'ils vont fournir leur
identité donc il faut avouer que la
situation est un peu cfcayenne c'est
tellement vrai qu'en effet le Parti
socialiste je le rappelle à madame
caranli a voté ce texte au Parlement
européen qu'il a été mis en place par le
gouvernement social-démocrate de
Monsieur schols et des vers euh voilà
quelques mois que l'Italie mais avant
l'arrivée voilà l'Italie avant l'arrivée
de madame mélonie l'a mis en place
également comme les Pays-Bas euh bien
évidemment comme la Norvège comme la
Grèce ou comme l'Estonie donc il s'agit
en effet de pouvoir et je pense que ce
sera important de pouvoir euh euh faire
ce travail euh avec avec les services de
police alors ensuite moi je je le dis à
madame caramani vous dites il il y a pas
de possibilité de recours d'abord c'est
faux le Cénat euh a imposé euh des
mesures réglementaires comme l'a dit euh
monsieur le rapporteur on a discussion
avec le le Sénat l'autorisation du
procureur euh évidemment mais madame
caramoli vous savez c'est des policiers
ou des gendarmes qui font ça c'est c'est
pas des délincant en puissance hein
c'est des agents qui sont formés c'est
des policiers des gendarmes qui agissent
sous l'autorité des magistrats et qui
prennent les empreintes des personnes
bah oui c'est c'est c'est pas je pense
qu'on pourrait faire confiance au
policiers aux gendarmes je pense que
c'est d'ailleurs je pense que c'est ce
que vous faites personnellement donc
voilà on pe quand même considérer que
que c'est c'est c'est important donc
vraiment ce cet article 11 euh dans la
la lutte contreimmigration irrégulière
va donner aux policiers français les
moyens de faire leur travail puisque
aujourd'hui on veut lutter contre
l'immigration irrégulière mais on les
empêche de prendre l'identité des
personnes donc évidemment ça marche
moins bien comme aurait dit l'acteur
dans un film connu
voilà suppression qui vote pour qui vote
contre sont rejetés le suivant madame
Caram il est défendu monsieur
rapporteur
je le mets au voix qui vote pour qui
vote contre
rejeté ensuite on a un amendement de
Monsieur Alfandari
le
1243 puisque le 356 n'est pas défendusie
Alf
har ah non c'est Monsieur pouliia pardon
il y a pas il y a pas de défenseur de
l'amendement de ah si Monsieur Alf vous
arrivez à prenommer vous défendez votre
amendement euhende peut dire oui
monsieur le rapporteur ah non attendez
non euh je je voulais juste dire c'est
c'est c'est simplement que on est quand
même en le droit de de savoir qui est
sur le territoire et pouvoir Suiss c'est
pour prendre les empreintes et ça sert à
rien d'alourdir les choses c'est pour ça
qu'on a posé cet amendement monsieur
jacobelli le suivant merci monsieur le
Président vous le savez nous sommes face
à une vague migratoire et notre droit
n'est n'est pas adapté nous devons
identifier celles et ceux qui traversent
nos frontières c'est une question de
sécurité ça implique de laisser nos
forces de l'ordre faire de contrôle
nécessaires dont la prise d'empreinte
digitale et les photos lorsque
l'étranger refuse de s'y soumettre le
policier doit demander l'autorisation du
procureur de la République pour y
contraindre il ne peut pas par ailleurs
forcer un mineur ces garanties nous
paraissent suffisantes la présence
obligatoire d'un avocat ajoute une
complexité démesuré et supplémentaire à
une procédure som toute banale encore
une fois mes chers collègues ne perdons
pas de vue ce qui devrait être à notre
sens notre seule priorité protéger la
France et les Français et n nous perdons
pas en en mesures supplémentaires qui
nous font perdre du temps et mettre en
danger notre sécurité merci beaucoup
monsieur le rapporteur vos
avis donc sur ces amendements enion en
discussion commune j'ai un avis
favorable sur l'amendement 1243 du
président marcangéi et je demanderai un
retrait des autres amendements qui
poursuivent le même objectif madame
regol merci monsieur le Président
protéger la France et les Français c'est
faire respecter le droit arriver à
garder le cadre d'égalité en droit
devant les personnes on est déjà devant
un article qui joue avec les principes
de présomption et vous voulez rajouter
en plus la suppression du droit au
recours à un avocat ce qui fait quand
même partie des droits essentiel je
pense qu'on a là la preuve qu'
rassemblement national on ne protège que
soi-même et jamais les Françaises et les
Français encore moins la
France alors Monsieur le Ministre non
mais juste je suis évidemment favorable
moi aussi à l'amendement 1243 du
président marcangelli dire
euh peut-être à l'Assemblée nationale et
et peut-être singulièrement madame
jeunevard puisqu'elle m'ont fait le le
reproche ici ou là que ce sont des
dispositions de complexité du droit pour
les policiers qui ont été rajoutées par
le par le Sénat de cette présence
systématique de l'avocat ou de
l'information du de l'autorisation du
procureur demandé donc je pense que le
l'amendement proposé par notre votre
collègue marcangé qui prévoit
l'information du procureur et pas
l'autorisation et effectivement non la
présence obligatoire de l'avocat parce
que je pense que ça compliqué lorsqu'on
fait des contrôles d'identité s'il faut
à chaque fois un avocat présent je pense
que c'est une simplification procédurale
qui est bien
bienvenue jeis mettre au voix
l'amendement de Monsieur marcangi avec
avis favorable du rapporteur du ministre
qui vote pour qui vote contre il est
adopté il fait tomber le suivant
l'amendement de Madame Ménard n'est pas
défendu l'amendement de Monsieur Lucas
1045 merci président très rapidement
donc si j'ai bien entendu il y a un
instant le rapporteur a expliqué que des
amendements du rassemblement national
poursuivaient les mêmes objectifs que
ceux de Monsieur Marcangeli et du groupe
horizon c'est assez instructif et assez
révélateur j'allais dire de l'état
d'esprit dans lequel nous nous
légiférons et dans lequel depuis le
début de l'examen de ce texte la
majorité présidentielle qui avait promis
un équilibre gentil méchant j'ai pas
tout compris et cetera humanité et
fermeté en réalité s'aligne trop souvent
pas systématiquement mais trop souvent
sur la droite radicalisée qui elle-même
s ligne sur l'extrême droite je crois
que c'est extrêmement inquiétant et
préoccupant pour la démocratie et pour
les valeurs de notreépuique mon le
rapporteur non non monsieur le
rapporteur Pradal d'abord avis
défavorable monsieur le rapporteur
général oh non juste un éclairage pour
mon débat je fournirai monsieur Lucas
pour la séance amendement de la séance
compris l'ensemble des amendements
communs que vous déposerez identiques
avec le rassemblement national et nous
établirons une comptabilité très précise
nous pourrions d'ailleurs le faire à ce
stade je je ne le ferai pas aujourd'hui
car je n'ai pas la comptabilité précise
mais elle est importante elle est même
plus importante que ce seul amendement
mon cher collègue je le confirme et je
le déplore monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur
Lucas merci Monsieur le le président
monsieur le rapporteur vous pouvez
tenter toutes les manœuvres que vous
souhaitez tous les coups de
communication que vous souhaitez d'abord
un moi je n'ai jamais dit que je
partageais le moindre objectif commun
avec l'extrême droite au contraire par
ailleurs ce n'est pas moi qui défend sur
la question des migrations qui est une
question éminemment sensible et si je
puis dire éminemment au cœur de ce qui
est l'ADN de l'extrêant dans ce pays ce
n'est pas moi qui partage avec elle des
vues sur ce qu'il faut faire en matière
migratoire et évidemment les Françaises
et les Français pourront le voir vous
avez raison à l'occasion de la séance
j'invite simplement monsieur le
rapporteur Pradal à faire attention dans
les mots et dans les actes si possible
ce serait encore mieux à ne pas dire
qu'il partage les mêmes objectifs que le
rassemblement national il me semblait
que le Président de la République avait
été élu et réélu pour faire barrage à
Madame Le Pen monsieur le rapporteur al
je vais redire les choses clairement
monsieur Lucas vous êtes trop fin et
trop avisé pour ne pas av j'ai dit que
l'amendement poursuivait le même
objectif est-ce qu'un amendement peut
poursuivre un même objectif oui est-ce
que pour autant tous les signataires de
l'amendement partagent toute l'idéologie
sous-jacente à ce qui motive les
objectif j'ai dit que nous venons
d'adopter sur un article précédent un
amendement de supr que j'avais présenté
vous aviez également présenté un
amendement de suppression pour autant
l'amendement partageit le même objectif
certainement pas pour la même idéologie
et je crois que sur un certain nombre de
votes y compris en matière de motion de
censure des voies se sont mélangées sans
forcément qu'elles aient le même
objectif ou alors oui moii moi j'irai
plus loin monsieur le rapporteur vous
avez dit que Monsieur Lucas que vous
n'avez jamais partagé d'objectif avec le
rassemblement national si au moins celui
de faire tomber le gouvernement et à
plusieurs reprises et vous l'avez même
assumé arrive même au
meilleur sur votre amendement qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est rejeté il y
a Monsieur Dumont qui est jaloux du MJS
monsieur Lucas voyez
monsieur monsieur la
tombe offrez-lui une carte dois vous en
rester madame monsieur balanan non
c'est
oui
donc mais ça ça tourne et je peux
merci bon nous nous on trouve que que
les garanties qui sont
apportées dans dans la dans la rédaction
de cet article sont sont suffisantes
mais dans un souci que nous avons de de
protéger les personnes mais aussi de
faire
faire d'avoir un suivi de la santé d'un
certain nombre de personnes qui rentrent
sur notre territoire pour parfois gagner
du temps nous proposons que sur la
demande euh de la personne et ou de son
avocat euh il peut euh être examiné par
un médecin euh ça permettrait euh de
d'avoir un bilan médical de la personne
à son entrée euh souvent de mettre en
place des soins immédiatement et souvent
euh je le dis aussi pour ceux qui
penseraient que c'est un peu angélique
euh de faire des économies parce que la
prévention permet souvent de faire de
nombreuses économies en terme de santé
euh donc voici le sens de cet amendement
monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
malanan Merci de de cet amendement et et
du sujet qu'il pose je serais amené à
vous demander de le retirer parce que à
mon sens les dispositions que vous
demandez c'est la présence d'un médecin
pour une opération don je rappelle
qu'elle est de courte durée et peu
contraignant sont déjà prévu par
l'article
l813-5 et ça nous paraîtrait
superféatoire de les rajouter également
à l'article l813-1 c'est pour ça je me
permets de vous demander de retirer cet
amendement monsieur oui d'accord bah
dans ces cas-là effectivement on le
retire ça veut bien dire aussi que cette
ce dispositif s'intègre dans un nombre
de protections qui existe déjà pour tous
les sujets de contraintte voilà donc je
crois que c'est aussi important de le
rappeler
retirer Madame regol ou Monsieur Lucas
qui défend le 1064 c'est moi merci
monsieur le Président donc l'article 11
c'est un un amendement de notre collègue
pascunque j'ai l'honneur de de défendre
en son nom l'article 11 autorise le le
recours à la cooherition pour relever
les empreunes et prendre en photo les
personnes étrangères en situations
irrégulière ou qui franchiraient la
frontière cette mesure porte atteinte à
plusieurs droits fondamentaux comme le
principe d'inviolabilité du du corps
humain la liberté individuelle le
principe de la dignité de la personne
humaine ou encore les droits de la
défense fameux État de droit euh et
fameux principe que nous nous faisons un
honneur de de défendre avec avec mes
collègues de la gauche et des
écologistes l'expression manifestement
âgé d'au moins 18 ans rajouté au Sénat
pour exclure les mineurs du périmètre de
cet article euh est très insuffisante
elle laisse la place à une appréciation
subjective de la minorité car elle
permettrait à un officier de police
judiciaire de se prononcer sur la
minorité de la personne de manière
active et totalement arbitraire en
l'état comme expliqué par la Défenseur
des droits là aussi institution que nous
respectons et que nous estimons ne vous
en déplaise il serait impossible de
garantir que des personnes se disant
mineurs non accompagné ne seront pas
concernés par cet article et donc de
satisfaire à l'exigence de protection de
l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant à défaut
de supprimer cet article extrêmement
préoccupant pour les libertés
individuelles nous proposons donc à
minimum s'assurer que le recours à la
cocession ne sera en aucun cas possible
pour les mineurs merci monsieur le
Président qui défend le C madame torgia
merci nous nous opposons bien sûr au
dispositifs de coerition pour les prises
d'empreinte digital et de photographie
et particulièrement pour les mineurs et
c'est pour cela que nous souhaitons
supprimer dans cet article le mot
manifestement qui est très ambigu euh
nous redisons nous redisons que ce ce
texte va pas dans le bon sens parce que
il exprime toujours
la la suspicion envers les étrangers la
suspicion envers les enfants que ce
texte ne protège pas les enfants mais je
vois que ici la macronie la droite et
l'extrême droite s'associe main dans la
main pour aller contre l'État de droit
puisque précédemment ils ont tous
accepté l'amendement ils ont tous adopté
l'amendement qui prive les étrangers de
la présence de leur avocat donc non vous
n'êtes pas non plus pour l'État de droit
alors monsieur le
rapporteur le la principale critique
portée par ces amendements pour sur le
le terme de de manifestement AG2 et et
donc ce dispositif existe déjà dans
notre droit puisque à l'occasion de la
réforme du Code de justice pénale des
mineurs porté par l'excellent rapporteur
Terlier nous avons eu cette ce
dispositif qui avait été intégré à
l'article L
413-17 de ce code je ne vois donc pas en
quoi cette ce dispositif violerait
l'État de droit étant donné que cela
existe déjà dans des circonstances
d'ailleurs exactement comparabl puisque
cette disposition de ce code visait
également la prise d'empreinte pour les
mineurs donc avis défavoraable à ces
deux amendements monsieur balanan
oui je voulais répondre à à ma collègue
parce que je tout à l'heure l'amendement
que j'ai que j'ai souhaité poser sur le
sur le la visite médicale le rapporteur
m'a m'a fait la démonstration que le
texte intégrait dans j'ai envie de dire
les standards de notre droit et donc euh
je crois que c'est un c'est c'est
inutile d'essayer de de de secouer des
chiffons rouges là on est dans un
encadrement qui qui correspond à tous
les standards habituels euh dès qu'il y
a de la contrainte et si on avait été
plus loin euh de n'importe quelle autre
façon il est sûr que le Conseil
constitutionnel nous aurait censuré donc
inutile de dire que ce coupci vous avez
pas dit raciste c'est il y a un net
progrès mais je je crois que si on veut
avancer et si on veut répondre à la la
préoccupation des Français parce que la
préoccupation des Français n'est pas
effectivement de se dire qu'il est trop
d'étranger la préoccupation des Français
veulent juste que ça soit juste humain
et
efficace monsieur le rapporteur général
mais simplement dire à Monsieur Lucas
qu' on ne peut pas complètement
traverstir traverstir la réalité vous
vous reprenez vous contentez de
reprendre les les arguments du Syndicat
de la magistrature le Syndicat de la
magistrature n'est pas toujours
impartial il lui arrive d'avoir
manifestement des opinions vous dirait
c'est normal c'est un syndicat et donc
je ne lui reproche pas mais en
l'occurrence ces dispositions ont été
visées par le Conseil d'État et au
regard et de façon impertiale et
indépendante au regard de notre État de
droit de nos libertés publiques de nos
libertés constitutionnelles je reprend
vos termes et à aucun moment le Conseil
d'État n'a trouvé quoi que ce soit y
redire au contraire il a parfait ement
valider ces dispositions je tiens à le
redire parce qu'en vous écoutant on
donne le sentiment on croit on croirait
presque que nous sommes en train de
trahir l'ensemble de nos droits et
libertés publiques évidemment ça n'est
pas le cas je vous réfère au paragraphe
26 de l'avis du Conseil d'État mon cher
collègue alors j'ai encore madame Tor et
Monsieur lucasprs et madameou alors
madame
t alors c'est pas une impression oui ici
avec ce texte et d'ailleursar avant
aussi on l'avait déjà remarqué on ne
respecte pas vraiment l'État de droit et
je je je veux rappeler au collègues
balanan parce que je n'ai pas pu le
faire lors de mon de ma défense
d'amendement puisque nous n'avons qu'une
minute que dans sa défense de votre
amendement collègue balanan vous avez
prononcé le mot en présence de son
avocat et la et la vidéo pourra le
montrer or juste avant la présence de
l'avocat a été supprimée par la macronie
la droite et l'extrême droite le
rassemblement national donc vous n'aviez
même pas suivi le cours des débats parce
que dans la défense de votre amendement
vous avez cité en présence de l'avocat
je pensais que le rapporteur allait vous
le dire alors ça n'est pas écrit dans
l'amendement que vous défendiez monsieur
balanon mais vous l'avez vous-même
exprimé parce que instinctivement vous
pensez instinctivement vous pensez que
il faut la présence d'un avocat quand
même vous voyez finir par alors Monsieur
Lucas écoutez moi j'ai pas grand chose à
à rajouter à ce que vient de dire ma
collègue Torenia et qu'elle
a si si je peux finir monsieur le
rapporteur général simplement pour vous
dire Monsieur le Rapporteur général on
peut être en désaccord avec vous sans
travestir la réalité et on peut
considérer c'est facile depuis le début
que soit le ministre de l'intérieur ou
vous depuis lundi vous créez des
questions que nous n'avons pas poser
pour y répondre et vous contreargumentez
sur des arguments que nous n'avons pas
évoqué de la même façon que personne n'a
dit que l'ensemble des des principes de
l'État de droit ét remis en cause par ce
texte il y en a beaucoup il y en a
beaucoup mais je vais vous dire quelques
principes ça compte les symboles ça
compte et les principes ça compte l'état
de droit ça compte et votre attaque
contre le Syndicat de la magistrature me
paraît particulièrement déplacé en
l'occurrence et oui nous nous respectons
ce qu'on à dire les organisations
syndicales ça s'est vu d'ailleurs au
moment du débat sur la réforme des
retraites nous croyons au cores
intermédiaire qui contribue à l'exercice
et au bon exercice de notre démocratie
et nous croyons que la parole des
magistrats la parole des j'ai entendu
tout à l'heure un collègue m'en accusé
je ne suis pas effectivement
constitutionnaliste ni juriste mais je
crois en la parole d'un certain nombre
de professionnels du droit et des
alertes qu'il nous donneent et je suis
fier de porter ici un certain nombre de
revendications qu'ils expriment madame
gnou oui merci monsieur le Président
juste pour m'étonner du côté un peu
absurde de l'amendement qui est proposé
qu'on nous demande de remplacer
manifestement âgé de moins 18 ans au
majeur pour des personnes qui n'ont pas
de documents d'identité donc au fond
voter cet amendement ça viendrait même
aller à l'encontre de l'objectif qu'il
recherche puisque ça viendrait à retirer
à rendre inopérant cette protection des
mineurs manifest manifestement âgé de
moins 18 ans le rapporteur Philippe
Radal l'a très bien dit c'est documenté
juridiquement et en français c'est
simplement à l'évidence âgé d'au moins
18 ans donc c'est bien une mesure de
protection qu'il faut conserver et
rejeter ces
amendements alors Monsieur le
Ministre oui je je veux soutenir
effectivement la la thèse de Philippe
Pradal et de Marie guevnou évidemment
que c'est protecteur pour les mineurs en
premier lieu manifestement deuxièmement
je vous déjà je pense vous avoir déjà
expliqué notamment dans la première
partie de notre discussion que nous
mettons en place avec le garde des sauts
et sous l'autorité des magistrats
toujours sous l'autorité des magistrats
le principe de const de procès verbaux
de constatation de majorité ou de
minorité qui sont validés par les
magistrats eux-mêmes c'est ce que nous
faisons à Bordeaux dans le le le chez le
procureur de la République de Bordeaux
où les policiers les gendarmes
établissent des procè verbaux et
constate si les gens sont manifestement
majeurs ou mineurs c'est ça se reconnaît
assez facilement quand la personne fait
1 M90 à une grande barbe et et par
ailleurs a déjà été interpellé a déjà
été interpellé plusieurs fois notamment
il y a trois ou 4 ans quand il y a 3 ou
4 ans ça a déjà été décrit comme
quelqu'un qui était grand avec une barbe
et B oui le procè le policier national
ou le gendarme il établit un procès
verbal de constatation il le sommet au
procureur de la République qui le sommet
au juges et qui en effet que quelqu'un
est majeur ou mineur voilà c'est c'est
c'est c'est faut faire confiance aussi
au policiers au gendarmes et rien
n'empêche effectivement qu'il y ait une
contestation de ce principe par ailleurs
ensuite devant devant un juge donc c'est
toujours sur l'autorité d'un magistrat
que les policiers et les gendarmes
agissent donc je pense qu'il y a pas de
de contraire avec l'État de droit il y a
au contraire une protection des mineurs
comme l' très bien dit Philippe Radal et
Marie gevnou et il y a deuxièmement des
abus qui doivent être évidemment
combattu et vous ne servez pas la cause
des mineurs en en acceptant de ne pas
combattre contre les ces abus alors je
mets au voir l'amendement 1064 de
Monsieur Lucas qui vote pour qui vote
contre rejeté le suivant le 779 de
Madame ob qui vote pour qui vote contre
rejeté le monsieur Pradal monsieur
rapporteur le 17
pardon donc amendement 1715 qui vise en
fait à créer comme c'est déjà prévu pour
la vérification des titres de séjour un
procès verbal du relevé d'empreinte sans
consentement à l'occasion du contrôle
effectué je mets au voix qui vote pour
qui vote contre il est adopté le suivant
de Madame Ménard n'est pas défendu
l'article 11 qui vote pour qui vote
contre il est adopté après l'article 11
l'amendement 961 qui est-ce qui le
défend monsieur
porte merci monsieur le Président un
amendement de suppression puisque là on
est en 20 c'est un amendement
additionnel ah non non c'est 961
je peux le défendre c'est un amendement
qui vise à revenir au droit en vigueur
précédent la loi de 2018 qui notamment
la loi 2018 de Gérard colon avait étendu
la durée de retenue pour vérification de
droit de séjour encore une fois on est
sur une atteinte aux libertés et vous
engagez dans un domaine extrêmement
répressive donc nous on souhaite revenir
en arrière là-dessus monsieur le
rapporteur avis défavorable la la durée
de 24 heures est une durée maximale le
Conseil constitutionnel à l'occasion de
la réforme de 2018 a estimé que c'était
équilibré je le mets voix qui vote pour
qui vote contre rejeté le suivant le 959
de Madame obono qu'est-ce qui le
défend défendu monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable je mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre rejeté amendement
l'article 11 bis qui le défend au
rassemblement national monsieur Guiton
oui merci monsieur le Président ben
écoutez j'entends depuis tout à l'heure
et je vais prenter cet amendement de
cette manière monsieur le ministre qui
nous dit que nous avons pas de
proposition une proposition l'en voilà
une et puisque monsieur le ministre vous
parlez de fermeté dans vos textes alors
j'espère que vous allez l'adopter cet
amendement il propose tout simplement de
doubler les peines pour toute personne
suspectée d'avoir commis une infraction
qui refuse de soumettre à des
prélèvements qui refuse de soumettre aux
prises d'empreintes digital ou aux
photographies autorisé par le procureur
de la République ou le juge
d'instruction je pense que il faut
favoriser le travail de nos forces de
l'ordre mais il faut surtout être très
ferme votre texte ne sert ira
strictement à rien puisque vous nous
avez dit que nous avions pas de
proposition monsieur le ministre je vous
invite à lire le livret aime la lutte
contre l'immigration de Marine Le Pen
parce qu'il est bien plus complet que
votre 30e loi sur l'immigration qui ne
sert à rien je tiens quand même à vous
rappeler que depuis que vous êtes fin de
l'intérieur il a un peu près 500000
personnes par an qui rentre dans notre
pays donc nous av'ons pas de leçon à
recevoir de gestion de l'immigration de
votre part d'ailleurs les Français nous
font plus confiance à nous qu'à vous
pour gérer les problèmes d'immigration
monsieur
rapporteur avis défavorable doubler les
peines les mettraz au même niveau que
que c'est par exemple la dessimulation
forcée du visage d'un mineur ou les
propositions sexuelles faites en ligne à
un mineur c'est dire que quand même il
faut avoir un certain équilibre dans
l'échelle des peinees àis
défavorable monsieur le ministre non
mais un avis défavorable parce qu'en
fait le Sénat lui-même n'a pas voté son
propre article 11 bis parce que le 11 a
été modifié par le gouvernement il est
plus évident d'ailleurs je constate que
monsieur yakovelli a apporté un
amendement qui contrarie ce que vous
dites puisque par nature vous dites ça
de Tex servir à rien monsieur yacobelli
ayant porté qu'on la vient d'entendre
une disposition qui vient renforcé
l'article 11 c'est vous-même d'ailleurs
vous l'avez fait je l'ai constaté donc
le 11 bis ne sert plus à rien puisque il
existe le 11 il y a plus de poursuite à
voir puisqu une coersition directement
désormais donc je crois qu' vous devriez
retirer votre
amendement je mets au voix qui vote pour
qui vote contre rejeté je met pas
l'article 11 bis parce qu'il a pas été
amendementécriture le H TER amendement
du rapporteur de suppression ah faut
mettre au voix l'article 11 et pourtant
il av pas été adopté par le Sénat bon
alors on me demande de mettre au voix
l'article 11 B qui pourtant n'a pas été
adopté au Sénat qui vote pour qui vote
contre rejeté sur le 11 amendement de
suppression de monsieur le rapporteur
oui merci monsieur le Président donc la
cette création spécifique d'un fichier
MNA délinquent euh nous portons un
amendement de suppression avec le
rapporteur général en effet un tel
fichier ne paraît pas opportun d'abord
le fichier AEM contient déjà les
informations sur les mineurs enen
accompagné en plus le Tage ne prévoit
pas de limite d'âge pour l'inscription
des personnes sur ce fichier donc ce
fichier serait inutile amendement de
suppression le 782 monsieur porte merci
monsieur le Président dans le même état
d'esprit on est encore une fois sur une
surveillance généralisée créer un
fichier spécifique avec une photographie
et empreinte des mineurs nous paraît
extrêmement dangereux donc c'est un
amendement de suppression et pour
rebondir sur ce que vous avez dit
précédemment et sur nos complaisances ou
sur les votes avec l'extrême droite je
rappellerai quand même que ce ne sont
pas les députés de laanupes qui sont
allés mettre des bultins dans les urnnes
pour élire de vis président d'extrême
droite et c'est quand même vous monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur qui lors des
débats sur l'immigration avez cité
Jacques benville historien de l'Action
française mouvement antisémite c'est ça
la réalité donc nous nous n'avons aucune
complaisance et la vidéo le prouvera
votre première parole lors de
l'ouverture des débats quand il y a eu
si si dans les myic Jacques benville
était un historien de l'Action française
monsieur le
ministre alors Monsieur Valo le 911
monsieur
oui
défendu monsieurc d'accord monsieur le
Président ma collègue va présenter le
1039 et 1065
ok merci chers collègu oui la question
des fichiers elle est toujours sensible
comme l'a dit le rapporteur
Pradal il existe déjà des fichiers ce
qui rend totalement inutile cette
disposition à moins évidemment qu'il
s'agisse d'avoir un fichier réservé aux
jeunes hommes de 1,90 portant une barbe
pour arriver à à en nourrir les
nouvelles enfin les nouvelles
surveillances vidéo par intelligence
artificielle dont l'intelligence toute
relative a besoin d'être nourri par des
stéréotypes en dehors de ça la Défenseur
des droits rappelle que cet article est
une atteinte majeur et disproportionné
au respect de la vie privée qu'il
stigmatise injustement des mineurs et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous vous
demandons de le supprimer alors le
suivant n'est pas défendu parce que vous
n'êtes pas signataire ensuite madame si
on le 1186 oui je crois que le ministre
comprendra que quand on s'appelle Elsa
on laisse pas passer un trait d'égalité
entre Aragon et Jacques blinville c'est
quand même des des personnalités qui
n'ont pas apporté tout à fait la même
chose au pays évidemment un un
amendement de de de de suppression de de
cet article puisqu'il il concourt
vraiment à à à une logique qui est
d'ailleurs bien trop
souvent mise en place dans les faits
aujourd'hui dans le pays c'est-à-dire de
jeter la suspicion sur les mineurs non
accompagnés les mineurs étranger plutôt
que de se précipiter pour les protéger
et donc vraiment à la fois je me
satisfais évidemment qu'il y a une
volonté de de supprimer cet article mais
me permet aussi d'interpeller sur ce
qu'est la réalité aujourd'hui bien
souvent dans dans des départements sur
la manière dont dont sont traités ces
jeunes qui arrivent sur notre
territoire monsieur balanan le
1329 merci monsieur le Président dans
dans le même sens enfin c'est c'est il
est il est gênant quand même cette cet
article du du des sénateurs parce que on
est sur une sorte de euh de de
présomption d'AC enfin de de de
culpabilité qui qui qui qui enfin dans
sa rédaction quand même je je le redis
hein donc l'idée serait de faire un un
un fichier d'identification d' mineuvre
à l'encontre desquels il existe des
indices graves ou concordants rendant
vraisemblable qu'ils aient pu participer
bon je je trouve que c'est assez assez
limite quand même sachant que qu'il
existe déjà un fichier hein c'est le
Tage et le Tage comme l'a dit le
rapporteur on peut parfaitement y
inscrire des mineurs donc nous demandons
la suppression de cet article madame
Miller le 1565
oui merci monsieur le Président
effectivement ça ça a été dit par par
tout le monde c'est un article un peu
surprenant il y a pas grandchose qui va
dans cet article à la fois on parle des
mineurs sans préciser les mineurs
étrangers donc on se demande ce que ça
vient faire dans le Code de l'entrée du
séjour des étrangers et du droit d'asile
on se demande aussi ce qui vient faire
dans ce projet de loi c'est toute
évidence un cavalier législatif euh et
puis de toute façon il existe un fichier
de traitement des antécédents
judiciaires le tâ comme l'a précisé le
rapporteur donc en effet on demande de
supprimer cet
article
euh alors monsieur le rapporteur vos
avis favoraable je présume
oui avis favorable monsieur rapporteur
général vous vouliez dire un mot alors
madame
Diaz merci monsieur le Président alors
ici dans dans cet article on parle pas
du tout de discrimination on parle pas
non plus de surveillance généralisée euh
on parle surtout de protection des
Français et quand on voit les
amendements de suppression déposés par
les macronistes ou par l'anupes et ben
les Français peuvent se dire
heureusement qu'il y a le rassemblement
national pour penser à leur sécurité
parce que la sécurité des Français vous
n'en faites peu de cas vous avez
certainement pas vous n'avez
certainement pas vu passer les les les
sondages qui indiquent que 60 % des
Français se sentent en insécurité et que
80 % des Français ont peur pour la
sécurité de leurs enfants alors là dans
cet article on ne traite pas je vous dis
il y a pas de surveillance généralisée
on parle en plus d'un statut de MNA dont
je rappelle qu'il y a une large
suspicion de fraude qui entoure ce
statut et donc quand vous avez en 2020
30 % des cambriolages qui sont commis
par les mineurs non accompagnés oui nous
nous considérons en rassemblement
national que pour la protection des
Français il faut maintenir cet article
monsieur
Dumont merci monsieur le président ident
je pense qu'il faut quand j'entends les
propos de de
laanupes garder raison personne ne dit
que tous les MNA sont des délinquants
mais il est évident qu'il y a une
surreprésentativité des actes de
délinquence commis par les mineurs non
accompagnés en 2020 à Paris les chiffres
de la justice montrent que les MNA sont
responsables de 30 % des cambriolages 44
% des voles à la TI 32 % des vols avec
violence et que 80 % des déferments de
mineurs le sont pour des pour dmna donc
il y a en effet un vrai sujet d'où
l'intérêt de créer ce fichier qui a été
introduit par nos collègues sénateur et
que l'avantage de ce fichier c'est que
ça permet aussi pour l'AZ dans les
différents départements de savoir avec
qui les MNA seront en
contact avec qui dans les structures
d'accueil les mineurs qui sont de la
protection des départements vont se
retrouver côte à côte c'est le sens d'un
amendement de notre collègue
à mon avis on aura du mal à le discuter
puisque ce sera supprimé mais je tenais
à attirer l'attention là-dessus alors
j'ai trois inscrits madame regol
oui merci monsieur le Président je je je
j'entends ces chiffres répétés à nosam
sur la surreprésentation de telle ou
telle population dans les chiffres de la
délinquence alors spoiler chers
collègues effectivement c'est dans les
populations pauvres qu'on va avoir le
plus de gens qui vont se faire attraper
et oui peut-être que si on voulait
changer ses chiffres et essayer de
changer les choses peut-être que
l'accompagnement de ces mineurs serait
une solution après c'est vrai je vous
dis les pauvres sont sur représentés
dans les chiffres de la délinquence
c'est pas tout à fait vrai parce que ce
sont de grands partis politiques qui
détournent 6 millions d'argent public ou
de grands ministres qui fournissent des
emplois fictifs ou autres mises en
accusation il y en a trop dans le
gouvernement actuel pour les passer en
revue donc oui effectivement quand on ne
prend que les chiffres de la petite
délinquence on peut ad nooséam faire
monter des idées reçues xénophobe sur
une partie de la population et continuer
à stigmatiser stigmatiser sans jamais
attaquer les véritables problèmes qui
sont ceux de la France Mad
Martin bon d'abord se dire que pour nous
l'enjeu n'est pas la protection des
Français en tant que tel puisque nous ne
pratiquons pas
cette fausse préférence nationale moi je
je crois que une des difficultés
majeures auxquelles on est confronté
lorsque l'on parle des jeunes gens qui
arrivent en France par leurs propres
moyens dans des conditions qui sont
extrêmement difficiles voire
traumatisante sur sur le chemin ce qui
ne fonctionne pas c'est toujours la
question de l'organisation de l'accueil
et en particulier la mobilisation des
départements à qui l'on a confié
peut-être de ma mauvaise manière les les
les services de protection de l'enfance
donc c'est de ce côté-là qu'il faut
regarder et sans doute faudrait-il qu'il
y ait euh
des des moyens des moyens nécessaires
qui soient apportés au département mais
bien sûr ça n'est pas d'actualité au vu
des logiques d'austérité pour que les
départements puissent bien prendre en
compte ces jeunes gens par ailleurs nous
avons une question sur l'organisation de
nos débats et on voudrait savoir c'est
pas il à l'amendement et on voudrait
savoir
quandce non mais en fait vous avez une
minute comme tout le monde vous la
poserez à la pause monsieur balanan oui
je je voulais répondre à mon collègue
Dumont qui qui connaît pourtant ces
situations dans son territoire quand
vous avez des jeunes
laissés sans sans accompagnement seul
dans la rue sans moyen de
subsistance
leur la logique effectivement c'est que
sans doute il se ils produisent des
petits malfras des petits cambriolages
tout simplement parfois pour subsister
alors je vais pas pardonner ça mais tout
l'enjeu de ce texte c'est de faire en
sorte que l'on
puisse justement je suis en train de
vous dire Madame Diaz ne vous exitez pas
tout de suite que je ne vais pas le
pardonner par contre notre rôle et notre
responsabilité contrairement à la vôtre
c'est d'organiser cela d'organiser les
moyens de de de que c'est que c que ces
choses n'existent pas et c'est tout
l'enjeu du texte l'enjeu du texte c'est
de contrôler les les ces
jeunesci mais est-ce que je peux parler
vous vous bernalisez je trouve est-ce
quez vous avez 10 secondes pour terminer
non ben écoutez termz Monsieur B et donc
donc tout l'enjeu du texte tout l'enjeu
du texte mer tout l'enjeu du texte c'est
justement de permettre de humainement de
façon juste de façon équitable efficace
je mets au voix les amendements de
suppression qui vote
pour qui vote contre ils sont adoptés
ils suppriment l'article et font tomber
les amendements à l'article le 831
monsieur Baillou
oui monsieur le Président en fait merci
nous allons vous proposer pour nous
éviter bon nombre de débats de d'abroger
le régime de la rétention administrative
les visites en centre de rétention que
peuent faire les parlementaires ouou le
Défenseur des droits montre que les
tentatives de suicide ils sont liés
légion les actes d' d'autoutilation les
humiliations les violences physiques je
parle même pas des mauvaises conditions
sanitaires évidemment notamment en
période d'épidémie et donc c'est
proprement indigne et on peut tourner
autour du pot mais il s'agit bien
évidemment d'une non peut-être pas d'une
prison mais au moins d'une privation de
de liberté et donc on a aussi un
problème de droit la directive retour de
1991 disait que la rétention
administrative ne pouvait être que
l'exception et au contraire on a une
administration qui en fait quasiment une
obligation avant tout parcours
d'éloignement on pourrait imaginer les
assignations résidence ou les centres
ouverts belges sur le modèle des des
maisons de retour belge de fait la durée
de rétention a quadruplé depuis 1981 il
est temps de mettre fin à ce régime de
la rétention administrative monsieur le
rapporteur avis défavorable les les
lieux de rétention ou les centres de
rétention administratives sont
nécessaires à l'exercice de la politique
migratoire que nous voulons conduire et
donc il est impossible même si nous
prévoirons un certain nombre
d'aménagements dans cet article 12 de
purement et simplement les supprimer
madame Diaz
oui merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement est absolument lunaire on
nous propose de supprimer les centres de
rétention administrative en disant
qu'ils sont la généralité écoutez je
vais juste vous rappeler quelques
chiffres cher collègue il y a dans notre
pays entre 600000 et 900000 clandestins
pour moins de 2000 places disponible
donc à notre sens l'exception c'est
plutôt l'enfermement et en début de
semaine j'ai été visité le CRAT Vincen
avec mon collègue Johann Gillet à peu
près 200 places et les les les les
forces de l'ordre nous indiquaient que
faute de place dans ce CRAT ne venait
pas que les les personnes placées sous
auocutf mais venent juste en fait les
personnes enfin les clandestins qui de
sur croix étaient des délinquants alors
je pense pardon de vous le dire mais que
votre amendement est irresponsable et
que de toute façon ce que vous voulez
c'està-dire que l'enfermement soit
l'exception c'est déjà ce que vos amis
de la macronie sont en train de faire
dans notre pays alors j'ai donné la
parole à Monsieur Bou pour répondre mais
au centre de rétention administrative de
Vincen c'est normal que vous voyez
exclusivement des délinquants madame
Diaz puisque c'est la politique du
gouvernement de d'enfermer que les
délincants en CR pour parvenir à leur
expulsion et de pas enfermer des
familles donc en fait çaappelle
çaappelle l'efficacité de la politique
française d'expulsion ou d'éloignement
monsieur Bou merci je je vois que Madame
Diaz est tout à fait à l'aise pour
enfermer des des personnes innocentes
euh
je voulais insister sur le fait que en
deux mots vraiment si vous voulez moins
de personnes en situation irrégulière
sur le territoire national voter les
amendements de régularisation et ainsi
ça concourra à augmenter les salaires de
l'ensemble de la population française
comme ça s'est passé en 1981 et je note
qu'à chaque fois qu'il s'agit
d'augmenter les salaires des Français
vous votez
contre Monsieur le Ministre non juste
faire
remarquer juste faire remarquer à
Monsieur Bou que le centre de rétention
administratif
n'a rien de n'a rien de dshonorant il a
été inventé le 2 novembre 45 par le
gouvernement de libération de la
francequel siégé des communistes par une
ordonnance de 1945 et il a été pour le
centre de rétention administratif en
tant que tel inventé par le Premier
ministre de gauche puisque vous parlez
de des avancées de 1980 86 en 1984 par
le gouvernement socialiste de François
mitteran donc ce centre non moi non plus
d'ailleurs mais voilà mais donc je pense
que ce qu'il faut bien voir ce centre de
attention ils sont une longue politique
que nous menons quels que soient les les
partis politiques parce que il faut
évidemment avoir sous la main la
possibilité de renvoyer des personnes
qui veulent se soustraire à la décision
de reconduite à la frontière on ne met
pas dans les centre de r administratif
tous les étrangers mais je veux dire à
Madame Dias par ailleurs que
heureusement qu'on ne crée pas des
places pour 500000 600000 ou 700000
personnes c'est pas le d'ailleurs aucun
pays au monde ne le fait nous le nous
mettons dans le centr de rention
administratif que les gens qui veulent
se soustraire à la reconduite à la
frontière je rappelle que l'essentiel
des eqtf sont des départs volontaires et
pas des départs forcé donc il faut
distinguer les deux choses et
troisièmement c'est une politique que
j'ai mené qui consiste à mettre dans les
centres de rention administratif qui
effectivement monsieur Bayou jamais un
moment rigolo dans l'existance je veux
tout à fait bien l'admettre c'est tout à
fait vrai il faut qu'ils y passe le
moins de temps possible parce que c'est
effectivement des lieu de privation
liberté personne ne conteste cela en
tout cas pas moi je nimet désormais où
je demande au préfet d'yimettre que les
personnes qui représentent une
dangerosité pour l'espace public et donc
c'est une bonne chose puisque je veux
constater aussi avec vous on a parlé des
chiffres de la délinquence tout au long
de ce débat qu'on est à à 5 à 6 points
de moins de délinquence étrangère on ne
le site jamais depuis 2 ans depuis que
nous mettons dans les centres de
rétention administratif des personnes
qui sont dangereuses et que nous
arrivons davantage à les expulser ce qui
est tout à fait vrai c'est qu'on est
autour de 40 % de réussite d'expulsion
d'éloignement quand ils sont dans lescas
et qu'on est à moins de 15 % lorsqu'ils
ne sont pas dans les CR et ce qui est
important c'est de prioriser qui on met
dans les cras donc ces cras ne sont pas
des moments toujours évidemment
sympathique c'est moins compisir de la
vie des personnes c'est pour ça que je
proposeraiis dans l'article 12 on en
parlera dans l'article suivant pardon
l'article 12 qu'on puisse ne pu mettre
des mineurs qui n'ont rien à faire dans
ce centre de rétention administratif
évidemment mais je vais rappeler quand
même que cela fait très longtemps que la
France les a imaginé et qui ont été
imaginé par la
gauche alors on va passer au vote sur
cet amendement qui vote pour qui vote
contre il est rejeté on en arrive à
l'article 12 monsieur Dumont
l'amendement de suppression
oui merci merci monsieur le Président C
de suppression de l'article 12 est
absolument primordiale parce que vous
l'avez dit ça été dit par Monsieur le
Ministre également le CR est fait pour
pouvoir s'assurer que les étranger en
situation
irrégulière qui risque de se soustraire
à une mesure d'éloignement puisse rester
sous la main des autorités de notre pays
qu'on puisse procéder à leur éloignement
la difficulté qu'on a avec C cet article
c'est que nous interdisons de placer en
cras les enfants de mineur de moins de
16 ans mais également leur famillees et
ce qui donc risque de créer une
situation où il suffirait queun famille
avec un individu qui a une situation
personnelle compliquée qu'on veut
absolument expulser ne pourra pas être
placé en en centre de rétention
administratif parce qu'il aurait dans sa
famille un mineur de 15 ans ce qui
risque de poser un problème de sécurité
pour les compatriotes pour nos
compatriotes et donc nous estimons qu'il
est aujourd'hui nécessaire de supprimer
cet amendement je rajouterai que la
situation est particulièrement
importante par exemple à Mayotte ou dans
le Crâ Mayot un nombre important de
mineurs se trouve et on pourrait être
beaucoup moins efficace dans les renvoi
vers les Comor monsieur Pradal monsieur
le
rapporteur avis défavorable le le régime
du placement en centre de tion des des
mineurs et de leur famille doit être
adapté pour deux raisons d'une part et
c'est l'objet de l'article 12 d'une part
parce que la pratique administrative
retenu maintenant depuis plusieurs
années fait que en pratique il n'y a
aujourd'hui plus de familles qui sont
présentes en cras ça représente moins de
1,1 % des déplacements en centre de
rétention au cours de l'année 2019 de
plus la jurisprudence de la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme a
régulièrement pointé cette insuffisance
de la France dans en l'accompagnement
des des familles de mineurs c'est pour
cela que parce qu'il existe des
solutions alternatives qui permettent
d'assurer les mêmes résultats il est
proposé dans cet article 12 d'aménager
le régime du CRRA pour les mineurs et
les familles avec
mineurs monsieur le ministre non mais
c'est un article très très important
parce que il vient mettre d'ailleurs en
fait ce qui existe en droit pardon ce
qui existe en fait depuis que j'ai
l'honneur de mener les desstinés du
ministre de l'Intérieur c'est-à-dire que
nous ne mettons plus de mineurs dans les
centres de rétention administratif à
quelques rares exceptions prês et nous
mettons fin aux espaces 10 familles dans
ces dans ces centres de rétention
administratifs alors pourquoi parce que
nous considérons-nous qu'on doit mettre
dans les centres de rention
administratif que les personnes qui
présentent une particulièrement une
particulière dangerosité ce qui n'est
pas le cas des des mineurs et quand ils
le sont je rappelle que les mineurs ils
sont expulsés non pas par le ministère
d'intérieur ou par les préfets mais par
les mesures de justice les passe par
d'autres centres que les centres de
rétention administratif cependant il est
évident monsieur Dumont que cette action
je crois forte humaniste qu'il considère
en effet puisque ce sera le premier
gouvernement à à le faire et je prendrai
les amendements par avance qui évoquent
les moins de 18 ans ou les ou les lieux
de rétention administratif ce n'est pas
pour autant qu'il faut qu'il faut
refuser d'éloigner des familles bien
évidemment ces familles on va continuer
à les éloigner c'est tellement vrai que
Monsieur Pradal l'a dit Mayotte mis à
part mais je reviendrai parler de
Mayotte dans quelques instants nous
arrivons à améliorer cette année on va
faire entre 6 et 8 % d'éloign en plus
par rapport à l'année dernière y compris
avec les difficultés que nous avons
connu avec certains pays et pour autant
nous avons toujours continué à augmenter
ces ces éloignements y compris de
famillees qui sont en augmentation parce
que nous passons par le système de
l'assignation à résidence quand nous
avons une famille à à à éloigner ce que
je demande au Service de police c'est de
bien préparer tous les documents de les
assigner à résidence ta veille ou
l'avantveille soit dans leur lieu de
domicile soit dans un hôtel et notamment
près d'un aéroport c'est quand même plus
simple simple pour pouvoir les éloigner
donc on peut éloigner les personnes avec
humanité on peut assigner à résidence
dans des hôtels près des aéroports des
personnes dire ne pas sortir prévoir une
garde mais que les enfants qui sont en
construction d'adolescents ou d'enfance
ne soient pas dans un lieu qui soit un
lieu carcéral chacun peut chacun peut le
comprendre et et pour autant nous
arrivons à faire ces éloignements donc
je pense qu'on peut tout à fait à la
fois supprimer la présence de mineurs
dans les dans les cras sans pour autant
refuser notre principe d'éloignement
alors vous avez raison à Mayotte la
situation n'est pas la même pour deux
raisons la première c'est qu'à Mayotte
vont dans le centre de rétention
administratif d'aujourd'hui pas que des
gens qui ont commis des actes de
délinquance donc là c'est vrai que vu le
flux de personnes qui sont irrégulières
notamment venant des Comores et par la
proximité immédiate des îles des Comores
la mê la chose ne peut pas être
similaire c'est pour ça que le
gouvernement et vous l'avez voté je vous
en remercie prévoit une augmentation par
deux des lieux de rétention
administratif je rappelle qu'on est on
va passer à à plus de 3000 000 plac et
notamment un deuxième centre de
rétention administratif à Mayotte
notamment sur la Grande Terre parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est la petite terre qui
pose des questions de transport pour en
spécialiser un dans la délinquence et un
autre évidemment si jeose dire dans les
eqtf sans délinquence et nous avons
prévu puisqu'à Maillotte il y a
effectivement beaucoup de familles qui
sont concernées de ne pas appliquer le
texte de loi avant le 1er janvier 2027
afin que nous puissions réaliser ces
investissements et permettre des
assignations à résidence qu'on pourrait
qualifier de familial qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui donc on va REC que c'est
l'article 27 de ce projet de loi où il
est très clairement explicité que la
présente l'article 12 de la présente loi
entre en vigueur à Mayotte le 1er
janvier 2027 ce qui laissera largement
le temps d'y revenir s'il y a une
difficulté ou de faire les
investissements nécessaires sur l'île de
Mayotte puisqu'on aura à la fois des
dispositions particulières à Mayot son
les propositions du rapport serva et des
parlementaires élus dans ce magnifique
territoire français mais aussi la loi
maot qui arrivera et je l'espère une loi
constitutionnelle qui permettra de
modifier les la réglementation et la
législation à Mayotte donc je pense
qu'on peut à la fois et c'est un point
très important interdire et c'est très
important y compris que cette majoritéci
le porte parce qu'on attend beaucoup de
discours humanistes mais ça n'a jamais
été fait par personne voilà donc nous le
faisons nous interdisons les mineurs
dans les centres de rétention
administratif ou de rétention
administrative tout en étant plus
efficace dans l'éloignement en
respectant les personnes j'en appelle
d'ailleurs à à à au rassemblement
national peut-être pour dire que s'ils
ont depuis des nouvelles de leur mère
qui voudrai que nous puissions avoir un
terrain pour construire des lieux de
rétention administrative je je suis
preneur les les les maires du
rassemblement national n'ont pas voulu
positivement à ma demande de centre
d'oration administrative sur leur
territoire j'ai CR comprendre qu'il y
avait un peu de moyens dans la commune
de Fréjus enfin je en lisant la presse
rapidement je suis donc sensible à
l'idée que nous pourrions imaginer par
implantter puisque monsieur Rachin m'a
fait une l de trois pages pour
m'expliquer que finalement c'était pas
bien les centre de rétention
administratif elle est à votre
disposition d'ailleurs n'hésitez pas
pour la pour la consulter voilà je pense
que le le le rassembl nationale devrait
sur ce point mettre en cohérence ses
idées ses actions je crois que sur les
étranger ou la rétention vous êtes
croyant mais pas
pratiquant monsieur le rapporteur
général un quelques mots monsieur le
Président je je voudrais qu'on mesure la
la décision historique hein que l'on
s'apprête à à prendre ce matin ici en
commission des lois et bien sûr en
séance je je le dis notamment à toutes
celles et ceux qui qui depuis plusieurs
jours font des leçons de morale
permanente
aboutir aujourd'hui à ce que il y ait à
la fois l'interdiction de la rétention
des familles dans les
cras c'est le fruit d'un d'un long
processus j'en suis le témoin parce que
j'ai moi-même déposé au mandat précédent
monsieur le ministre vous le savez une
proposition de loi qui visait non pas
interdire d'ailleurs à resserrer les
critères d'interdiction et je dois dire
que je suis très heureux que l'on puisse
avoutir aujourd'hui de façon beaucoup
plus définitive deux amendements
supplémentaires seront acceptés ce matin
je
l'espère le premier c'est de porter
jusqu'à 18 ans et non pas jusqu'à 16 an
et monsieur le ministre vous l'aviez à
plusieurs reprises y compris au Sénat
indiqué je note que le Sénat avait
refusé cet élargissement à 18 ans
pourtant sur des amendements qui étaient
issus plutôt des groupes de gauche au
Sénat élargissement jusqu'à 18 ans et
puis d'autre part l'interdiction non
seulement dans les centres de rétention
administrative mais dans tout les locaux
de rétention
administrative c'est une décision
absolument majeure euh elle est le fruit
de longues réflexion parce que il faut à
la fois concilier les impératifs de
fermeté absolu et ce texte vous le savez
en comporte de très nombreux et nous
venons de voir les articles 9 et 10 et
en même temps de savoir trouver les
solutions alternative lorsque des
mineurs accompagnés pourraient subir
l'éloignement justifié par leur
situation mais pas dans un centre de
rétention administrative et pas dans un
local de rétention administrative voilà
j'espère que que chacun mesure la portée
de cette décision mesure aussi à quel
point par conséquent ce texte ne mérite
pas parfois les tonbau d'insanité que
nous avons pu entendre depuis lundi et
que j'ai trouvé je pense en particulier
à certains arguments des LFI pardon de
le dire euh qui parle de racisme qui
parle voilà voilà ce qu'est la réalité
de ce texte j'espère aussi que les
structures associatives seront le juger
à cette auteur madame
Martin euh il va quand même falloir
clarifier la situation des 16 18 ans
parce qu'en France tant qu'on n pas 18
ans on est mineur par ailleurs il y a
quand même un angle mort dans toutes ces
affaires là c'est l'absence de respect
de la dignité humaine dans les centre de
rétention administrative l'absence de
respect de la vie privée chacun ici a pu
visiter Descas et globalement chacun a
pu constater dans quelle situation tout
ça se passait d'ailleurs on a été
condamné et pas seulement à l'égard des
familles et des mineurs de nombreuses
fois en particulier par la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme le
troisième élément que je veux glisser et
vous le savez sans doute puisque
maintenant ça fait je ne sais combien de
jours qu'on pose la question qu'en
est-il des de ces lieux sans droit ni
ties de mise à l'abri par exemple à la
frontière franco-italienne dans la dans
lesquelles des familles avec des tout
petits enfants sont tout à fait enfermés
donc non seulement ils sont enfermés
avec des petits enfants mais encore une
fois il y a pas de cadre réglementaire
pour les y enfermész simplement dire
merci ce serait pas mal madame
Diaz merci monsieur le Président alors
nous ne sommes pas dupes he des des des
tentatives de diversion de monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur dont le bilan
devrait le faire rougir qu'il s'attaque
de cette manière à frésu je trouve
vraiment que c'est pas au niveau mais
les Français surtout les frais juciens
ne seront pas DUP et quant à son
argument qu'il répète en boucle sur
comme quoi les mairies du rassemblement
national ne souhaiteraient pas
accueillir quelques cras enfin pardon
monsieur le ministre ça n'est pas au dit
mairie Ren de venir compenser l'incurie
de votre gouvernement là vous êtes en
panique parce que vous avez promis dans
la Lop mie que vous alliez accorder 3000
places de cras vous avez des mairies
macronistes et bien demandez à vos amis
et quand bien même vous arriveriez
l'objectif de 3000 plac de en 2027 je
voudrais juste vous rappeler qu'il y a
dans notre pays entre 600000 et 900000
clandestins et la cause des personnes
qui sont en situation irrégulière et
qu'il faut expulser c'est parce que vous
êtes incapable de faire votre travail et
que vous êtes incapable de contrôler les
frontières et ce texte en est la preuve
matériel monsieur le
ministre
bien madame madame la député on a
toujours pas compris si vous étiez pour
ou contre
finalement la suppression on toujours
pas compris cétiz pour compte finalement
la suppression de la présence des
mineurs dans les cras euh et si vous
aviez euh compris le fait qu'il fallit
désormais mettre dans les centres de
rétention administratif des personnes
dangereuses donc ce sera intéressant de
de le savoir deuxièmement madame la
députée ils sont trouvé ces 3000 places
de cras heureusement qu'il y a des
mairies LR macronistes que le maire de
Bézier que le des maires socialistes euh
que des maires communistes nous ont
accordé des terrains bien évidemment euh
elles sont j'ai déjà annoncé la liste de
ces centres de rétention administratif
et que nous pouvons les construire c'est
le cas à Nant je remercie la mre de
Nantes c'est le cas à Bézier c'est le
cas à dkererque c'est le cas à
goussinville c'est le cas à mérigac
c'est le cas à Oliver donc bien sûr que
nous avons construit sans vous ces
places mais j'aiécris à tous les maires
vous savez madame j'écris pas com maire
du rassemblement national le seul qui
m''est répondu en expliquant que les
centre de rétention administratif ne
fonctionnait pas c'est le maire de
Fréjus donc comme on dit à Fréjus c'est
pas l'heure de ça Saché
madame bien donc on va passer au vote
sur cet amendement de suppression avec
avis défavorable du rapporteur qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est rejeté le
490 monsieur Bou merci monsieur le
Président un amendement pour mettre fin
à l'enfermement des mineurs et des
femmes enceintes et je précise d'embl
que contrairement à ce que disait le
rapporteur ça serait pas une décision
historique à laquelle il faudrait dire
merci ça serait uniquement se mettre en
conformité avec le droit européen et
pour moi c'est un amendement de replili
parce que nous proposons bien avec les
écologistes l'abrogation complète du du
régime de rétention administrative je
prends appui sur le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui nous a dit à uninant qui
expliquait que c'était pas un moment
amusant dans l'existence et de fait la
France a été condamnée 12 fois pour
traitement inhumain et dégradant et pas
amusant mais il l'avait pas précisé mais
ça va de soi et y compris encore
récemment depuis que Monsieur Darmanin
vous êtes ministre de l'Intérieur la
France a été condamné par exemple pour
une rétention en janvier 2021 c'était
dans le barrain une
femme une mère et son fils âgé de 7 mois
et il s'agissait de les renvoyer vers
l'Espagne monsieur le ministre vous avez
dit à l'instant je demande au préfet de
n'y placer que des personnes dangereuses
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire quel
danger représentait cette femme et son
bébé de 7 mois vous avez dit également
ce qui est important c'est de prioriser
qui on met dans ses cras est-ce qu'une
femme enceinte de 7 mois c'est une
priorité monsieur Vallot pour le suivant
oui
défendu monsieur le rapporteur
rapporteur
sur l'amendement 490 donc qui qui vise à
la fois à interdire le placement enc des
enfants mineurs mais ça monsieur le le
ministre a répondu et nous aurons un peu
plus tard dans la discussion n vous
proposerons d'adopter un amendement qui
a présenté par le groupe lot dans ce but
en revanche vous évoquez une autre
situation qui qui paraît importante et
qui sera évoqué d'ailleurs par d'autres
amendements qui sont les personnes qui
présentent une situation de
vulnérabilité que ce soit une femme
enceinte que ce soit les person personn
porteur de handicap et je me permets de
faire cette réponse un peu longue à ce
stade afin qu'elle soit plus plus brève
après l'article
l7414 du czda impose déjà à l'autorité
administrative avant toute décision de
placement en rétention la prise en
compte de l'état de vulnérabilité et de
tout handicap de l'étranger j'insiste
sur le terme de vulnérabilité parce
qu'on va bien au-delà de ce que pourrait
être une une définition peut-être
stricte du handicap ou de la situation
de femme ence cette appréciation est
bien sûr prise sous le contrôle du juge
des dispositions réglementaire ont
organisé également la prise en compte de
cet état de vulnérabilité notamment pour
le placement en rétention spécifiquement
des demandeurs d'asile prévoyant ainsi
qu'indépendamment de l'état de de
l'examen de l'état de vulnérabilité par
l'autorité administrative l'étranger
peut faire l'objet à sa demande d'une
évaluation de son état de vulnérabilité
par l'OFI et en tant que de besoin par
un médecin de l'unité médicale du Centre
de Rétention Administrative peut-être
qu'il est possible d'apporter des
améliorations vous avez vu qu'un certain
nombre relève du domaine réglementaire
c'est pour cela que je j'émettrai un
avis défavorable sur cet amendement mais
en expliquant comme enfin en redisant
pardon que sur la première partie ça
serait plutôt une demande de retrait
puisque des amendements viendront
répondre à cette question et sur la
deuxième je pense que la situation est
largement réglée mais je laisserai
peut-être monsieur le ministre apporter
des des informations complémentaires sur
l'amendement 913 ça sera une demande de
retrait pour les précisions que j'ai
apporté au vu des amendements à venir
monsieur le rapporteur général oui
monsieur Bou mais si c'est monsieur Bou
c'est une décision historique c'est une
décision historique vous pourriez vous
pourriez vous en réjouir simplement
écoutez lorsque nous avons examiné au
mandat précédent et débattu de la loi
colon combien de fois cette mesure aelle
été réclamé par y compris je parle sous
le contrôle d'Elsa fauxillon a été
réclamé par des personnes issues de la
majorité de l'époque je parle sous le
contrôle aussi des Roan balanan et
d'autres encore ou de Stella Dupont
quand combien de membres du Parti
socialiste combien de membres des
écologistes l'ont réclamé mais c'est une
décision historique et vous au lieu de
vous en réjouir vous rappelez même la
jurisprudence du de la Cour européenne
des droits de l'homme et vous montez et
vous montez vous montez doublement oui
oui tout à fait vous montez doublement 1
la directive retour elle autorise la
rétention elle elle autorise même la
rétention jusqu'à 18 mois jusqu'à 18
mois enfin compris enfin compris est-ce
que nous l'appliquons en France
aujourd'ui non la loi colon a permis
d'étendre la durée de rétention mais pas
jusqu'à 18 mois et encore moins pour
tous les enfants monsieur le ministre
vous a répondu il n'y a plus dès à
présent de mineurs en centre de
rétention administrative et est-ce que
nous avons été condamnés par la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme pour
pratiquer à l'époque c'était d'ailleurs
sous François Hollande que nous avons
été condamnés dernière décision 2016
monsieur Bou 2016 nous avons été
condamnés à l'époque l'État français a
été condamné non pas parce que il y
avait une rétention des mineurs mais
parce que les conditions de rétention
des mineurs n'étaient pas acceptables
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
nous étions si nombreux à défendre une
proposition de loi qui n'a pas plus
aboutir et finalement c'est aussi bien
parce que là c'est l'interdiction pure
et simple et que cela vous plaise ou pas
le ministre de l'Intérieur qui aura
interdit la rétention des mineurs dans
lescra qui aura interdit la rétention
des mineurs dans les LRA et jusqu'à 18
ans c'est le ministre de l'Intérieur
actuel monsieur monsieur le
ministre merci
merci à vous donc en effet moi je veux
dire après le rapporteur général et le
rapporteur que c'est évidemment une
décision très très importante et et très
symbolique que nous que nous prenons et
qui encore une fois n'est prise par
aucun autre pays européen à l'exception
de l'Irlande donc je pense qu' l'a très
bien dit Monsieur le monsieur le
rapporteur général on nous oblige pas à
le faire nous le faisons de notre plein
gré et nous le faisons parce que c'est
plus efficace d'abord de de pas le faire
comme ça pour l'éloignement c'est
beaucoup moins traumatisant pour
effectivement ses enfants et dire à
Monsieur Payou mon instruction mais il
le sait très bien pour l'interdiction
des mineurs dans les cras indépendamment
de la loi date d'O 2022 et et que par
ailleurs il faut trouver il fallait
trouver des moyens différents ça se fait
pas comme ça monsieur Bayou mais vous le
savez bien de passer à des milliers
d'enfants qui étaient placés dans un
centre de rétention à des milliers
d'enfants qui sont placés avec leur
famille dans des assignations d'hôtel
voilà c'est pas si évident donc oui j'ai
mis un an et demi à trouver des milliers
de places d'hôtel pour pouvoirlacer ses
familles benah en effet je ne suis pas
je ne suis pas David Copperfield même si
vous me prêtez ce manifestement c'est
c'est pouvoir bon le deuxième sujet je
veux le dire avec beaucoup
d'intérêt nous prendrons les
dispositions en effet qui interdiront
les mineurs de moins de 18 ans je
l'avais déjà évoqué moi je constate
d'abord et je le dis aussi à Monsieur
Dumont que le Sénat a voté cet article
parce que je crois qu'il a été convaincu
d'ailleurs il l'a voté à l'unanimité je
crois qu' y compris avec les deux des
des sénateurs du ressemblement national
d'ailleurs et et Monsieur ravier il a
été il a été combattu euh ils ont été
convaincus pardon les sénateurs sur le
fait que nous avions des alternatives à
l'éloignement par le centre de réttenion
administratif il s'agit pas de mettre
fin à l'éloignement des familles il
s'agit de mettre fin au centre de
rétention administratif pour les
familles c'est extrêmement
différent sur la question des 18 ans
donc je l'avais proposé effectivement
comme de plusieurs groupes centristes et
de gauche du Sénat il n'a pas été tenu
je retiendrai les amendements 18 ans et
les amendements qui évoquent également
la fin de la présence des mineurs de
moins 18 ans dans les lieux de
réttention les fameux LRA don je
rappelle d'ailleurs qu'ils ont aussi été
imaginés par un gouvernement de gauche
puisque c'était jel Jospin qui les avait
créé ce ne veut pas dire qu'on soit bien
clair entre nous qu'on met fin aux
rétentions dans les assignations à
résidence c'estàd que dans les hôtels ou
dans les maisons les domiciles des
personnes qui permettent en effet
d'attendre l'éloignement voilà donc il y
aura toujours il y aura toujours une
assignation à résidence pour ces
familles mais elle se fera dans un cadre
qui n'est pas qualifié de carcéral on
peut pour quiconque a visiter un CRRA
donc je préfère monsieur le rapporteur
et ce n'est pas une logique partisane
l'amendement de Monsieur Pancher et de
Monsieur Castellani qui est le
683 pour l'interdire le placement
général de la rétention des des mineurs
monsieur su de Monsieur Valot est
intéressant mais il écrase le JLD si
j'ose dire euh il il permet de de de de
sortir totalement de notre
fonctionnement de de rétention euh
actuelle avec un JLD qui ne qui ne joue
pas son rôle comme comme il le devrait
et il me semble que l'ement du groupe
lot et notamment de de Monsieur Pancher
qui sera défendu dans quelques instants
et et et est favorable davantage voilà
je pense que c'est la la conception
également du rapporteur général et du
rapporteur on a on a trois interventions
ah pardon on a trois
interventions monsieur Bou madame F
banant et on passera au vot sur cette
discussion généraleci qui n'est pas
celle
sur Oh madame tia ça suffit monsieur Bou
merci merci monsieur le Président moi
c'était moi c'était uniquement pour
répondre au au rapporteur qui m'a traité
de menteur et et et donc je vais vous
répondre et vous demander des
excuses donc vous m'avez
dit parce qu'en fait moi ça me pose un
problème à moi mais ça me pose surtout
un problème au respect de la commission
des lois vous avez dit la directive de
retour 91 vous autorise parfaitement
lisonsla ensemble si vous voulez elle
pose la rétention comme ultime
moyen ça n'est pas le cas en France et
c'est le Sénat c'est un rapport du Sénat
qui le dit maintenant je vous demande de
retirer ce premier euh propos de
mensonger après vous m'avez dit la de la
France n'a pas été condamnée récemment
et je vous ai cité une jurisprudence de
mai 2023 pour une rétention de mai 2021
et monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
vient de vous contredire donc est-ce que
vous voulez non non jurisprudence de mai
2023 condamn ation par la Cour européne
des droits de l'homme pour une rétention
administrative en mai 2021 en en mai
2021 et monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur vient de dire
qu'effectivement depuis 2022 et depuis
sa nomination il y avait eu
effectivement quelques situations vous
pouvez pas contredire monsieur le
ministre et la réalité quand même pas
les deux à la fois donc vraiment j'ai un
problème vous vous ridiculisez et je
vous demande de retirer ces accusations
madame
fussillon merci Monsieur le le Président
si nous allons évidemment continuer à à
nous battre pour que cette interdiction
soit complète c'est-à-dire qu'elle aille
jusqu'à Mayotte et que les enfants et
leur familles aussi à Mayotte ne
puissent être enfermé en centre de
rétention je veux dire aussi que ce
matin et je l'espère jusqu'au bout c'est
une bataille de très longue
haleine qui en réalité fait
qu'aujourd'hui le ministre le
rapporteur finisse en réalité par
accepter que les les enfants et leurs
famillees ne soient plus enfermés en
centre de rétention je je pense par
exemple à Daniel obonau et Marietta
caramanli qui en 2018 avec moi se sont
largement battus et il y en a d'autres y
compris au sein de de la majorité à
l'époque qui se sont battus pour cette
interdiction et je me souviens
d'ailleurs monsieur bouier que comme des
parlementaires au Sénat il y a quelques
semaines ont refusé à cette époque
également nous nous faisions face contre
sur cette interdiction des centres de
rétention je préfère que les choses
changent dans ce sens et que aujourd'hui
ce soit ce soit le cas enfin que demain
ce soit le cas pour que des mineurs ne
soient plus enfermés en centre de
rétention je veux dire qu'évidemment ça
n'efface pas pour nous toutes les autres
choses qu'il y a dans ce texte de loi
monsieur Balanant et ontera oui
c'est il faut se féliciter de ce moment
parce que c'est un combat madame
fossillon vient de le rappeler c'est un
combat qu'on a mené en tout cas moi que
j'ai mené dès mon élection en 2017 et
qu'on avait mené dans le cadre de la loi
asile imigration porté par par par le
regrettter Gérard
colonb Le le je je me souviens même
m'être abstenu sur ce texte dans sur le
vote final parce que nous avions pas
avancé sur ce sujet donc c'est une une
vraie satisfaction et une double
satisfaction et je dois le dire parce
que Monsieur le Ministre dès votre
arrivée vous avez fait des efforts pour
qu'il n'y ait plus d'enfants et c'est ce
qu' n'y a c'est les fait aujourd'hui il
n'y a plus d'enfants il en restait dans
les LRA et et vous prenez l'engagement
aujourd'hui que même dans les LRA et
c'est compliqué aussi pour vous à mettre
en place je le sais vous prenez cet
engagement et c'est un engagement quand
même qui est un engagement fort et je
trouve que
collectivement malgré nos différences
nos partis parfois opposé nous pourrions
tous au moins nous féliciter et et noter
que c'est une avancée très forte pour
les droits des enfants dans ce pays et
donc c'est avec une grande satisfaction
que je vois voterai les amendements que
vous avez proposé j'aiété trop timide
dans dans ma dans mon écriture dans
alors le rapporteur général va dire un
mot on votera en raant que ce n'est pas
cette discussion générale c'est les
amendements de cette discussion générale
qui ont reçu un avis favorable oui je je
confirme monsieur bon vous avez menti et
vous allez continué dans votre réponse
parce que le droit français aujourd'hui
il ne changera pas de ce point de vue
c'est le principe c'est la signation et
la rétention n'est utilisée que pour
l'éloignement et dans les cas très
restrictifs d'ailleurs raison pour la il
n'y a aujourd'hui que 1500 places de
rétention administrative et 3000 demain
et pas des dizaines de milliers donc
bien sûr qu'en France vous avez dit le
contraire tout à l'heure bien sûr qu'en
France la rétention n'est pas le
principe c'est d'abord l'assignation et
c'est la rétention ensuite et puis je
continue à dire que vous avez travesti
la réalité si vous préférez cette
expression qui consiste à dire que la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
aurait condamné la France par principe
sur la rétention même des enfants ce
n'est pas le cas ce n'est pas le cas
elle a condamné la France non pas sur le
principe de la rétention des familles
mais ce qui n'empêche pas que nous
souhaitons l'interdire quand même il y a
pas d'obligations européennes
d'interdiction elle l'a toujours
condamné sur les conditions d'accueil
dans les centres de réttention et la
décision auquelle à laquelle vous faites
référence en 2022 2023 qui correspond à
une rétention de 2021 elle ne porte même
pas d'ailleurs sur les conditions de
rétention mais peu importe ça n'est pas
plus acceptable sur le temps long de la
rétention et uniquement sur ce principe
là et non pas sur la rétention elle-même
donc attention je pense que il faut
connaître le sujet je pense qu'on est
quelquesuns ici de à le connaître depuis
très longtemps pour savoir à quel point
en effet ce que nous faisons ce matin je
le rappelle interdiction dans les cras
interdiction dans les LRA pour toute
personne tout mineur jusqu'à 18 ans oui
je vous confirme C historique et vous
devriez encore vous en réjouir alors on
va voter ces deux amendements avec qui
ont des avis défavorables du rapporteur
qui votre pour le premier de Monsieur
Bou qui votre contre rejeté le suivant
de Monsieur monsieur Vallot qui vote
pour contre rejeté on entame une autre
discussion commune qui défend
l'amendement du rassemblement national
le 400
oui monsieur le
Président l'article 12 pris en ses
alinéas 3 à 6 vise à faire en sorte
qu'un étranger accompagnant un mineur de
de 16 ans ne puisse être placé en
rétention administrative cette ne se
justifie pas alors qu'elle empêche un
réel contrôle de l'immigration et que le
placement en rétention si les centres
sont correctement aménagé n'est pas
incompatiblees avec la présence de
mineurs de 16 ans et les personnes les
accompagnant dans nos circonscription je
l'imagine on ouvre tous les journaux
locaux et on voit tous les jours des
mamis qui se font agressés par des
jeunes de 16 à 18 ans étrangers
clandestins on voit ces jeunes filles
qui se font violer on voit ces magasins
qui sont braqués les faits divivers les
faits divivers dans la presse montre
très clairement qu'il y a une
délinquence importante avec les
clandestins étranger et juste 5 secondes
pour répondre à Monsieur le Ministre sur
l'assignation à résidence ça me paraît
important monsieur le Président j'en
termine c'est très court c'est un échec
c'est un échec au CR de nî la dernière
fois que j'y suis allé monsieur Dumont
je laisser 15 secondes de plus merci
monsieur le Président bon on a bien
compris l'enjeu ici l'enjeu c'est pour
le gouvernement pour Monsieur le
Ministre de donner un biscuit à l'aile
gauche de la majorité afin de faire
voter ce texte la réalité c'est quoi
c'est qu'il s'agit et vous l'avez dit
c'est une surtransposition on est sur
une surtransposition d'une directive
européenne et en faisant cela pardon de
le dire vous êtes en train de faire le
lit du rassemblement national puisque le
R remblement national fera quoi il fera
campagne en disant regardez l'Europe
nous empêche deux et cetera alors que
vous êtes en train de surtransposer vous
êtes en train de mettre la France dans
une situation où elle pourra pardon de
le dire et je le répète moins bien
exécuter les mesures d'éloignement c'est
pas la question d'éloigner des mineurs
c'est la question d'éloigner les
familles des mineurs et l'assignation à
résidence n'est pas une rétention
habituelle dans un centre de rétention
administratif et donc on est dans cette
situation où cette surtransposition
risque malheureusement un d'envoyer un
mauvais signal qui à l'ÉE des élections
européennes fera lit du populisme
d'extrême droite et d'autre part de
limiter nos capacités de renvoir mon
çaa merci monsieur le Président
amendement du président Pancher Liot
c'est un marqueur important de notre
groupe après la départementalisation des
mesures pour les métiers en tenstion
chers collègues j'ai une fille de 17 ans
a priori française mais enfin elle a la
même couleur de peau que moi et vous
imaginez bien parfois les amalgames qui
peuvent être faits c'est quoi MNA je
trouve ce terme très la je vais enfin
vous le savez ça s'appelle un mineur non
accompagné très bien et un mineur non
accompagné dans la définition c'est
marqué enfant de moins de 18 ans de
nationalité étrangère qui n'est pas
accompagné d'un adulte et donc
voyez-vous le groupe lot nous voulons
une loi tion intégration équilibrée ni
laxiste ni monstrueuse et nous ne
voulons pas une loi de
déséquilibré et donc cet amendement vise
à dire que aucun enfant aucun enfant on
parle bien d'enfant vous avez tous vu ou
connu ou eu des enfants ne doit être
mise en rétention du seul fait qu'il
soit
étranger merci Monsieur min voulez nous
dire quelque chose avant de ouis Duon je
partage
pas votre
propos ça arrive et vous savez que j'ai
pour vous de l'estime et de l'amitié pas
simplement régionale mais je je pense
que je pense que vous pourriez me porter
je pense que vous pourriez porter ce
crédit qu'il m'arrive de penser et de
proposer des choses indépendamment d'un
texte de loi c'est tellement vrai que
monsieur balanan l'a dit lui-même je me
suis exprimé sur la rétention des
mineurs dès mon arrivée au ministère de
l'intérie ailleurs en 2020 et j'ai pris
une instruction bien avant la création
de ce projet de loi déposé en Conseil
d'État donc ne faisons pas croire un
seul instant que cet article est un
équilibre politique ça peut m'arriver
bien évidemment mais mais pas le cas
pour trois raisons d'abord je pense
avoir visité la quasi intégralité des
centres de rétention de notre pays al
vous en visitez beaucoup mais sauf que
par mes fonctions de ministre d'
l'intérieur je les ai quasiment
toutouses visité d'ailleurs je je
constaterai avec vous pour être de très
nombreuses fois allé à Mayotte et
continuer à y aller que le centre de
rétention de Mayotte n'est pas comp
comparable à celui du M lamelot ou celui
de l'quin ou celui de Vincen c'est
toujours un moment difficile que vivre
dans un centre de rétention
administratif quelques jours mais c'est
pas le cas de de celui de de grand de
Petite Terre à Mayotte qui qui est
objectivement très différent des autres
donc je le dis pour nos débats je sais
pas si tout le monde a visité ce centre
de rétention administratif mais c'est
pas un lieu carcéral comme il peut y en
être sur le territoire
hexagonal deuxièmement je ne pense pas
que ce soit un service à à ses futurs
adultes que de laisser des enfants de 3
4 5 6 ans qui sont en construction
psychologique et
mentale parfois des des jours des
semaines et et des mois avec des gens
qui sont aujourd'hui monsieur Dumont
parce que c'est ce qui a changé
fondamentalement avec cette décision
c'est le fait qu'on a changé la nature
d'cra des personnes fichées pour
radicalisation condamné pour terrorisme
à 90% 99 % des hommes 99 % des hommes et
tout tous en tout cas dans l'Hexagone
condamnés à des actes criminels
élictuels je ne pense que ce n'est pas
un bon signe pour leur construction
mentale et psychologique et je pense que
nous construisons des bombes humaines à
les laisser dans ces centres de
rétention administratif où ils peuvent
connaître des attouchements où ils
peuvent connaîre des viols où ils
peuvent connaître évidemment des cris
des violences des violences contre les
personnes des positeurs d'autorité
publique parce que les policiers de la
PAF on doit les honorer de faire ce
travail dans ces centres de rétention
c'est très difficile ou les gendarmes à
Lyon très difficile et je ne suis pas
sûr que quand on change la nature du
centre de Ré administratif qui a depuis
4 5 ans changé puisqu'on y met en eff
faet des gens radicalisés des gens
condamnés pour terrorisme ou des gens
violents que des hommes c'est pas un bon
signne d' mettre des enfants de 3 4 5 6
ans voilà c'est peut-être aussi le jeune
père de famille qui qui vous parle mais
je pense pas que 2 3 ans alors qu'on a
on apprend on pe l'assemblée national
peut pas à la fois dire que les 1000
premiers jours sont importants dans la
vie et les enfermer dans un centre de
rét administratif avec des fichiers ça
me paraît incompatible donc ça dépend ce
qu'on veut soit on veut continuer à
créer des possibles bombes humaines tous
tous sont pas bain enfin une partie vont
con des traumatismes évidents voilà et
et on sait pas ce qu'il feront C ces
enfants devenus adolescents puis adultes
à 5 15 20 25 ans 30 ans où est-ce qu'on
veut considérer que bah un adulte c'est
pas un mineur et que un mineur dans un
centre de rétention où il y a que des
gens dangereux bah c'est pas le bon
moyen de de s'éduquer et de vivre bon
deuxièmement monsieur Dumon j'ai essayé
de vous démontrer et je suis tout à fait
prêt d'ailleurs à le justifier et je
peux comprendre cette interrogation que
ce n'est pas un frein à l'éloignement
cette année nous avons mis je crois sur
le territoire national de mémoire si je
parle que de l'Hexagone encore une
cinquantaine d'enfants mineurs dans les
centres de rétention pour quelques
heures ou quelques jours voilà soit
parce que quelques policiers ou préfet
n'appliquent pas les décisions ad
litéram que j'ai posé donc j'ai demandé
évidemment
leur leur leur départ de centre de
rétention soit parce qu'il y avait pas
d'autres moyens il y avait pas assez
pour l'instant de place d'hôtel que ce
que nous terminons de de construire nous
avons amélioré pourtant on verra les
chiffres de d'année de 5 à 10 %
l'éloignement encore des familles alors
que nous faisons nous mettons plus
d'enfants dans les centres de rétention
c'est bien qu'on est capable de
réquisitionner des hôtels ou dans les
appartements mêmees on met des policiers
devant la porte de l'hôtel devant la
porte de l'appartement pour dire bah
voilà on vous assigne que demain vous
prenez l'avion à 7h à partir de horlye
et on regarde que les gens s'en aillent
pas la fin des mineurs dans les centres
de réttion administratif ne veut pas
dire la naïveté de gens qui pourraient
utiliser d'avoir des mineurs pour pour
se détourner administrative je n'ai
jamais dit que je ne voulais pas
éloigner les familles avec enfants j'ai
dit que je voulais pas le faire dans des
conditions de traumatisme c'est très
différent et nous arrivons puisque la
démonstration du pudding étant qu'il se
mange cette année nous avons pas de
mineur dans dans centre de rétion
administratif on fera entre 5 et 10 %
d'loign plus de famille c'est donc que
cette mesure non seulement je crois est
profondément humaine elle elle garde
profondément la possibilité de ne pas
donner à des enfants qui ne sont pas en
rien responsables à 3 4 ans du
comportement de leurs parents en aucun
cas y compris dans lesirrégularités du
séjour en aucun cas descstructions
mentales et psychologiqu voire physique
qui feraiit que demain il serait
profondément marqué par cela voilà donc
voilà je vous le dis en toute franchise
je n'ai pas pris cette proposition qui
il est vrai n'était pas porté par les
services du ministère de l'Intérieur je
veux bien dire volontiers que c'est une
décision politique c'est tout à fait
vrai chacun sait les réflexes pe avoir
le ministère de l'intérieur parce que
évidemment il y a une habitude et je
peux tout à fait le comprendre mais pour
avoir visité des tas de des tas de
centres de rétenion administratif il
faut des enfants 3 4 ans voyez des des
types radicalisés crier dans la dans la
chamb parce que vous savez comment ça
fonctionne dans la vitre juste à côté
d'eux agresser leur mère les agresser
eux-mêmes pour les avoir vu physiquement
je pense qu'on peut pas le faire quand
on est un homme ou une femme digne de ce
nom et qui aime la République voilà
s'empêche pas d'avoir une grande fermeté
contre les derni camp étranger et je
vais vous dire c'est pas c'est pas un en
même temps c'est une efficacité d'être
dur contre les étrangers délincants et
de comprendre qu'on peut pas mettre des
mineurs de 3 ans dans des CR quand il y
a des radicalisés dedans voilà c'est
tout ça me paraît assez évident donc en
plus je terminerai par dire que ça
libère des places si j'étais absolument
cynique en vous disant que bah moi on
fait de mineurs moins on fait de femmes
accompagné dans leur enfant plus on fait
de délinquants étrangers qui sont
essentiellement des hommes plus j'ai de
place et plus je les écartte de l'espace
public et donc plus je fais baisser les
taux de délinquence on reprend le cours
de la discussion commune par
l'amendement 914 du groupe
socialiste oui oui merci monsieur le
président et on l'a dit Monsieur le
Ministre effectivement l'interdiction de
de placement du placement rétention de
mineurs de 16 ans telle qu'elle est
prévu par le projet de loi est une
mesure évidemment positive vous l'avez
rappelé mais en retenant le seuil de
saison le gouvernement reste au milieu
de du chemin c'est pour cette raisonlà
que l'amendement que nous
présentons vise à étendre finalement le
le champ des dispositions de l'article
12 au mineur de plus de 16 ans et de sur
croit la mesure de ne serait pas limitée
au sols locaux des centres de rétention
administrative il est manifestement
insuffisante cette mesure interdisant
cette rétention au mineurs de moins de
16 ans et ne visant que les
crin monsieur Lucas le 1 38 madame orol
ouais
eu tout a été dit par ma collègue
Caraman mais je je note quand même que
la
persévérance est une bonne valeur
puisque elle nous permet arriver enfin à
envisager que les mineurs de moins de 16
ans ne soient plus
euh placé en rétention euh cependant il
y a besoin d'efficacité d'aller plus
loin dans la façon dont c'est explicité
pour qu'il n'y ait plus de doute
possible d'où ces amendements euh après
j'ai envie de vous dire que si 16 ans
devient la nouvelle majorité alors
offrons le droit de vote aux jeunes du
même âge et soyons cohérents mais ne
retirons pas d'un côté ce qui est déjà
retiré de
l'autre Monsieur B le
1336 c'était en réalité je il y a
quelqu'un voilà excusez-moi cel oui non
mais ça y est j'ai
compris oui donc en réalité vu comment
on avait écrit notre dispositif que
disais tout à l'heure j'ai j'ai été
presque trop timide je je pensais qu'on
allait gagner excusez-moi du du terme un
peu sportif qu'on allait gagner sur les
CRRA et et je je ne pensais pas qu'on
allait gagner sur les LRA et donc c'est
une satisfaction mais une vraie
satisfaction c'est même plus que ça
c'est un bonheur c'est un bonheur je le
dis c'est un combat de 6 ans sur ce sur
cette question mais aussi sur d'autres
pour le droit des enfants et donc je je
je suis presque ému je vous le dis et je
remercie vraiment Florent bouer pour bah
écoutez excusez-moi on parle d'enfants
on parle d'enfants et je crois que le
ministre l'a dit a bien décrit les
choses évidemment ça fait ricaner le
Front
national toujours amoureux de la haine
tout le temps et moi je vous le dis je
suis ému les enfants de notre dans notre
pays seront mieux protégés et je redis
un merci au ministre un merci à Florent
bouier et un merci ai à Elsa fossillon
pour avoir mené ce combat et phppead le
rapporteur évidemment qui Monsieur
Madame jeunevard ce sont deux
amendements identiques de votre groupe
oui merci monsieur le Président donc
c'est un amendement d'Éric
cotti cet article 12 mais fin à la
présence de mineurs de 16 ans dans les
centres de rétention
administrative et cet amendement refuse
de conférer une immunité absolue contre
la rétention d'étranger adulte en
situation irrégulière au seul motif
qu'il serait accompagné d'un mineur et
ce pour éviter que les adultes ne se
soustrait à leur éloignement alors j'ai
entendu monsieur le ministre vos
réservve sur les dangers du placement
des enfants dans des cras je voudrais
dire d'abord que tous les mineurs ne
sont pas des
enfants c'est pour ça qu'on parle de
mineurs il y a des il y a des grands
enfant aussi parmi les mineurs bah oui
donc le terme mineur est
inapproprié
mais il me semble important de rappeler
que la présence d'un enfant auprès d'un
adulte en situation irrégulière ou d'un
mineur ne peut pas être un motif à
affaiblir le l'éloignement de cet adulte
et donc j'espère l'efficacité dans les
locaux adaptés de rétention
administrative par rapport au centre de
rétention administrative Monsieur Ban
nous reste votre amendement de
1388 oui c'était donc c'était
l'amendement le plus complet l'écriture
proposée par Monsieur Pancher et
soutenue par par le rapporteur Pradal me
va très bien mais juste juste redire une
chose et en toute amitié à jeunevard ce
qui fait ce qui fait le fait d'être
adulte c'est d'avoir sans doute plus de
18 ans peut-être parfois on est un petit
peu avant mais parfois un petit peu
après mais en tout cas l'adulte il se
doit il a une mission dans notre société
c'est de protéger les
et donc de protéger tous ceux qui sont
vulnérables qui sont plus faibles et
donc qu'ils aient on on a fixé que
c'était 18 ans la fin de
l'enfance en tout cas d'un point de vue
juridique donc je crois pas qu'on puisse
se dire qu'il y a des grands enfants il
y a des enfants qui ont 18 ans et
d'autres qui n'ont pas 18 ans voilà tout
simplement alors monsieur le rapporteur
vos avis sur cette discussion
commune merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président un bref moi pour donner très
rapidement les avis vie je crois qu' il
y a des moments qui sont importants
parce qu'on adopte des textes que l'on
juge importants et des moments qui sont
importants par la justification que nous
donnons aux décisions que nous prenons
et je voulais remercier le ministre de
l'Intérieur bien sûr pour l'appui et les
décisions politiques qui nous conduisent
aujourd'hui à adopter ces textes avec
les amendements mais également par par
la justification qu'il en a donné qui me
paraît éclairer et peut-être rendre plus
simple plus efficace et donner un peu de
de dignité politique à un article qui
aurait pu paraître pour un article
technique et qui en fait une une réalité
tout autre les avis rapidement donc le
400 et le 989 avis défavorable parce que
je suis convaincu qu'il faut procéder
c'est ce que nous faisons à une à une
réforme utile et importante de
la du placement en CR des mineurs le
ralliment annoncé donc à à l'amendement
683 Cigné par le groupe présenté par le
président Pancher qui par sa rédaction
permet d'englober les deux dimensions
que nous
souhaitons absorber et ce qui est
justifié par le ralliment à cet
amendement puisque il rappelle la
proscription du placement en lieu de
rétention et en cras des mineur de 18
ans réglant ainsi les les deux sujets
donc ce qui me conduit à émettre une
demande de retrait pour le 914 le 1038
et a exprimé avec l'accord du rapporteur
général un retrait de l'amendement 1668
que j'avais déposer avec lui sur le
sujet sur l'amendement 914 il s'agira et
vous le comprendrez d'une demande de
retrait puisque il paraît satisfait s'il
adop si le 683 est doit adopter même
position pour le 1038 même position pour
le
12336 et pour les amendements 475 et 805
qui vont plutôt à rebours des
despositions qui ont été adopté par cet
amendement 683 un avis défavorable et
pour terminer en le remerciant de ses
propos un un avis une demande de retrait
ou à des fois un avis défavorable pour
l'amendement présenté par Monsieur
balanan le 1338 madame
yousoufa merci monsieur le Président
pour compléter les propos qui ont été
tenus le CRAT de Mayotte est
effectivement le plus grand de France
avec un quartier particulier pour les
familles compte tenu du caractère
spécifique de l'immigration à Mayotte je
voudrais rappeler que si on ne permet
pas que les enfants soient expulsés avec
leurs parents ces enfants sont
abandonnés ce n'est pas de l'imagination
ni de la fiction c'est la réalité
actuellement à Mayotte et ça dure depuis
une dizaine d'années avec maintenant des
bandes constituées par ces jeunes qui
sont et et je pense que nous pourrons
tous être d'accord là-dessus en
situation d'une immense détresse donc il
ne s'agit pas par une décision nationale
dans un contexte que nous entendons bien
à Mayotte
de de mettre fin à une exception qui se
justifie par la réalité à Mayotte et qui
est impérative je je je dis ici les
choses ne mettez pas fin à cette
exception sinon nous aurons encore plus
de mineurs abandonnés à Mayotte et
encore plus de dangerosité pour eux
comme pour la population je vous
remercie madame obodo
oui merci monsieur le
Président en fait on se rend compte dans
ce débat à quel point le centre de
gravité
politique dans ce pays a tellement
dérivé vers l'extrême
droite pas à l'insu du plingré des force
politique parce que le choix notamment
de la macronie l'a fait dérivé que on en
arrive comme ça a été dit à exiger qu'on
remercie le fait de respecter les droits
fondamentaux des personnes des enfants
et je pense que c'est assez révélateur
ce débat non non ce n'est pas une grande
victoire que de revenir à ce qui devrait
être des fondamentaux de notre
République de revenir au respect du des
droits fondamentaux des enfants et
l'équilibre que vous faites entre la
droite et l'extrême droite parce que moi
je crois sincèrement à ce que vous dites
collègue balanan je crois qu'il y a une
droite humaniste et qui est sincèrement
révoltée par l' l'enfermement mais je ne
crois pas qu'on doit se réjouir qu'on en
arrive à un tel débat et il fa donner
des médailles pour respecter les droits
fondamentaux des enfants don oui une
partie de l'enfance et a jamais gâché et
déchiré et traumatisé parce qu'ils sont
suivis dans les CRA et aussi dans dans
la
chasse oui très rapidement deux chose la
première une réponse au ministre même si
il n'est plus là il parlait tout à
l'heure des assignations à résidence il
faut le rappeler les assignations à
résidence en lieu et place de la
rétention en CR ça ne fonctionne pas je
vous prends un exemple d' fois je suis
allé au CRAT de nî il y avait une
personne sous qtf placée en CRAT qui
était à son 87e jour donc libérable 3
jours après dangereux euh présumé
fortement islamiste et bien à sa sortie
il n'a pas été expulsé il a été mis en
détention en pardon en assignation à
résidence évidemment 3 jours après on
avait plus de trace de lui puis personne
ne savait où il était voilà la première
chose deuxième chose il faut le rappeler
il n'y aurait pas besoin de placement en
rétention en cras si on était efficace
sur les expulsions c'est à cet égard
qu'on vous proposera dans dans les
prochains amendements dans les prochains
articles des sanctions notamment pour
les pays qui ne délivrent pas les
laisser passer consulair ces pays
doivent être sanctionnés et si on est
efficace sur les expulsions et bien on
aura besoin finalement de moins de place
en CR monsieur
Castellani merci président mot je
voudrais remercier les rapporteurs et
préciser l'esprit qui qui a présidé à la
rédaction de notre amendement qui vient
d'être présenté excellemment par Olivier
serva ce que je voudrais dire c'est pas
de l'angélisme on connaît les les
difficultés des choses on connaît la la
variété des situations qui s'oppose
souvent à nous mais ce que je voudrais
dire c'est que les mineurs sont des
personnes fragiles le sort qui leur est
réservé engage leur vie future et que
notre devoir est de les préserver du
mieux possible de limiter les
traumatismes de les engager autant que
possible dans une voie de vie positive
voilà c'est une question qui est très
difficile très difficile sur le plan
technique sur le plan matériel sur le
plan humain mais c'est ce qui doit
dicter avant tout notre notre avancée
c'est cette dimension humaine voilà ce
que je voulais dire monsieur
Dumont la réalité c'est qu'il y a eu un
raisonnement peu par l'absurde du
ministre de
l'intérieur on peut entendre la question
des 3 4 6 ans pour reprendre son
expression mais la volonté de la
majorité du gouvernement c'est de mettre
des même interdire à des individus de 16
à 18 ans d'être à l'intérieur des cras
pardon mais un individu de 16 ans est
beaucoup plus proche d'un jeune majeur
que d'un enfant ou un bébé de 3 ans et
que donc cette cette ce raisonnement qui
a été mis en place par le ministre de
l'Intérieur contredit la volonté de la
majorité de vouloir étendre le
dispositif à l'ensemble des mineurs à
côté de ça on a un autre sujet qui est
la volonté de passer avec des cras qui
ne servent plus à préparer l'expulsion
mais à enfermer des ESI qui sont des
troubles à l'ordre publicque avec des
agents de la PAF à l'intérieur des cras
qui ne sont pas formés pour gérer ce
genre d'individu et donc on peut plus y
mettre en rétention des personnes qui
elle ne demande rien à personne et ont
comme seul tort d'être en situation
régulière et qu'on doit donc renvoyer et
dans cette situation qui doit inciter je
pense à une réflexion plus large sur
est-ce que N va pas créer un nouveau
type de CR un CR spécial pour les tops
et un CR plus classique tel qu'il avait
été imaginé ces 30 dernières années
monsieur
Baladan amendements je crois pardon oui
oui je je vais retirer évidemment les
les le le 1336 et le 1338 au bénéfice de
l'amendement de Monsieur Pancher le
683 très bien Madame Dupont
oui merci monsieur le Président moi je
regrette les propos de Madame auonau he
se refusant à saluer cette décision
d'interdiction de rétention des enfants
et des mineurs de moins de 18 ans je
pense que c'est une action
transpartisane parlementaire qui s'est
qui a été mené avec ténacité qui est
aujourd'hui soutenu par le ministre de
l'Intérieur et je salue cette décision
également et ce choix mais ça fait 5 ans
qu'on y travaille ardemment on a on a
rien lâché et je pense que vous voyez
aujourd'hui encore les collègues des
républicains ou du rassemblement
national restent totalement opposés à
cette perspective donc moi contrairement
à vous je suis fi de cette bataille
parlementaire humaniste qu'on a su mener
et qu'on a su gagner donc voilà bravo à
tous tout simplement et donc on passe au
vote je commence par l'amendement 1400
du rassemblement national avec avis
défavorable du rapporteur qui vote pour
qui vote contre rejeté le suivant de
Monsieur Dumont qui vote pour qui vote
contre rejeté et on en vient à
l'amendement
683 de Monsieur Pancher ave avis
favorable du rapporteur qui vote pour
qui vote contre il est adopté alors il
fait tomber la quasi-ttalité des
amendements à l'article à l'exception du
dernier le
1187 qui est celui de Madame
kerbidi madame Fillon le dernier de la
je vous en prie
[Musique]
11 défendu excusez-moi alors monsieur le
rapporteur défavorable vous y êtes
défavorable je le mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est rejeté c'est
l'article 12 qui vient d'être réécrit
par l'amendement de Monsieur pchet que
je mets à vos scrutin à vos suffrages
qui vote pour qui vote contre il est
adopté le après l'article 12 de
l'amendement 100 de Monsieur Lucas ou de
madame regol je sais
pas merci merci monsieur le Président
écoutez nous souhaitons que so consid
comme lieu de rétention administrative
tout lieu dans lequel un Primot arrivant
est maintenu en rétention on se la vise
à limiter les atteintes portées au droit
des Primot arrivant notamment en matière
de de rétention parfois arbitraire et en
dehors de tout cadre légal monsieur le
rapporteur avis avis défavorable avis
défavorable je le mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est rejeté
amendement suivant le 1114 madame madame
regol euh
c'est amendem de ma collègue Sandrine
Rousseau qui vise à interdire le
placement en rétention des étrangers en
situation de handicap un droit qui
devrait être tout
droit identique du groupe socialiste
madame
caramandli ma collègue elle a très bien
défendu aussi cette idée qui consiste à
rappeler que la situation des handicapé
n'ont pas n'ont pas finalement leur
place dans ces lieux de rétention
monsieur le rapporteur merci monsieur le
Président comme j'ai pu le dire en début
de de discussion sur cet article je
pense que la situation des personnes
porteurs de handicap renvoie plutôt à la
situation des personnes vulnérables et
de la compatibilité de leur état de
vulnérabilité avec le placement en lieu
de rétention ou en centre de rétention
les dispositions que j'ai rappelé
actuell du czda permettent de régler un
certain nombre de situations je pense
qu'il y a peut-être des des évolutions à
prévoir et ce que je voulais vous
proposer c'est qu'on puisse d'ici la
séance continuer à travailler sur ce
sujet avec les services du ministre pour
voir comment on peut organiser peut-être
une écriture qui paraisse plus
rassurante même si des dispositions
existent aujourd'hui donc ça sera une
demande de retrait à des fois avis
défavorable alors j'ai j'ai oublié un
amendement de la la discussion commune
qui était signée par Monsieur PAVI mais
je sais pas qui le défend monsieur Lucas
peut-être merci monsieur le Président
cet amendement de notre collègue petavi
vise à interdire le placement en
rétention administratif pour les
personnes dont l'état de santé est
particulièrement incompatible avec une
telle mesure t que les personnes en
situation de handicap enceinte ou malade
nous rappelons que paréant la rétention
est fondamentalement incompatible avec
la santé et le bien-être tant physique
que psychologique c'est d'autant plus le
cas lorsque les conditions de vie ou
plutôt de survie ils sont manifestement
indignes comme dans les cras la
Contrôleur général des lieux de
privation liberté liberté pardon a ainsi
constaté des problèmes généralis
généralisés de chauffage de sanitaires
insalubres des difficultés d'accès aux
soins et même un manque de nourriture la
simade a elle-même ressensé des cas de
rétention intolérable d'une
ressortissante chinoise très âgée et
handicapé d'un homme incapable
d'utiliser les toilettes en raison d'un
handicap ou d'une femme enceinte de 8
mois la rétention des personnes avec des
troubles psychiques issu de multiples
traumatismes est encore plus compliqué
si bien que lorsque la situation n'est
plus tenable la personne est soit
hospitalisée soit transférée ailleurs
soit remise en liberté par le juge la
rétention étant manifestement pas
adaptée comment sommes-nous arrivés à
traiter des êtres humains d'une telle
façon monsieur le rapporteur votre avis
est défavorable également oui c'est ça
retrezou défavorable pour les raisons
que que j'ai exposé plusôt et si
Monsieur Lucas me permet de ne pas les
réexprimer madame
martant mais au fond c'est presque pire
votre réponse c'est-à-dire que vous
dites la question n'est pas d'être
porteur de handicap la question est de
prendre en compte la
vulnérabilité des personnes moi
évidemment je partage cela mais il
faudrait nous dire en quoi et encore une
fois lors de des nombreus visite que
nous avons fait dans l'écra que nous
avons fait aussi dans ce lieu de mise à
l'abri je vous garantis je vous lâcherai
pas là-dessus parce qu'il y a un moment
faut quand même nous respecter et il
faut répondre aux questions qu'on pose
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce lieu cendroit
nitide dans lequel on enferme là pour le
coup des mineurs des petits des grands
des isolés des pas isolés des femmes
enceintes enfin hein tout ce que tout ce
que vous pouvez imaginer bref donc si
c'est la question de la vulnérabilité
des personnes qui est prise en compte
c'est encore pire et lors d'une visite
dans un CCK qui était je crois
saintexupéri 2 pour répondre en
particulier à la vulnérabilité psychique
moi je sais pas comment vous dire les
choses la proposition c'est de
cachetonner les gens c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire et de les cachetonner
à fond les ballons pardon pardon de
parler comme ça donc si on est sur les
questions de vulnérabilité répondez-nous
alors du coup
sur ce concept qui est plus
extensif
merci merci monsieur le rapporteur pour
votre réponse j'ai pas compris ce qu'
fond ce que vous trouvez pas clair dans
la rédaction mais j'ai en revanche très
bien compris la main tendue qui qui est
que vous vous engagez à ce qu'il a une
réécriture fait avec vous le rapporteur
général et les services du ministre afin
que ce qu'on demande à savoir les
personnes en situation fragile
d'handicap physique visible ou
invisible puissent être intégré de façon
formelle dans le texte donc j'acte le
fait que ce sera intégré pour la séance
merci
retirez ou vous le
maintenezt mainten alors le premier
amendement celui de monsieur Rousseau
madame rousse et Monsieur Vall je les
mets au voix qui vote pour qui vote
contre rejeté le suivant de Monsieur PAV
qui vote pour qui vote contre rejeté
monsieurou vous avez le 48 oui
rapidement merci monsieur le Président
pour en fait revenir sur les duréugé
2018 par la loi qui porte mal son nom
asile et immigration euh et qui prévoit
de d'augmenter considérablement le temps
de rétention administrative on a vu
qu'en fait ça s'accompagnait
mécaniquement d'une durée équivalente de
moyenne de temps de rétention et
disons-nous les choses concrètement pour
moi c'est évidemment un amendement de
repli de repli mais vous enfin si vous
gardez aussi longtemps les gens puisque
vous ne pouvez pas les expulser faute de
laisser passer consulaire en fait on on
en sortira jamais et donc autant revenir
même si c'est un amendement d'appel à
des durées plus
raisonnables monsieur le rapporteur
oui vous l'avez dit vousmême Monsieur B
un abandement d'appel donc je vous
inviter à le retirer d'autant plus que
le l'article visé le 7428 du czda
notamment ne porte pas sur le sujet et
pourrait créer une complication
rédactionnelle et légistique s'il était
adopté donc pour ces deux raisons et
puis peut-être pour vous laisser le
temps de le retravailler je vous propose
de le retirer sinon avis défavorable je
mets au voix qui vote pour qui vote
contre il est rejeté madame caramand il
y a deux amendements identiques du
groupe socialiste oui tout d'abord par
cet amendement le groupe insiste sur
deux trois points particulièrement sur
l'introduction de la précision selon
laquelle le placement d'un étranger dans
un local de rétention administrative ne
veut ne peut avoir qu'un caractère
exceptionnel et qu'il prévoit que qu'un
étranger ne peut être maintenu dans un
local de rétention si le juge décide de
la prolongation justement de la
rétention enfin on demande aussi à ce
qu'on puisse garantir la publicité de
ces lieux et donc le préfet devrait
devra communiquer sans délai au
procureur et au contrôleur général des
lieu de privation de liberté l'arrêté
portant création de ce local de
rétention informer également les
parlementaires du département de sorte à
ce qu'ils puissent aussi exercer leur
droit de visite et enfin l'amendement
aussi vise à garantir que les droits de
l'étranger retenus dans un local de
rétention administrative ne soi pas
inférieur à ceux dont il bénéficie dans
un centre de rétention
administrative monsieur le rapporteur
sur ces deux amendements alors sur le
917 ça sera une un avis défavorable
puisqueen fait les la la définition et
l'organisation relève du pouvoir
réglementaire et vous savez à à quel
point il est risqué en application
l'article 34 de la Constitution que la
loi se mèle de ce qui est réservé au
pouvoir réglementaire donc avis
défavorable et sur le 919 la la
rédaction et l'exposé sommaire paraisse
comporter des zones d'imprécision
importantes qui le rendrait uneopérant
c'est pour cela que j'ai mets un avis
défavorable alors je mets successivement
voie les amendements le 917 avis
défavorable qui vote pour contre
rejeté le 919 qui vote pour qui vote
contre rejeté Madame Dupont le 1443 ou
merci monsieur le Président euh alors on
vient effectivement de prendre des
décisions d'importance avec
l'interdiction de la rétention des
enfants et des mineurs de moins de 18
ans en centre de rétention
administrative cet amendement vise à
prolonger cette interdiction en zone
d'attente qui sont des lieux clos et
également inadaptés à l'accueil
d'enfants et je viens d'en visiter tout
récemment il me semble utile et
nécessaire dans cette logique de respect
et de protection de l'enfance tout
simplement d'élargir cette interdiction
à ces zones d'attente spécifiques
merci
rapporteur là nous évoquons le sujet des
zones d'attente qui ne visent pas des
personnes qui sont rentrées en
franceusement l'objectif de la zone
d'attente est une mesure administrative
différente du placement en rétention et
s'applique au moment du contrôle à la
frontière il ne s'agit pas de
l'exécution de mesure d'éloignement
elles sont par définition placées à
proximité du lieu où la personne est
entrée sur le territoire national et la
durée est strictement nécessaire pour
permettre le départ de l'étranger
aujourd'hui ces placements sont limités
à 4 jours et peut-être mangé dans
certains cas de 8 jours supplémentaires
à titre exceptionnel la différence de
régime et la différence d'objectif visé
me conduit à émettre un avis défavorable
à votre
amendement je le mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est rejeté on en
vient au 12 B 1 avec des amendements de
suppression madame
caramanli allez oui oui voà ça cet
amendement effectivement euh voilà c'est
pour supprimer cet article 12 bis euh
effectivement qui cherche à éteindre
finalement le créé un régime
d'assignation à la résidence et de
placement de rétention du demandeur
d'asile qui présente une menace à
l'ordre publici il a été bien sûr ajouté
il a été présenté tout à l'heure par le
ministre il est juste à Noé que le
risque de fuite pouvant être présumé de
manière très large ces centres pourrait
être vite être surpeuplé donc ça ne git
pas finalement aujourd'hui ce qui a été
exprimé tout à l'heure par le ministre
comme quoi on préfèire les la la
maintenir les personnes à domicile que
pour que ça soit plus humain je dirais
que c'est aujourd'hui il y a c'est ces
risques de fuite pourrait être aussi
apprécié très ou trop longtemps on n'
pas de de de limite on sait pas trop
qu'est-ce qu'on attend à travers ces ces
ces imprécisions en tout cas à cet égard
on nous trouve regret que le
gouvernement évite son obligation de
produire des études d'impact en passant
par de tels amendements qui n'ont pas de
qui qui ne sont pas précis et qui en
tout cas engagent fortement les droits
fondamentaux euh madame
fossillon oui je je je je partage
l'argument selon lequel il y a une forme
d'évitement par cette voie d'amendement
et de l'étude d'impact et ici de d'un
avis du du Conseil d'État d'autant que
là très clairement par par cette
création du régime d'assignation à
résidence ou de placement en rétention
des des demandeurs d'asile on on rentre
potentiellement quand même dans une une
atteinte justement au au droit d'asile
avec une suspicion qui se formule
jusqu'au demandeur d'asile euh on pense
que on pense qu'il y a vraiment d'autres
manières d'opérer et que il faut
absolument protéger euh le le droit
d'asile euh et voilà ê là madame sbaahi
le suivant
oui je vais par revenir sur ce qu'on dit
déjà mes deux collègues mais cet article
signifie finalement que l'étranger en
situation irrégulière présentant une
demande d'asile à une autorité non
compétente pour l'enregistrer pourra
être placé en rétention s'il présente un
risque de fuite dont la définition reste
extrêmement floue alors il faudrait
s'interroger sur les objectifs de cette
disposition si l'objectif est de mettre
en rétention un très grand nombre de
demandeurs d'asile pour le plaisir du
chiffre c'est très réussi si l'objectif
est de réserver la rétention aux
situations qui s'avèrent nécessaire par
exemple lorsque d'autres mesures moins
coeritives ne suffisent pas dans une
démarche de proportionnalité telle que
prévu par le droit européen c'est raté
c'est même très raté puisque cette
disposition détourne totalement la
rétention de son objectif iniiciale qui
est de permettre à l'administration
d'organiser le départ forcé d'une
personne sous mesure d'éloignement avec
cette disposition la rétention pourra
être utilisé de manière complètement
arbitraire sur des étrangers qui ne font
par exemple même pas l'objet de mesur
d'éloignement c'est contraire au droit
international donc on vous demande la
suppression de cet article monsieur
rapporteur vos avis merci monsieur le
Président donc les situations visées de
qui s'agit-il sagit de l'étranger qui
est en situation irrégulière et qui
manifeste sa volonté de demander l'asile
à l'occasion d'une interpellation donc
faisant l'objet d'une interpellation
l'autre cas et vous l'avez indiqué c'est
l'étranger en situation irrégulière dont
la demande d'asile a été présentée à une
mauvaise autorité et qui présente un
risque de fuite donc il s'agit en fait
par un dispositif équilibré de répondre
à ces deux situations là en créant cet
article qui a été fait au Sénat sur
proposition d'un amendement du
gouvernement mais il s'agit surtout de
la
transposition plus complète de l'article
8 de la directive procédure qui avait
été adopté le 26 juin 2013 et qui
autorise très spécifiquement c'est cette
procédure désormais introduite en France
par cet article s'il est adopté c'est
pourquoi j'ai met un avis défavorable à
ces amendements de suppression je les
mets donc au voix qui vote pour qui vote
contre sont rejeté le 372 n'est pas
défendu le 688 monsieur servard monsieur
Castellani
oui
oui c'est un amendement qui qui vise à
supprimer l'ajou du Sénat qui conduit à
à placer d'office des demandeurs d'asile
en ration administrative ou à les
assigner à résidence le temps qu'il
qu'il présente leur demande on sait très
bien que les cas sont conçus pour
organiser et exécuter l'éloignement or
cette disposition détourne cette
finalité
d'écran prévoyant de priver de liberté
des personnes en demande d'asile dès le
début de la procédure avant même
l'examen sur le bien fondé de leur
demande d'où l'objet de de cet
amendement merci monsieur le
rapporteur avis défavorable pour les
raisons que j'ai exposé à savoir ça ne
s'applique qu'aux personnes qui présente
un risque de fuite et ce qui est
caractérisé d'autre part si la
transcription la directive procédure
plus complète en droit français avis
défavorable je mets au voix qui vote
pour contre
rejeté qui défend le 399 madame bord
oui merci monsieur le Président
effectivement l'alinéa 7 de cet article
12 prévoit que le placement en rétention
d'un étranger en situation irrégulière
ne peut être justifié que lorsqu'il
présente un risque de fuite et les
alinéas 9 à 13 décrivent des cas
suffisamment graves pour que le risque
de fuite soit
automatiquement retenu lorsque ces cas
sont visé en fait c cet amendement vise
à retenir systématiquement le risque de
fuite dans les cas visés à ces
amendement avis défavorable rendre
automatique la caractérisation du risque
de fuite n'est pas conforme au principes
généraux de notre droit qui prévoit
quand même que l'appréciation au cas par
cas doit rester la règle ce qui
d'ailleurs a été inclus dans l'article 8
de la directive procédure avis
défavorable madame tour merci monsieur
président donc preuve est faite que le
rassemblement national n'aime pas le
droit c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure voilà n'aime pas le droit n'aime
pas l'état de droit merci à monsieur le
rapporteur de de le rappeler je voix qui
vote pour qui vote contre rejeté qui
défend l'amendement de Monsieur
yacovelli le
439 défendu monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable je mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre il re
le 376 n'est pas défendu donc c'est
l'article 12 B a que je mets au suffrage
qui vote pour qui mode contre il est
adopté 12 BB amendement de suppression
le 921 madame Carami défendu le 1190
madame fossillon défendu défendu
monsieur le rapporteur défavorable
défavorable je le mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre rejeté le 846
Monsieur kerbat Merci monsieur le
Président cet amendement vise à ajouter
un article pour modifier les durées
d'assignation à résidence administrative
prévu pour les personnes faisant l'objet
d'une octf le fait de soumettre une
personne faisant l'objet d'une octf à
une assignation à résidence poursuit la
tradition des politiques migratoires de
ces 20 dernières années à disimiler à
assimiler délinquence et immigration la
nonrégularité de la présence sur le
territoire ne peut-être assimilée à de
la délinquence et ne doit pas faire
l'objet d'une peine qui plus
administratif de restriction de liberté
individuelle l'assignation à résidence
devit être imposée dans le cadre d'une
procédure pénale à l'star de tout autre
jusiciable sous contrôle d'un juge des
libertés et de la détention ce continuum
de l'enfement doit cesser la durée de 45
jours prévu à l'article L 732-3 est une
durée suffisamment importante et
attentatoire au liberté elle devrait pas
être renouvelable et enfin la durée de 6
mois prévu à l'article 732-4 est
inadmissible et devrait pas exister dans
un État de
droit alors monsieur le
rapporteur donc sur cet amendement de
suppression puisque nous parlons d'État
de droit le Conseil constitutionnel
saisi de cette question le 30 novembre
2017 a très clairement exprimé le
principe qu'il était possible d'éviter
que puisse librement circuler sur le
territoire national une personne
dépourvue de droit au séjour c'est donc
à ce titre que que cet article fixe dans
des situations bien particulières et
strictement encadrer la possibilité de
cette assignation à résidence de longue
durée avis
défavorable
je les mets au voix qui vote pour contre
rejeté les deux suivants ne sont pas
défendu et c'est donc l'article 12 bis
pour lequel j'appelle vos votes qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est
adopté après l'article 12 bis madame
gevennou 1319 à Madame legrip pardon
merci monsieur le Président oui je
défends un amendement proposé par notre
collègue Mathieu Lefèvre par cet
amendement nous souhaitons préciser que
les étrangers reconnus coupables de
provocation directe à des actes de
terrorisme ou d'apologie du terrorisme
puisse être retenu en CRA jusqu'à 210
jours comme le précise l'article 742-7
du czda nous considérons en effet que
les étrangers reconnus coupables
d'apologie du terrorisme ou de
provocation directe à la commission
d'acte de terrorisme représente une
menace importante pour la sécurité des
Français et pour l'ordre public je
merci monsieur le
rapporteur merci chers collègues de
cette proposition de précision qui
paraît tout à fait opportune et donc
avis favorable je mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est adopté le
1538 je ne vois pas
madameadan donc il n'est pas
défendu article 12 bis C monsieur porte
pour l'amendement de suppression merci
monsieur le Président ici un amendement
qui vise à supprimer ce qui a été
introduit euh au Sénat qui veut réduire
le délai entre deux placements en
rétention de 7 jours euh à 48 he je
rappelle quand même que l'article 741-7
du czda prévoit l'obligation pour
l'autorité administrative de respecter
un délai de 7 jours entre deux décisions
et là on passerait à 48h écoutez euh
nous on s'oppose à cette multiplication
des possibilités d'enfermement dans des
délais réduits c'est pas sérieux c'est
pas la hauteur et c'est contraire à
l'état de droit de notre pays même si
certains veulent s'essuer les pieds
dessus on considère qu'il faut supprimer
cet article monsieur Valo le le 922
madame Carami oui monsieur le Président
très rapidement on on demande la
suppression de cet article parce que il
entend ici refuser l'octroi d'un contrat
de jeune majeur à une personne faisant
l'objet d'un d'une
qtfel non pardon je me suis trompé
défendu
pardon madame fussillon il est bien oui
nous voulons supprimer supprimer cette
cet article puisqueici il y a la volonté
d'exécuter des des mesures des LO ement
au mépris de la préservation des droits
fondamentaux des personnes retenues en
les gardant enfermés de façon quasi
continue et donc on juge ce dispositif
comme comme disproportionné juste pour
exemple une personne libérée par un juge
pourrait se retrouver de nouveau
enfermée en cras alors même qu'une
juridiction aurait constaté quelques
jours plusut tôt la violation de ces
droits de même une personne enfermée en
cras pendant une longue durée pouvant
aller jusque 60 ou 90 jours pourrait se
retrouver de nouveau en rétention 2
jours après alors même qu'il n'aura pas
été possible pour l'administration de
l'éloigner dans les délais impartis vous
voyez quand je dis disproportionné c'est
même un peu
faible alors le l'avis du rapporteur
s'il vous
plaît merci monsieur le Président on
c'est pas disproportionné c'est au
contraire strictement proportionné parce
que je rappelle que l'article 12 B C
prévoit de réduire le délai dans la
mesure où il y a de nouvelles
circonstances de fait ou de droit qui
justifie que la personne soit à nouveau
placée en en rétention et donc à ce
titre ce dispositif d'illeur existe déjà
dans l'article l7417 du CGDA étant donné
que les cas de dérogation sont limités
et correctement proportionnés j'ai met
un avis défavorable à cet amendement de
suppression je le mets au voix qui vote
pour qui vote contre ils sont rejetés
monsieur gilet le
829 défendu monsieur le
rapporteur défavorable je me vois qui
vot pour contre rejeté l'article 12 B
qui vare pour contre
attendez parce que ça été un peu vite
qui vote pour l'article 12 BC qui vote
contre
adopté le pour le 12 bis votre
amendement monsieur le rapporteur le
1669 amendement de merci monsieur le
Président donc amendement de de
suppression puisque cet article
introduit par le Sénat pour prévoir
d'exclure les jeunes majeurs faant
l'objet d'tf de l'obligation de prise en
charge jusquà 2 an lorsquil sortent de
l' par aller au-delà de l'objectif visé
par la protection des mineurs qui ont
été pris en charge par la et la
poursuite de l'accompagnement paraît un
sujet important qu'il convient de
maintenir à ce titre il est proposé la
suppression par cet amendementorté avec
le rapporteur général de cet
article Monsieur Madame T pour le
37 merci nous nous opposons à
cette nous nous opposons à cet article
et c'est pour ça que nous proposons de
le supprimer c'est un article qui a été
rajouté par le gouvernement au Sénat et
qui vise une fois de plus à criminaliser
les étrangers en les privant de leur
liberté d'aller et venir puisque donc ça
rallonge la durée de l'autorisation de
l'assignation à résidence des étrangers
son couvert de humanisme nous sommes
contre cette C cet article nous le
disons à avec force c'est un article qui
a été rajouté par le gouvernement au
Sénat ce qui prouve bien que le ministre
de l'Intérieur
trouvver Madame Le Pen trop molle donc
il va plus loin et pendant tout ce texte
depuis tout ce texte nous voyons que la
macronie court après le rassemblement
national et vice
versa ensuite madame Martin le
sur quel bouton je
dois donc là on est sur sur une
situation de poursuite de la
protection que que nous devons hein aux
jeunes gens qui ont été pris en charge
par la zeu étant entendu qu'il y a cette
question financière que j'aiévoqué tout
à l'heure mais qui pourrait être tout à
fait résolue par des dotations particuli
donc l'idée c'est que ces jeunes gens
continuent à bénéficier du contrat jeune
majeur puisque il y a pas de il y a il y
a pas de raison de les laisser
complètement tomber même si on a décidé
de les de les mettre dehors du du pays
par ailleurs vous savez mois on s'occupe
enfin moins on se préoccupe des personne
plus on les livre à
elle-même plus on les met bien sûr en
danger mais plus on les livre aussi à à
faire un certain nombre de délit et je
pense que ici chacun est capable de de
le comprendre tant c'est basique donc ça
veut dire que par les conditions qu'on
organise autour des personnes on les met
dans des situations de délinquence après
on dit ah quand même les é merci madame
Martin monsieur Valot le
923 défendu madame alors qui est
signataire du 1067 merci monsieur le
Président amendement de notre collègue
pascini l'article 12 bis a pour objet
d'exclure du bénéfice de la protection
de l'aide sociale à l'enfance et du
contrat jeun majeur tout jeune Maur
majeur ayant fait l'objet d'une qtf en
premier lieu les mesures relatives à la
prise en charge des mineurs et des
jeunes majeurs par l'aide sociale à
l'enfance relève du champ de la
protection de l'enfance elles n'ont donc
rien à faire dans un texte sur la loi
immigration la protection des mineurs de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance jusqu'à leurs
21 ans visent à prévenir le basculement
vers la pauvreté des jeunes majeurs qui
ne sont pas accompagnés par leurs
proches lorsque leur famille n'est pas
là et que leurs ressources financières
sont insuffisante le contrat jeune
majeur est un dispositif qui permet
d'assurer la continuité de
l'accompagnement de laazu afin d'offrir
à ces jeunes une autonomie et une
insertion professionnelle refuser cet
accompagnement aux jeunes majeurs
faisant l'objet d'uneqtf est un nonsens
politique et moral total notamment quand
on sait qu'un nombre conséquent
d'qtf pardon excusez-moi bon je défendu
m
ftill C bizarre
la ils sont annulés par les tribunaux
administratifs ouais par
exmoi bon d'abord il faut dire à quel
point les les contrats jeunes majeur
sont importants parce que se retrouver
en en sortie d'Azu à 18 ans après des
parcours souvent quand même très très
traumatique très difficile et malgré une
prise en charge par laazu à 18 ans on n'
pas tout réglé dans sa vie et donc les
contrats jeunes majeurs sont quand même
une aide importante la deuxième chose et
il faut le dire les otf pour des jeunes
pour des pour des jeunes majeurs en
contrat jeunes majeurs assidus qui sont
en formation qui trouve un patron et
cetera il y en a plein il y en a plein
et franchement je peux vous le dire en
tout cas dans mon département pour
connaître beaucoup de jeunes qui ont été
concernés par ces OQTF c'est
incompréhensible on ne sait pas pourquoi
ils ont des OQTF alors qu'ils sont en
train de suivre une formation donc
franchement les sortir de du bénéfice de
l'azux c'est vraiment enfin une mesure
qui n'a aucun sens pour leur intégration
dans notre pays pour le pour des jeunes
qui veulent vraiment à à chaque fois
pouvoir apprendre la langue travailler
être utile au pays arrêtons de les
stigmatiser on on on on va dans le
mauvais sens en faisant ça vraiment on
va dans le mauvais sens par des mesures
stigmatisante et qui socialement n'ont
aucun sens merci euh monsieur balanan le
suivant ont été donné je je sais plus
qui disait que c'était un un amendement
du Gouvernement c'est pas c'est pas du
tout un un amendement du Gouvernement au
Sénat ça a été rajouté c'est pas dans le
texte initial et sauf erreur de ma part
c'est un amendement des rapporteurs du
Sénat
donc c'est pas pour ça qu'on veut le
supprimer hein on veut le supprimer
parce que ce n'est pas un bon dispositif
et donc nous souhaitons nous avons donc
déposé cet amendement de suppression
pour supprimer l'article 12
bis madame Miller pour le suivant oui
monsieur le Président c'est un
amendement qui a été travaillé avec
monsieur le rapporteur donc voilà il est
déposé et déjà défendu merci votre avis
est favorable monsieur le rapporteur
madame
jeunevar merci monsieur le Président moi
je voudrais me faire l'écho des immenses
difficultés que connaissent aujourd'hui
les conseils départementaux d'abord pour
financer euh tout ce qui a trait à la
prise en charge des mineurs non
accompagnés je regrette d'ailleurs que
vous ayez supprimé le fichier qui
permettait de pouvoir recenser
l'ensemble de ces mineurs non
accompagnés euh aujourd'hui les conseils
départementaux sont dans une situation
très difficile ils sont l'objet
d'injonction contradictoire monsieur le
rapporteur parce que ils sont tenus par
la loi de 2022 de maintenir
euh jusqu'à 21 ans la prise en charge
par
l'AZ et en même temps lorsqu'il
suspendent les contrats jeunes majeur
parce que le jeune majeur est sous qtf
et bien on
suspend le la décision leur décision est
suspendue donc il y a il y a quelque
chose de contrad victoire qui ne
fonctionne pas qu'est-ce que vous
pouvezci comment résoudre cette
difficulté madame
ftillon euh simplement pour dire autant
je je je crois que l'État doit être
aujourd'hui plus présent dans
l'accompagnement des départements pour
la prise en charge des enfants placés
sous la protection de l'enfance ça c'est
une réalité et et pas que financièrement
d'ailleurs il y a beaucoup de choses à
revoir autant ça suffit aujourd'hui
d'expliquer que euh les départements
seraient en faillite du fait euh des
mineurs non accompagnés d'abord
disons-le au sein de la protection de
l'enfance aujourd'hui il y a un afflux
plus important d'enfants en général pas
que de mineurs non accompagnés il y a
beaucoup plus de bébés parce qu'on a
constaté euh plus de maltraitance et
qu'il y a une meilleure prise en charge
parce qu'il y a des adolescents qui sont
en grave affection de santé mentale et
qui sont pris en charge donc il y a
plein d'enfants dans notre pays
aujourd'hui qui vont mal qui qu'ils
aient une carte d'identité française ou
pas et donc qu'est-ce qu'on dit on dit
on s'en occupe
pas on on trie les étrangers et les
Français non il y a besoin de s'occuper
plus de la protection de l'enfance et
donc faut demander à l'état d'être au
rendez-vous pas vouloir exclure les
mineurs non accompagnés parce que dans
pas longtemps on fera quoi on exclura
les adolescents parce qu'ils sont trop
vieux monsieur monsieur
kbrat monsieur
kbrat ou par exemple dire que des
enfants monsieur kirbrat pas monsieur
coulom monsieur kbrat c'est Malon
moi je souscris entièrement à ce que
vient de dire notre collègue Elsa
fossillon euh et je vais quand même
poser une question à nos collègues qui
par humanisme se posent des questions
sur ces jeunes
étrangers qui sont soit une charge pas
une charge pour la ze qui pourrait être
en situation d'qtf et de contrat
peut-être que si on ne foutait pas des
cttf d 18 ans dès le passage à la
majorité à tous les étrangers mineurs
étrangers de ce pays ça irait beaucoup
mieux on a tous dans notre
circonscription des cas complètement
absurd d'étudiants BTS qui passent de
leur 17 à leur 18 ans PAF décembre ils
ont 17 ans janvier ils ont 18 ans auqtf
alors qu'ils FT étudiant par exemple en
contat j'en avais un an qui était
étudiant contat ils tombent sur une qtf
un jeune poète Danta falmarès publié
chez galimar 17 ans 18 ans PAF au qtf
automaticité peut-être qu'on pourrait
réfléchir au lieu de faire des articles
assez ridicules comme celui-ci à une
présomption de titres étudiant une
présomption sur C passage pour éviter
d'avoir en fait des emongements
administratifs débiles on vote les
amendements de suppression qui vote pour
avec far du rapporteur qui vote contre
ils sont adoptés ils font tomber les
amendements suivants il supprime
l'article de bis et on va pouvoir
appeler le
1670 du rapporteur dans le calme comme
nous le faisons depuis ce matin
merci
merci monsieur le Président l'article 10
pardon l'amendement 1670 prévoit une
suppression de l'article 12 TER en effet
cet article 12 TER prévoit la création
d'un C des charges nationale sur la base
duquel l'évaluation de minorités des
mineurs non accompagnés pourrait être
réalisé ce dispositif justifie de de ma
part un amendement de suppression parce
qu'il est déjà satisfait par les
articles r221 11 et suivants du Code de
l'action sociale et un arrêté de
novembre 2 2019 qui a fixé un
référentiel national d'évaluation de la
minorité de plus un guide des bonnes
pratiques a été rédigé en formation
interministérielle pour l'évaluation de
la minorité de l'isolement et donc à ce
titre le ce point me paraît justifier la
cet amendement de suppression je me
permet de répondre rapidement à madame
jeunev je pense que le sujet n'est pas
seulement la jction contradictoire sur
ce sujet important de l'accompagnement
des jeunes qui étaient sous ASE de 18 à
21 ans et je pense que le sujet
d'ailleurs a été ouvert à l'occasion
d'une prise de position public de Madame
cobel sur peut-être repenser les
relations entre l'État et les conseils
départementaux sur
l'accompagnement de des mineurs parce
que c'est vrai que ça peut créer des
difficultés mais je ne pense pas qu'il
convienne d'isoler certains sujets faute
de quoi on manquerait probablement le la
résolution globale et sans vouloir à
tout prix concilier tous les points de
vue effectivement la dégradation de la
santé mentale des jeunes adultes et des
enfants et des adolescents doit nous
conduire à nous interroger sur
aujourd'hui la situation d'un certain
nombre de jeunes qui ont probablement
d'un accompagne pas forcément aussi
lourd que la se tel qu'on la comprend
mais probablement modulé et c'est un
sujet qui doit être porté conjointement
par les département qui ont reçu cette
compétence et par l'État qui ne peut
s'en désintéresser mais je pense en
essayant d'aborder tous les sujets et de
pas trop les fragmenter ou segmenter
monsieur vot
oui simplement un amendement de de
suppression considérant que on le voit
bien dans ce dans ce texte nous n'avons
ban que le le ministre de l'intérieur
alors que manifeste sa disposition
relève d'autres ministères et d'autres
codes que le code de séjour des
étrangers en
France Monsieur balanan le
suivant défendu
défendu madame meriller le
suivant oui merci monsieur le Président
comme l'a dit le rapporteur c'est un
amendement qui est un article qui est
déjà satisfait qui par ailleurs on peut
se poser la question je pense qu' relève
pas vraiment du domaine de la loi et
puis pour poursuivre et pour compléter
et pour surtout confirmer les propos de
du rapporteur je pense que sur la
question il y a un vrai sujet sur les
MNA en revanche il faut pas évidemment
notre objectif n'est pas de mettre la
poussière sous le tapis mais simplement
de pas confondre tout et donc de prendre
les sujets les uns après les autres ça
relève pas de ce projet de loi donc
parlons-en plus tard mais il y a
évidemment un vrai
sujet donc Madame jeunevar vouliz réagir
parce que c'est la vie favorable du
rapporteur puisqu merci monsieur le
rapporteur de de de son intervention moi
je pense que aujourd'hui l'État ne prend
pas suffisamment en compte les immenses
difficultés des départements d'ailleurs
le président de l'Association des
départements de France qui n'est pas un
dangereux radicalisé pour reprendre les
termes de certains a alerté il y a des
limites à la au caractère supportable
des dépenses qui sont engagées d'un
nombre sans cesse croissant de mineurs
non accompagné avec cette difficulté que
ils sont sous contrat jeune majeur
jusqu'à 21 ans et sousqtf à partir de 18
ans donc là il faut quand même dire la
la façon de faire au département
j'ajoute que les républicain bon cette
disposition cet amendement a été déclaré
irrecevable mais préconise que l'État
reprenne la main sur la gestion des MNA
donc que que que nous dit que nous dit
le gouvernement à ce sujet
madame
Diaz oui merci monsieur le Président
alors bon l'idée de créer un cahier des
charges
national
pour traiter du de la question des
mineurs non accompagnés bon ça nous
paraî être quand même un petit peu
fumeux mais on peut dire que on peut
espérer que ça aille dans le bon sens
ces amendements de suppression en
revanche ben finalement c'est pire que
tout parce que là en fait on acte le
désengagement de l'État et moi je vous
rappelle qu'on regarde des suspicionss
de fraude qui entourent le statut des
mineurs non accompagnés puisqu'on estime
en tout cas des professionnel estime que
jusqu'à 80 % des personnes qui se
déclarent mineurs sont en réalité majeur
je je regrette profondément que vous
n'ayez pas voté par sectarisme la
proposition de loi de notre collègue
Alexandra Masson qui proposait de mettre
en place des tests radiologiques afin de
déterminer là je précise des mineurs
prétendus non accompagnés je mets au
voix qui vote pour l'amendement de supr
qui contre il est adopté alors il
supprime l'article de terre il fait tomb
les amendements suivants on enent
l'amendement après de terre Mad madame
DUP n'est pas là je crois qu'il n'est
pas
défendu l'article 13 amendement de
suppressionarticle 13 qui défend l'amend
écologistur
présentendés demande la suppression de
cet article sur le contrat d'engagement
au respect des principes de la
République en rappelant qu'il a déjà été
censuré par le Conseil constitutionnel
et nous nous aimons parfois souvent le
Conseil constitutionnel n déplaise à la
collègue qui nous ENIT le reproche tout
à l'heure car jugé trop imprécis en
effet il s'agit d'un énième levier pour
octroyer des refus de titre de séjour
sur des motifs particulièrement vagues
comme le respect des symboles de la
République et de sa devise moi par
exemple je considère que les
interventions du rassemblement national
depuis lundi et même avant
contreviennent gravement à la devise
républ et au symbole de notre République
cette mesure est une extension du
contrat d'engagement républicain issue
de la loi sur le respect des principes
de la République dont aucun bilan n'a
été effectué ce contrat d'engagement
républicain est toutefois déjà suspecté
d'être utilisé à des fins
d'instrumentalisation par C certaines
préfectures qui l'utiliserait pour
contraindre l'expression d'association
écologiste ou féministe par exemple nous
demandons donc l'abrogation de cet
article qui ajouterait à l'arbitraire du
contrat d'engagement républicain sans
aucune base légale
tangible monsieur KBr la base légale
monsieur la baseégale merci monsieur le
Président dans la suite de mon collègue
Luca on demande la suppression de cette
article qui introduit de nouveaux
critères pour encadrer les titres de
séjour sur les respects des principes de
la République ça a été rappelé déjà vous
avez tenté dans la loi séparatisme
d'introduire cette disposition et vous
avez été rappelé à l'ordre par le
Conseil
constitutionnel parce que ici le respect
des principes de la République ça n'a
pas de sens juridique et derrière cette
volonté de créer de nouveaux critères
c'est une politique de chasse contre les
étrangers qui a été organisé et c'est
aussi l'idée de d'entretenir ce qui est
cher au ministre de l'Intérieur un
racisme d'atmosphère cette disposition a
été déjà sanctionnée à l'époque par le
Conseil constitutionnel nous nous
opposons à ce qu'elle revienne ici et
nous demandons la suppression de cet
article qui est absolument inutile et
qui poursuit des objectifs politiques
très dangereux et intentatoire aux
libertés qui avait déjà remis en cause
la liberté d'association Vous avez ciblé
des associations via la loi
séparatisme euh monsieur valallot pour
le 927
oui merci enens de ce qui ait déjà déjà
dit cet article 13 qui fait suite à
l'article 9 crée en réalité un nouveau
motif d'expulsion des étrangers protégés
ou un refus de renouvellement de de
titrre euh pour non respect de ce de ce
contrat et d'un certain nombre de valeur
de la République qui bien que préciser
euh pour j'imagine faire suite à la
censure du Conseil constitut in ne nous
paraissent pas et ne reparaissent pas
d'ailleurs la défenseuse des droits non
plus suffisamment précis pour échapper à
une question de conformité à l'objectif
de valeur constitutionnelle
d'accessibilité et
d'intelligibilité de la loi et puis par
ailleurs pour souligner les
questionnements que peuvent soulever
cette rédaction est-ce que siffler la
Marseillaise ou ne pas la chanter
lorsqu'elle serait entenée serait un
motif d'interdiction de séjour et puis
par ailleurs dans la précision sont
apportés sur ce qu'il faut entendre par
valeur de la
République le trouble à l'ordre publici
n'est que un cas qu'il serait pris de
façon échéante en compte c'est-à-dire de
façon aléatoire et discrétionnaire on va
inverser parce que l'amendement madame
chat n pas signé par Monsieur Lucas donc
monsieur Lucas vous avez défendu votre
amendement 1035 est-ce que un des
membres du groupe écologiste veut
défendre l'autre on dire défendu défendu
le madame fosstillon
oui on demande la suppression de cet
article parce qu'en fait on on se refuse
à inscrire dans dans la loi des des
dispositions avec un très fort potentiel
de de discrimination et c'est bien ça
qui est là c'est-à-dire voilà le le but
c'est quand même de de de de fragiliser
le le droit au séjour mais au-delà de le
fragiliser dans les faits euh parce que
ça c'est possible avec les mesures qui
sont des mesures tout à fait
discrétionnaires flou et tout ça mais en
réalité là le but on le voit bien
au-delà de ça et en amont c'est de faire
en sorte encore un peu plus de suspecter
les étrangers qui sont sur notre sol de
ne pas être en en en conformité avec les
valeurs républicaines moi je franchement
j'invite tous les collègues si l'ont pas
déjà fait souvent à interroger les
personnes sur pourquoi elles arrivent
ici il y a la raison de départ mais il y
a aussi très souvent et c'est d'ailleurs
parfois un peu presque étonnant pour
nous-même qui euh regardons parfois
notre patrie est pas toujours en lien
dans l'application avec sa devise
républicaine de dire à quel point ils
sont heureux d'arriver dans un pays qui
défend les droits de l'homme et et en
réalité ça suffit ça suffit de les
suspecter d'être de ne pas pouvoir de ne
pas pouvoir s'insérer dans ces valeurs
là alors monsieur le rapporteur vos avis
sur ces
amendements
alors donc ces amendements visent à
supprimer l'article 13 motif notamment
que le droit existant paraît
satisfaisant au signataire de ces
amendements et que le dispositif proposé
induirit un risque de discrimination à
titre liminaire je rappellerai que
certains exposés sommaires ne concernent
que le volet relatif au respect des
principes de la République or l'article
13 est bien plus large puisqu'il englobe
notamment un volet relatif aux menaces
graves pour l'ordre public il ne faut
pas oublier et un volet subordonnant le
renouvellement des titres longs à une
résidence habituelle en France qui est
aussi une dimension importante de cet
article ces amendements supprimeraient
ainsi ces mesures complémentaires et
seraient des dommages collatéraux si
vous me permettez cette expression d'un
manque de ciblage pour cette raison
j'aimis déjà un avis défavorable sur la
question des principes de la République
vous avez raison de mentionner le
contrat d'intégration républicaine et le
fait que le respect des principes de la
République existe déjà mais cette
présentation me paraît incomplète tous
les titres et toutes les situations ne
sont pas concerné par l'exigence du
respect de ce document en l'état du
droit le refus de signer l'engagement à
respecter les principes ne suffit pas à
lui seul aujourd'hui pour refuser un
titre on est sous l'angle du dossier
incomplet pas sur un motif substantiel
de fond l'article 13 dans un de ces
trois volets dans donc l'exigence du
respect des principes de la République
et en renforce la portée il semble que
sur ce sujet nous devrions pouvoir tous
nous retrouver car de quoi parle-t-on
parlons de faire
prévaloir nous parlons pardon du du
risque que certains souhaitent faire
prévaloir une règle religieuse ou
dogmatique sur les règles communes et
les principes qui fondent notre société
comme notamment l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes ou encore contester
des enseignements au motif que cela ne
conviendrait pas à leur conviction
personnelle bref l'article vise en fait
le refus de vivre en société sur des
valeurs universelles que nous portons il
lutte ainsi contre le séparatisme
parfois insidieu mais toujours des les
terre pour nos valeurs et la e sous
l'angle constitutionnel il appartiendra
au conseil de se prononcer mais je me
permets de dire déjà que ce dispositif
est bien plus précis que celui qui avait
été établi en 2021 ici les élements sont
clairement définis de plus le Conseil
d'État dans son avis a clairement validé
ce dispositifens qu' ne cet aucune
disposition constitutionnelle enfin et
pour terminer je ne vois pas où est la
discrimination dans la mesure où ce
dispositif serait applicable à toutes
les personnes qui rentrent dans le champ
de l'article 13 et il est donc de nature
à améliorer l'intégration des étrangers
en France à ce titre avis défavorable
aux amendements de suppression monsieur
pouliia
oui merci monsieur le Président juste de
mots le premier pour rappeler quand même
le contrô d'engagement républicain il
n'est pas du tout attentatoire à la
liberté d'association comme ça a été dit
je tiens à rappeler d'ailleurs que il ne
il n'est basé que sur un seul principe
c'est que la République n'a pas à
financer ceux qui la combattent et
deuxième point sur la question du de du
respect des principes républicains pour
les étrangers ben oui aussi je discute
avec des personnes qu'on a accueilli et
ils sont tout à fait raccord avec l'idée
qu'il faut respecter les principes du
pays qui vous accueille et en cela ça
leur pose aucun problème de respecter
les principes républicains et ceux à qui
ça pose problème et ben effectivement je
vois pas pourquoi on continuera à les
accueillir madame torgia merci monsieur
le Président quelle hypocrisie quelle
hypocrisie quand on va demander aux
étrangers de respecter les principes de
la République alors que ce texte
les Abî les abîmes les détruit quelle
hypocrisie quand ce gouvernement ne
respecte pas liberté égalité fraternité
liberté non la liberté n'est pas
respectée quand on ne respecte pas la
liberté de manifester égalité non elle
n'est pas respectée quand des écoles
n'ont plus de remplaçant quand d'autres
écoles n'ont jamais de problème de
remplaçant et quelle quelle hypocrisie
quand ce texte quand ce texte renit la
devise
fraternité alors monsieur le rapporteur
général vouliez dire un mot
oui j'aime beaucoup répondre à Madame
tourgha de de façon générale mais mais
quel hipoclisie de votre part ma cher
collègue quand vous caricaturez à ce
point le
texte est-ce que c'est inacceptable de
lutter contre les passeurs les marchands
de sommeil est-ce que c'est inacceptable
de lutter est-ce que c'est
pass de lutter contre les employeurs
voou est-ce que c'est inacceptable de
régulariser un d'étranger parce que nous
estimons qu'il il à fois nos besoins
économiques et des besoins de de
protection les concernant est-ce que
c'est inacceptable ma chère collègue
d'interdire la rétention des mineurs
jusqu'à 18 ans dans les cras dans les
LRA et d'engager la discussion sur
l'éventuelle discussion sur la
vulnérabilité qui pourrait être une
condition supplémentaire moi je veux
simplement rappeler une chose le contrat
d'engagement républicain qui a été
imposé par le Sénat ça n'était pas notre
proposition initiale au fond il vient
répondre à la question de de quel
principe parlons-nous vous dites vous
êtes vague vous êtes flou effectivement
c'est ce qu'a dit le Conseil
constitutionnel dans sa décision du 13
août 2021 ça m'a pas échappé j'étais
rapporteur général du texte par ailleurs
et nous avions d'ailleurs souligné un
certain nombre de de défaillances
possibles y compris au banc pour celles
et ceux qui euh son s'en souviennent
d'abord le Conseil constitutionnel ne
dit pas il y a des problèmes de
discrimination à l'époque il y a pas de
problème de discrimination dans son
argumentation il n y a pas de problème
au regard des libertés publiques d'aucun
droits fondamentaux il dit simplement il
y a un problème d'accessibilité et
d'intelligibilité du droit uniquement
cette argumentation dans la décision du
13 août 2021 aucune autre et précisément
lisez l'alinéa 7 du de l'article 13 tel
qu'il a été proposé enrichi pour le coup
par le Sénat tout est extrêmement bien
défini et ça devrait nous rassembler
mais de façon transpartisane au-delà de
nos différences de sensibilité respecter
la liberté personnelle madame Toria vous
êtes
contre respecter la liberté d'expression
et de conscience vous êtes contre vous
voulez le l'accepter vous voulez
l'accepter parce que la personne serait
nationalité étrangère respecter
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
vous êtes contre respecter la dignité de
la personne humain vous êtes contre
respecter la devise et les symboles de
la République vous êtes contre voilà ce
que nous estimons nécessaire d'imposer à
toute personne à toute personne qui
demande une carte de résident et une
carte de s jour plurannuel vous ajoutez
vous ajoutez madame à au mensonge
quotidien que vous faites rappeler ce
matin l'inélégance et l'inexactitude de
vos
arguments monsieur
Lucas moi je trouve que cette suspicion
permanente d'adhésion non adhésion au
principe républicain vis-à-vis des
étrangers contribu à ce racisme
l'atmosphère que nous décrivons depuis
lundi je me demande si nous-même
réussirions tous tous les tests qui
seraiit fait par exemple on peut-être
monarchiste et donc ne pas adhérer au
principes républicains et vivre
parfaitement en France et concourir à la
démocratie d'ailleurs je considère que
avec la conception que vous avez de la
5e République et de l'absolutisme
présidentiel vous êtes un peu
monarchiste vous-même on peut par
exemple détourner la Marseillaise la
Marseillaise Serge ginsbourg l'a fait
Serge Serge ginsbourg l'a fait et même
notre collègue Ruffin je crois dans une
chanson il y a TR ou 4 ans ils sont
pourtant français et n'ont pas eu à
passer de test vous disiez monsieur le
rapporteur vivre en société adhérer au
VUR universel moi je considère par
exemple que payer sa juste part d'impôt
est une preuve que l'on veut vivre en
société dans ce cas-là monsieur kusac
devrait se voir déchus de la nationalité
sans doute donc voyez vous entrez dans
une logique vous entrez dans une logique
sur les valeurs de la République
extrêmement partial et tourner vers les
étrangers madame
Diaz
merci monsieur le Président alors nous
nous allons voter contre cet amendement
de suppression mais laissez-moi quand
même vous dire notre scepticisme qui
entoure cet article qui je cite requiert
la souscription par tout étranger qui
sollicite un document de séjour à un
contrat d'engagement au respect des
principes de la République bon on a déjà
entendu ça on nous il y a quelques
années C en 2020 ou 2021 on a essayé de
nous faire croire qu'on allait faire
preuve de fermeté à l'encontre de ceux
qui veulent déstabiliser notre société
mais euh on a on a vu on a vu les échecs
on a vu que les atteintes à la laïcité
ont explosé que ça soit dans l'espace
public à l'école au travail dans les
collectivités territorial dans les
associations et même dans les listes
communautaristes au moment des élections
donc vu la gravité de la situation je ne
pense pas que cet article règle
grand-chose en tout cas je pense pas que
cet article fasse trembler ni les
délinquants ni les
islamistes alors on va mettre au voix C
cet amendement de suppression à Monsieur
Valo je vous avez pas vu allez-y je vous
rattrape au dernier moment oui
rapidement pour dire que évidemment il y
a une une part d'interprétation et et de
flou dans les notions qui qui nous
interroge nous sommes dans un Allot
permanent depuis quelques années de
remise en cause des libertés
fondamentales et et des et les droits
élémentaires euh nous devons avoir
conscience du fait que nous sommes
peut-être veillés et certains l'ont
évoqué par des régimes qui seraiit moins
attaché aux valeurs de la République que
nous-mêmes et puis il y a dans nos
rapports aux valeurs de la République
dont nous souhaitons parce qu'elles sont
nos règles de vie en commun
l'enseignement à ceux qui désirent
habiter notre notre pays une forme
d'appréhension en terme de catéchisme
c'est que on pourrait perdre la foi moi
je suis pour qu'il y ait une pédagogie
de la laïité une pédagogie des valeurs
de de la République et puis je ne peux
pas m'empêcher de de me dire que tout
cela est contingent et peut-être
instrumentalisé songez à ce poème qui
était un poème pacifiste de Jan sur le
drapeau qui lui a été reproché jusqu'à
son assassinat qui lui a été reproché
jusqu'à sa
pantéonisation par l'extrême droite dont
il faut se garder parce qu'elle est en
embuscade et je voudrais alerter sur ce
sur ces dispositions là qui nous
exposent à cela et nous comme
républicains nous devons être
extrêmement précis sur le fait que
seulle l'expérience dans une république
est universalisante et que c'est en
trouvant la République partout et pour
tous que nous fabriquons des citoyens
n'est pas ce que propose ni cet article
ni le texte dans son ensemble qui sur le
plan de l'intégration ne pour avoir rien
de ce point de vuel je mets au voix les
amendement de suppression avecis
défavorable du rapporteur qui vote pour
qui vote contre ils sont rejetés les 14
amendements de Madame Antoine qui
suivent ne sont pas
défendus et on arrive à l'amendement de
Monsieur camardine que défend monsieur
Dumont merci monsieur le Président oui
en effet il s'agit de défendre
l'amendement de mon collègue Mansour
camardine qui vise à faire respecter par
les étrangers sollicitant au titre de
séjour l'intégrité territoriale de notre
République euh évidemment cela un lien
avec la situation à Mayotte où euh une
partie de notre territoire en
particulier à Mayotte on a des
ressortissants des commor qui sollicite
un titre de séjour alors qu'ils ne
respectent pas l'intégrité territoriale
de notre pays et qu'ils font en sorte
également de faire de la propagande
anti-France pro comomore à l'intérieur
même de l'île euh et donc réussisse à
pouvoir être des agents de l'extérieur
et c'est une situation à laquelle notre
collègue camardine veut mettre fin avec
cet
amendement madame
yousoufa merci
effectivement cet
amendement vient dans un contexte
particulier vous savez que l'immigration
à Mayotte opère dans le cadre de la
contestation de nos frontières par notre
voisin les Comor je vous rappelle que
l'Union européenne et
l'OTAN qualifie l'instrumentalisation
des flux migratoires comme une menace
hybride je vous permet je vous je subis
vos discours je vous implore de subir le
mien et d'éviter de continuer à
m'interrompre c'est vraiment désagréable
vu ce qui s'est passé hier il va falloir
arrêter il me semble que vous savez que
la question de l'instrumentalisation des
flux migratoires est reconnue par par
l'Union européenne et l'OTAN comme une
déstabilisation c'est-à-dire qu'on
utilise nos propres lois contre nous
pour DAB iser le territoire c'est
précisément ce qu'il se passe à maotte
et en l'occurrence avoir cet article
permettre qu'on ne puisse pas
régulariser des comoriens qui viennent à
maottte spécifiquement pour contester
Mayot française le choix de ces
habitants est capital parce que ces
Comoriens viennent non seulement
organiser des meetings mais organiser
des contrepouch vers les Comores et
ensuite utiliser cela au niveau de
Moroni pour dire que Mayotte est bien
comorienne c'est-à-dire que le problème
est particulier mais que nous avons
besoin du soutien de l'ensemble du
Parlement et de la représentation
nationale pour réaffirmer maotte
française et éviter cette
instrumentalisation des flux migratoires
je vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
vos
avis merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président ces ces deux amendements
posent une une question importante et je
remercie les deux orateurs et
singulièrement madame yousoufa de La à
la fois de la clarté du propos et et de
son côté très pédagogique euh pour dire
pour dire les les choses clairement
effectivement actuellement dans la
rédaction de l'article 13 c'est le
trouble à l'ordre public qui qui peut
permettre lorsqu'il y a contestation de
principe de la République de mettre en
œuvre quelque chose et le sujet définir
effectivement les principes de la
République qui ne sont pas respectés ces
deux amendements pour objectif de mettre
la contestation de l'intégrité du
territoire de la République et ce qui se
passe à nos marge doit nous interroger
parce que ce qui se passe au marge finit
toujours par se passer ailleurs c'est
pour ça que c'est un point important
j'aurais une préférence pour
l'amendement présenté par Madame
yousoufa parce que l'amendement présenté
par Monsieur camardine et ses collègues
mett au même niveau l'intégrité
territoriale et principes de la
République dans votre amendement madame
yousoufa vous vous indiquer que c'est
intégré dans le respect des principes de
la République et que l'intégrité
territoriale en fait partie pour ça à ce
titre que je présente que je demanderit
un retrait de l'article 629 au profit de
la trait du 117 pour lequel j'ai mets un
avis
favorable il est
retirsieur voulez s'exprimer
allez-y merci monsieur le Président et
et bonjour à toutes et à tous cet
amendement il pose une question et je
trouve que la manière dont il est reçu
est assez étrange vous dites ce qui se
passe au marges finit toujours par se
passer ailleurs mais les outremères ne
sont pas les marges justement et c'est
la manière qui consiste à à considérer
les outrmèes comme des marches qui
justement pose un certain nombre de
problèmes et le fait que on naapplique
pas un certain nombre de règles
notamment en matière d'égalité et de
fraternité avec les outresmèes qui finit
par poser un certain nombre de problèmes
mais pour cet amendement comme pour
finalement cet article qui est ajouté il
y a un souci c'est que d'une part c'est
déclaratif c'est-à-dire vous basez sur
le fait que bon en gros on fait
confiance aux gens et puis c'est tout
mais surtout qu'il s'agisse de l'amour
de la la la République du respect des
valeurs républicaines ou du respect de
l'intégrité territoriale ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui se décrète c'est
quelque chose qui se conquère
c'est-à-dire que il suffira pas que
quelqu'un signe un papier sur quelque
chose c'est pour ça que nous on était
opposé à ça et qu'on est opposé à cet
amendement il suffit pas que quelqu'un
signe quelque chose sur un papier si
vous voulez du respect réel il faut que
ce respect soit construit et pour
construire ce respect c'est c'est une
formule mais je pense qu'elle est assez
bonne pour être respecté il faut se
rendre respectable et en l'occurrence
sur ce sujet-là je pense que ce que
disait ma collect monsieur serva et
après on
[Musique]
votera comment allez rendez le micro à
Monsieur va monsieur ça allez-y oui je
soutiens l'amendement de la collègue
Youssouf ainsi que celui de Monsieur
Camarine moi bien écrit et il faut faire
attention chers collègues à ne pas
parler à la place de ceux qui
connaissent mieux que vous la
situation et ne pas généraliser des
grands principes qui ne s'appliquent pas
pragmatiquement au cas de Mayotte je
crois que la collègue yououfa vous
expliquz avec pédagogie et clarté le
fait que certains Comoriens et il faut
connaître donc l'histoire des Comor de
mayott pour pouvoir mieux en parler
remettre en cause le fait que Mayot soit
française et que ça n'est pas acceptable
dans notre République et donc il est
plus prudent chers collègues de vous
concentrer sur ce que vous connaissez
parfaitement et de laisser ceux qui
maîtrisent parfaitement les sujets
s'exprimer en toute clarteté objectivité
et
pédagogie alors je mets au voix
l'amendement 1107 parce que Monsieur
Dumond m'a informé du retrait du 6
exporteur qui ve pourend
deppor contre il est adopté et je vous
propose qu'on s'enenne là pour ce matin
jecie je vous rappelle qu'on se retrouve
ici à 14h30 dans la même salle
mer